the
anamatronic Sinister superhero
homelander who terrorizes the world of
the boys and in the comments we kept
seeing one name pop up omn man the
terrifying almost Unstoppable viltrumite
Warrior who scared the hell out of all
of us in invincible so we decided to run
a simulation to see if the SCP
Foundation could find the same success
battling this diabolical corrupted
Superman the video you're about to see
is that simulation enjoy and keep an eye
on the skies it was Unthinkable Panic
had spread throughout the foundation as
reports came in that several of the most
high-profile groups of Interest across
the globe had suffered unbearably brutal
attacks from an unknown as salent
notable among the groups targeted were
GOC Global occult Coalition as well as
its opposing organization the Serpent's
hand in all incidents key buildings
belonging to the groups were demolished
and the bodies of all leadership
Personnel were discovered beaten to a
pul these massacres appeared to send a
terrifying message whoever was behind
these attacks the foundation was most
likely next on The Chopping Block as all
containment sites prepared for the worst
it was site 17 that received subsequent
news on the matter in the most
unsettling way imaginable a small flying
object was discovered in the SES
airspace and retrieved by an MTF issue
helicopter the object appeared to be an
action figure of world-renowned
superhero omn man and it bore the
trademark of Dr Wonder tainment toys the
mobile task force that discovered the
action figure had been on such high
alert that the appearance of this toy
almost seemed comical there was uneasy
laughter within the helicopter which
immediately turned to silence when the
toy began to speak boys and girls for
the very first time Dr Wonder detainment
presents to you run run for your lives
obn man is coming for us all the toy
continued what was apparently a
pre-recorded voiceover which became
increasingly frightened and desperate as
it went along the contents of the
recording confirmed that the one
responsible for the devastation of the
other groups of Interest was none other
than omn man himself his reasons for
doing this were unknown but he seemed
adamant on wiping out all groups with
significant control over the planet its
anomalies whoever was in charge at Dr
wondertainment had uncovered the truth
shortly before omn man arrived to do the
same to their group and had deployed the
toy in a last Stitch effort to Warrant
the SCP Foundation it was an
uncharacteristically opaque gesture from
the terrible toy maker but the
foundation had little choice but to take
it seriously if Earth's most powerful
superhero had really gone Rogue and was
going after influential organizations in
some bid to eliminate competition the
the foundation would have to develop
appropriate countermeasures as soon as
possible the first priority was securing
the safety of the 05 Council who would
most likely be the intended victims of
omn man's Rampage fortunately their
current location was extremely
classified so rather than Shuffle to a
new location the council chose to stay
where they were a conspicuous relocation
process could inadvertently give the
game away especially if the apply named
ah reducted it just launch us into space
procedure was in effect omn man was
known for his space fairing capabilities
and was fully capable of pursuing and
boarding the 05 council's getaway
shuttle if such a thing was attempted
additionally there would be no movement
of forces to the location of the 05
Council mobile task forces that were
already in the field would be instructed
to immediately cease their current
Mission and focus on locating omn man
while the superhero was incredibly
dangerous it was Paramount that valuable
time was bought so that a better attack
plan could be formulated that was one
advantage that the foundation had over
most of the other groups of Interest the
reserves to prolong a war of attrition
no matter how strong the enemy was there
was also the matter of establishing
protections for Sight 17 since Wonder
tainment had sent the action figure
there of all places to deliver the
message it was likely that omn man would
be headed there first sight staff
requested the immediate transfer of the
infamous mobile task force tal 5 samsara
a unit of immortal cyborgs with
superhuman physiology while omn man was
known to have fought and defeated
everything from the spawn of ancient
gods to cyborgs to Immortals the four
members of samsara were all three and
had strength in numbers the request
remained pending for several minutes
causing one researcher to blly remark
that the 05 Council had probably called
dibs fearing that MTF to 5 wouldn't
arrive to intercept omn man the
researchers assessed which anomalies
contained on site would be best suited
to holding the the superhero back one
ker class SCP in particular immediately
came to mind SCP 451 a male humanoid
with the anomalous ability to create
extra-dimensional wormholes these
wormholes could be used to produce any
object that SCP 451 desired including
exceedingly unstable Cognito hazards
while SCP 40 51's Powers were certainly
formidable it was the fact that the
humanoid who went by the name reineer
Miller had previously been acting as a
vigilante in the United States in other
words rineer Miller was likely to be of
special interest to omn man even if that
interest merely amounted to having one
more Target to wipe out while it
wouldn't be the only humanoid SCP that
could be considered similar to a
superhero 451 was definitely the closest
at hand not too long after the
discussion took place the site Radars
began to pick up omn man closing in his
approach was extraordinarily fast
breaking through the sound barrier and
Landing with great force in the center
of site 17 there was no time to waste
and all available guards and mobile Task
Force personnel were ordered to zero in
on omn man's location and open fire as
one might expect bullets weren't exactly
effective against the superhero turned
serial killer but they did provide a
plausible distraction while the
researchers mobilized to find other
means of neutralizing omn man it was a
terrifying sight watching the costume
man stand there within a hail of bullets
bearing no outward signs of distress
aside from a Stern facial expression he
moved smoothly through the air towards
the nearest Soldier and shattered every
rib with a single punch he then grabbed
another and used him to bludgeon several
other agents even with the substantial
advantage and raw power there was a
considered tactical reason for each of
omn man's movements he systematically
made his way through the site crushing
all within his path with absolute
Prejudice there were going to be no
survivors if this this continued
fortunately one of the sight 17 other
contingencies was about to come into
play you see the foundation had done
their research and with the
corroboration of information from other
groups including the United States
government had deduced that omn man
might have psychological weaknesses that
could be exploited namely his teenage
son Mark otherwise known by his
superhero Alias Invincible while the
foundation was far too cautious to
directly contact Invincible mostly out
of fear that the boy could be in a
the next best thing could still stall
omn man and give the researchers a
chance to get SCP 451 ready for combat
it certainly took omn Man by surprise
when he was floating down one of the
newly blood soaked corridors and saw
Invincible standing at the end staring
him down Dad what's going on why are you
hurting them said what appeared to be
Mark omn man stopped in his place and
his expression changed to a look of
concern for the first time since he
arrived at site 17 omn man spoke Mark
come on dad this is crazy you should
stop this and go back home to Mom omn
man froed his brow something was off
here for one this version of invincible
had both feet on the ground even though
he would have all the same powers of his
father also the fact that Invincible had
an approach suggested that this
individual was in such fear of omn man
that it refused to approach omn man had
been caught off guard by this at first
worried that his son could be afraid of
him to this extent but it was starting
to seem suspicious Mark was no coward he
had become a superhero like his father
because he wanted to protect the world
from all manner of threats although the
difference in combat experience between
the two was vast omn man knew that the
Invincible he knew was Reckless enough
to challenge him or at least have this
conversation at a regular distance his
intuition was right on the money as this
was not Invincible at all but SCP 953
the polymorphic humanoid instead while
this ker class SCP was known for taking
many forms usually that of beautiful
women the foundation staff had given it
access all available information on
omnimind fatherson relationship and in
doing so successfully convinced it that
taking the form of omnimon was the best
path towards self-preservation during
this perilous scenario SCP 953 continued
to make attempts at talking to omn man
doing its best to remain still not
wanting to reveal the vulpine features
beneath the vincible costume it was
wearing but omn man proved to be too
clever for this Gambit he chuckled then
suddenly zoomed forward with his fist
raised in front of him SCP 953 flinched
in Terror only to find that omn man had
pulled his punch at first SCP 953 was
relieved to still be intact but this
soon dissipated as the humanoid looked
at omn man and found none of the
compassion that was on his face just
moments ago you're not Mark omn man said
he's stronger than this SCP 953 trembled
in fear the polymorphic humanoid only
had one card left to play and it prayed
that it worked 953 shape shifted again
this time into omn man's wife Debbie her
fox-like features were more pronounced
in this form but it was clear that the
site of his human partner's face made
omn man hesitant to attack this
hesitation was all the time that the
polymorphic humanoid needed to run away
as several guards and SCP 451 arrived to
take over the duty of stalling omn man
several wor holes opened up around omn
man deploying Sonic grenades which
stunned him for several seconds the
guards Unleashed all of their ammo and
Drew omn man's aggression while rineer
prepared his next weapon a wormhole to a
pocket Dimension filled with
flamethrowers which he directed at omn
man hoping to at least cause some
lasting pain if not proper burns the
Flames did temporarily obscure his
vision but that didn't hinder him for
long as omn men moved straight upwards
through the ceiling before descending
back down into the building massacring
the guards surrounding SCP 451 he looked
on reineer with disdain especially as
the humanoid opened a wormhole and
pulled out an aluminum baseball bat you
really think a piece of Earthling sports
equipment is going to do anything to me
omn man said it doesn't matter if it
does or doesn't reineer replied you're
not the hero you once were and someone
has to try to stop you omn man paused
reminded of his own son though mere
sentiment wouldn't be to spare rineer
Miller the fate of the rest of his
planet and its people but rir opened a
wormhole directly in front of himself
which contained multiple anti-tank
rifles that fired in omn man's Direction
the impact didn't phase omn man but it
slowed the superhero down just enough
for rineer to tuck and roll behind him
reineer reached into another Wormhole
for a gas mask which he quickly dawned
as another one of his wormholes
Unleashed deadly poison gas into the
corridor omn man held his breath and
flew towards rineer grabbing his
aluminum bat midswing and bending it
into an l-shape without any apparent
effort rineer let go of his weapon but
omn man quickly grabbed him by the wrist
and lifted him into the air before
slamming him down on the ground rineer
Miller SCP 451 was incapacitated perhaps
fatally before omn man could confirm his
kill he was tackled and immediately
thrown to the nearest wall by the
combined force of four individuals in
cybernetic Armor mobile task force to 5
samsara had arrived and together they
surrounded amyan and hid him with
everything they had punches and kicks
bombarded him from all angles offering
barely any window for a response the
formation didn't last long as omn man
withstood the hits and maneuvered behind
one of the members of samsara grabbing
and snapping the Cyborg's neck in one
quick motion one of its fellow members
swung for omn man's face only for him to
catch the blow and severely batter the
arm of the attacker rendering it
unusable omnimed the last two members by
the throats and squeezed until he heard
the familiar pop and cry crack then he
let their bodies fall of course this
wasn't enough to neutralize samsara
completely the cyborgs were down but not
out as their fast regeneration began to
fix their injuries with detached
contempt omn man stomped forcefully on
their heads shattering the skulls of
each member of samsara one by one that
should be a lot harder to fix omn man
thought to himself he was almost
finished here then it would be on to the
next containment site and eventually to
the 05 Council itself his plan Planet
wouldn't need metalsome groups like The
SCP Foundation made up of inferior
humans playing at civilization he made
sure they knew how powerless they were
before the rest of the people of filtrum
arrived to complete the conquest of
Earth he applauded the short-lived
bravery of rer Miller and in an
uncharacteristic moment of Mercy chose
not to go back and check if his previous
opponent had truly been killed omn man
rationalized that he had already
inflicted a killing blow but deep down
as he concluded his Rampage through
through sight 17 and departed for the
sight of his next Slaughter he knew that
he had subconsciously gave the boy a
chance to live that's right it's time
once again to activate the fame anaton
6000 our patented machine that
definitely wasn't developed in
affiliation with Dr Wonder tainment we
swear after recalibrating rebooting and
hitting restart our Infamous specialized
supercomputer is ready to bring you all
manner of improbable scenarios we'll
simulate encounters between the SCP
foundation's various anomalies and any
other character from any other Universe
you could possibly imagine here's a
question for you what do you think would
happen if scp096 the notorious shy guy
ran a foul of someone he couldn't just
kill for daring to look at it what if
the scourge of the underworld batt of
demons and the Devil Himself set his
sights on scp096 while we're about to
hit the button and discover the outcome
come of scp096 versus the dreaded Doom
Slayer so you've heard the old
philosophical debate about a tree
falling down in the woods and whether or
not nobody being around to hear it
brings into question if it actually
happened at all right well let's reframe
that one a little if an interdimensional
rip in the very fabric of the time space
continuum opens up in an SCP Foundation
secure facility and nobody is around to
witness it does a 6 tall 360 lb hulking
killing machine still emerged to
slaughter everything in his path it
turns out yes yes he definitely does
horrified scream and the loud bang of
shotgun blasts rang out through the
hallway as Foundation researchers ran
for their lives the Doom Marine had just
been unceremoniously dropped out of a
portal into a strange and unfamiliar
environment mere minutes earlier he had
been awakened inside a sarcophagus
within a facility on Mars in the year
2148 unfortunately Doom guy hadn't had
the best start to his day given that the
base he'd woken up in was being overrun
by the forces of Hell itself thanks to a
rogue scientist opening up portals to
the underworld and allowing all manner
of demonic Abominations to come pouring
through so naturally when another portal
brought the armor-clad Demon Slayer to a
site run by the SCP Foundation the
intensity of battle had led to the Dooms
Slayer believing that the unsuspecting
staff were actually all demons and
disguise and to him the only good Demon
is one he got to send back to hell in
the most brutal fashion imaginable he
wasn't going to stop until he torn
through wave after wave a foundation
Personnel thinking perhaps if he killed
enough he'd be returned to his previous
local for more demon killing as the
foundation dispatched its security
forces and mobile task forces to take
down the Unstoppable force of Carnage
stucked out in head to toe green armor
it seemed nothing they could throw at
the Doom Marine was enough to take him
down a hail of bullets rained down on
him from the mtfs weapons ricocheting
ineffectually off his protective plating
as he continued his assault remaining
tireless thanks to his immense physical
conditioning the SCP Foundation tried
and failed to contain Doom Guai they
assumed him to either be a new
undocumented anomaly or a violent and
unhinged Maniac from the church of the
broken God given his armor resembling
cybernetic augmentations and machine
parts grafted to his body along with his
arsenal of advanced Weaponry but there
were no enhancements no augmentations
made to the Dooms Slayer he may have
once been mortal but centuries of
killing demons had allowed him to
transcend ordinary human physiology he
did not Tire never lost strength never
needed to eat or drink and was near
enough Immortal yet among all the chaos
that was unfurling a solitary researcher
had just managed to slip out of the Doom
slayer's reach he ran as fast and far as
he was physically able the mobile task
force troops were getting eviscerated
and The Slayer could easily tear through
the whole Foundation then fleeing for
his life the researcher had an idea
either a stroke of Genius or total
idiocy and a risky move either way he
would send an anomaly on the Doom Slayer
he turned to the nearest containment
cell a window room with a heavy locked
door hurriedly inputting his security
clearance code the researcher heaved the
door open and covered his eyes with his
arm it wouldn't have been his first
choice of SCP to send into battle SC SCP
96's cell was the closest lumbering out
of its containment chamber on its
misshapen elongated legs scp096 scanned
the area alarms were blaring it was loud
and frightening to the timid albeit
terrifying creature it reached reached
up to cover its ears in bewilderment not
that the researcher who had freed it
could see what it was doing for one his
eyes were still covered and for another
he was already dead thanks to the Dooms
Slayer barging shoulder first through a
nearby wall and raining debris onto the
nearby researcher beneath the visor of
his helmet the Marine breathed heavily
panting but not tiring as he looked at
the pale skinny creature in the corridor
before him it was clutching the sides of
its head its huge jaw hung open
as far as the Slayer knew he was making
progress his attack was working he'd
killed enough of these demonic imposters
that they were starting to reveal their
true forms although in all his years of
Bloodshed and being a Scourge to the
Dennison of hell he hadn't quite ever
seen a demon that looked like the shy
guy not that it mattered to Doom guy
before long it'd be dead like all the
rest the Towering stick thin creature
turned to face the armor adorned Warrior
and shrieked immediately overc come with
anguish having a full-blown breakdown as
it often did whenever someone looked at
it as the demon killer stomped down the
corridor towards it the doomblade a long
Sleek razor sharp edge extended from the
slayer's compet where it was mounted on
his wrist he reached down and yanked the
rip cord on his chainsaw 2 he was long
overdue for a glory kill but before he
could strike at scp096 the shy guy moved
with impossible speed faster than even
the Doom Marine himself it zipped behind
the encroaching Marine moving quicker
than he could perceive 1 second scp096
was crying and wailing in front of him
then not even a full second later the
creature was towering over Doom guy from
behind scp096 gripped the Doom blade and
snapped it with ease like breaking a
twig before reaching its other long arm
down and pulling the chainsaw from Doom
guy's hand the motorized blade was still
running as it clattered to the ground
cutting a hole through the floor and
falling down into the lower level of the
facility enraged as he very often was
the doomslayer reached both arms back
behind his head and gripped the
elongated torso of scp096 the virtually
Immortal killing machine hurled the
creature over his head with ease thanks
of course to his immense strength Doom
guy could lift objects far heavier than
most ordinary humans and carry heavy
weapons without tiring he had even
grappled hand to hand with demons
throwing the shy guy down the corridor
like hurling a basketball was no trouble
for the space fairing slaughterer of
Satan's spawn screaming and Howling in
pain as CP 096 crashed to the ground at
the far end of the corridor tumbling
over itself thanks to its long limbs
before landing in a confused Heap as the
shy guy reoriented itself struggling
back onto its feet and standing up at
its full height it was instantly knocked
back down as the force of something
Struck it barring down on scp096 the
Doom machine charged his signature d
double barreled saw off shotgun drawn it
was hardly leaving a scratch on scp096
his pale skin despite the moderate
amount of damage the weapon was capable
of two shots would ring out reeling the
creature but not harming it then by the
time SCP 096 managed to recover from the
blast the Slayer had finished reloading
in time to open fire yet again even as
the Doom Slayer raced nearer closing the
distance between him and what he thought
to be another demon for him to kill the
shotguns seemed to have little effect
against the shy guy at close range
stowing the weapon Doom guy put all of
his focus and energy into his charge
heavy boots stomping against the ground
as he raced towards the shy guy still
stunned by the latest shotgun blast
before the creature could steady itself
this time it was struck by another force
a heavy object barreling towards it the
Dooms Slayer shoulder barged as CP 096
sending the pair of them crashing
through the nearest wall they burst into
a neighbor bring room with a Dooms
Slayer keeping a single armed grip
around the shy guy while repeatedly
delivering vicious punches to its gut
with his other hand not once relenting
scp096 screeched in pain clawing at the
Slayer but unable to tear through his
impenetrable armor as they crashed
through yet another wall scp096 did
something it rarely ever did in fact
maybe something it had never ever done
before it ran away from someone that had
looked at it while the creature was
deeply insecure and so self-conscious
that it would kill anyone who saw so
much as a photograph of it it didn't
often feel afraid but the Doom Slayer
this musclebound killing machine that
had brutally butchered actual demons was
so imposing so threatening and so
effective at dispensing painful
punishment that he scared the fight out
of scp096
sobbing with Terror the creature zipped
away using its anomalous speed trying
desperately to put his as much distance
between it and the Doom Marine as it
possibly could but therein lay the
problem no sooner had scp096 gotten away
from the scourge of hell then the
creature immediately felt the familiar
pull whether it was an inescapable
compulsion to kill everyone who looked
at it for the fact of the Shy Guy's
biology It could only distance itself
from the Slayer for a few seconds before
it reappeared next to him from the doomu
perspective it seemed like the creature
was intentionally disappearing and
reappearing using its teleportation like
speed to evade a volley of his attacks
scp096 came at him again stuck in a loop
of trying to attack the Dooms Slayer for
looking at it to immediately regretting
that course of action and fleeing in
fear of its hulking heavy weapon toing
Target Doom guy Drew every weapon he had
in his Arsenal launching a barrage of
high explosive ordinance from his rocket
launcher to try and kill scp096 the
resulting damage PR practically reduced
an entire wing of the foundation sight
to Rubble but still couldn't kill the
slayer's opponent meanwhile in the
moments that the shy guy temporarily
forgot his own fear for the Doom guy it
managed to rush towards him swiping the
marinees various technologically
advanced armaments out of his hands
before instantly remembering why he was
so scared of the green armored force of
Destruction and dashing away doomguy's
supply of weapons had all but depleted
neither he nor scp096 were getting tired
out by their constant back and forth
they were locked in a stalemate until
the shy guy tried to get back to its
cell zipping away once again it cowed in
the corner reaching for an old wornout
paper bag that had slipped over its head
it sat down trembling rocking Back in
Forth in a fetal position the shy guy
was terrified an overwhelming
debilitating fear gripped it fear that
became pure dread as the sound of heavy
boots began to stomp closer and closer
kicking the steel door off its hinges
the Dooms Slayer walked into scp096 cell
carrying something huge in his hands it
was one of the most devastating weapons
doomed guy had at his disposal capable
of unleashing Untold destruction The BFG
9,000 without remorse not caring that
the creature seemed to have retreated
and was caring away from him the Slayer
raised the powerful weapon and fired an
enormous ball of green energy the blast
engulfed the entire room tendrils
snaking out from the energy projectile
causing additional damage to the
surrounding area until there was nothing
left of scp096
here we are again with the
anamatronic computer that helps us
create hyper accurate simulations of
some of the world's most bizarre
scenarios whether it's scp096 versus
siren head AEL versus chainsaw man or
now perhaps our most ridiculous matchup
yet SCP 035 the Diabolical possessive
mask versus The Mask the popular Jim
Carrey character based on the
hyperviolet comic book of the same name
so what the heck are we waiting for
let's crank up the machine and see what
the results are somebody stop me okay so
what have we got on intake today
researcher wereb asked a tone of boredom
hanging off his every word uh possible
anomalous entity his compatriot Dr mne
replied sipping his coffee sounding
equally as unenthused Caucasian male
early 30s a team of our agents picked
him up in the foundation doctor checked
his notes some place called Edge City
real appealing tourist spot he added
sarcastically now what's so anomalous
about him worb questioned his eyes
lazily scanned over a file mcne had
handed him says here he's just an
ordinary bank teller there's one prior
arrest on his record but the charges
were dropped later on this guy's a
nobody apparently he was in possession
of an anomalous artifact came the
doctor's reply he looked through the
one-way glass into the interrogation
room sat at the table wearing a matching
pair of hideous pajamas was a wiry
brown-haired man what was it researcher
worb asked not bothering to check the
file a mask apparently mne replied this
thing can form a symbiotic connection
with whoever wears it this guy's had it
for a while it causes him to undergo a
dramatic intensification of his
personality when he puts it on as well
as granting himself some uh unusual
abilities hold on aren't you just
describing SCP 035 worb said looking
confused nope the doctor responded by
handing him a clear evidence bag in it
was a single wooden mask a dull darkish
green tint to the object it looked to be
almost Viking in its design with three
holes on its surface one for the mouth
and two for the eyes it was hard to deny
it was completely different from the
white porcelain of SCP
035 what what this guy's name again worb
side looking at the scruffy pajama clad
man waiting for them ipus his colleague
replied Stanley ipus meanwhile locked up
tight in a hermetically sealed glass
case was another anomalous mask SCP 035
was kept under lock and key by the
foundation guarded constantly by a pair
of armed security officers one of them
officer rert had noticed something
strange about the infamous possessive
mass today or Stranger than usual anyway
s cp035 was known to compel people to
wear it if they were close enough often
through subtle psychic Whispers but
today it seemed Restless almost agitated
like it found something nearby to be
intensely annoying I already told you
everything I know Stanley upus sighed
exhaustedly he'd been dragged out of bed
at the crack of dawn by strange agents
and was now being interrogated about
what he knew of the wooden mask he'd
come across floating in the river one
fateful night I don't know where it came
from I swear I didn't even realize I
still had it uh we threw it back in the
river but my dog must have swam out and
fetched it Stanley explained you have no
idea what this thing is not even from
any firsthand experience Mr episs Dr mne
asked holding the mask up look I did
take it to a psychologist who told me it
might be Scandinavian a representation
of some Norse night god Loki I think he
answered we're not interested in this
mask as a historical artpiece researcher
wereb retorted tell us what happens when
you put it on Stanley paused for a
moment clearly aware he was in real
trouble but nervous about coughing up
the details to his Shady captors with a
sigh he decided it was best to
confess I don't know how it works but
whenever you put it on it's like it
brings your deepest desires to life when
I wear that mask I can do anything be
anything he described remembering a key
detail but it only works at night Dr mne
and researcher worb exchanged looks and
un certain if ipkiss was just a lunatic
or if there was truth to what he was
telling them assemble a security team
mne side we'll arrange a safe
environment for you tonight Mr episs
elsewhere in the facility rert and his
fellow security officer Dugen was
watching over SCP 035 with growing
concern what do you reckon has this
thing so agitated Dugan wondered aloud
who knows rer sighed Avari reported it
to command told them 035 is in a mood
they said to proceed as normal suddenly
as the words left his mouth officer rard
felt strange it was like he had been
hooked by an overwhelming urge to put
the possessive mask on he barely noticed
he had reached to unlock the door
sealing the area where SCP 035 was
contained in its case and as he stepped
through officer Dugan's pleased for him
to stop barely registered the other
officer tried in vain to pull rard back
as he walked towards the possessive mask
only to feel his coworker grip his shirt
and swing him face first over and over
again into to the glass case containing
the anomalous object his body going
completely limp after being used to
break the glass rer dropped Dugan to the
floor too lost in his trans-like state
to realize he just killed a fellow
Foundation security officer he was too
focused on SCP 035 as he lifted it up
and placed it over his face meanwhile
Stanley ipkiss had been brought to a
testing area a team of security officers
standing around him the fact that they
were all armed did little to ease
Stanley's nerves Dr mney strowed up to
him pulling the green wooden mask out of
the airtight bag it had been sealed in
and handed it to Stanley now funny
business Mr episs the doctor warmed I
really can't promise that Stanley
replied he looked at the mask in his
hands noticed a green Shimmer over the
reverse side of it as much as he had
gladly given it up part of him had
missed wearing it he could already hear
the low rumbling of thunder outside as
he lifted it towards his face feeling it
almost leap out of his hand hands and
latch itself onto him the green mask
eagerly became attached to Stanley the
surface of it spreading out where it
covered his face and wrap around his
entire head around him the guards
cautiously stepped back as they watched
Stanley convulse and wrie around the
place uncontrollably like a man
possessed both researcher word and Dr
mne looked at each other in wordless
disbelief before turning back to the
scene unfolding Before Their Eyes the
booming noise of thunder and cracks of
lightning rang out despite this all
taking place indoors as Stanley ipkiss
vanished in the center of a miniature
tornado that spun wildly around the
testing area before slowing to a halt in
its place stood a maniacal wide-eyed
figure dressed in a garish yellow zoot
suit and wearing an enormous tooth grin
on his bright green face how do fellas
the mask bombastically hooted at the
guards having been trained to deal with
absurd anomalies of Plenty the security
Team all defensively raised their
weapons out of a mix of Instinct and
confusion is rough crowd The green-faced
Lunatic stated to nobody it looked like
he had turned aside as if addressing
some invisible audience outstretching
both arms and one leg The Mask instantly
zipped off hurling around the room in a
whirlwind of absurdity in the style of
an old Tech saory cartoon the spinning
cackling combination of Stanley ipus and
the Magical mask weaved in between the
foundation guards all of whom tried in
vain to restrain him until he
disappeared out of the door after him Dr
mne yelled with urgency in his voice the
guards all turned to run after the mask
only for each one of them to trip over
and land face first on the floor of the
testing area as if something had tied
them all up by their ankles it was only
after the security officers all
struggled back up to their feet that
they noticed their pants had been yanked
down leaving the foundation's finest
somewhat embarrassed to say the least
outside the testing area Stanley or
rather the mask had already closed the
door behind him out of nowhere he
produced a series of wooden planks and
began hammering them into the door frame
boarding it up before speedily adding
chains and padlocks to the mix sighing
and in an OV exaggerated manner wiping
the sweat from his brow he turned around
only to be met with the sight of even
more SCP Foundation guards lying in wait
their guns all trained on him the mask
gave a scream of pure Terror that
briefly sent his skull popping out of
his head and his eyes shooting out of
his skull before everything zipped right
back into its original place his eyes
Jed around at the faces of the
foundation security wondering how he was
going to get out of this one oh gee this
all seems familiar he said either to
himself or his audience well if it ain't
broken hit it in the blink of an eye the
mask's bright yellow outfit had
transformed replaced by a silk blue
Rumba shirt with ruffled sleeves white
pants and a wide brim black hat as they
watched him stood at the ready a few of
the guards noticed the sound of music
not one of of them could tell where it
was coming from nor could they help
starting to tap their feet or Bob their
heads to the rhythm of the Cuban Pete
RBA the entire security team quickly
erupted into a full-blown dance number
that anyone who saw it couldn't resist
joining all led by The Mask wildly
waving Maracas in the air and singing
elsewhere in the facility officer rert
was beginning to melt he still had SCP
035 covering his face the frown of the
possessive mask conveying the entity's
sheer discontent tent the black ooze
secreting from its porcelain surface had
the unfortunate effect of corroding and
melting down anyone that wore it
dissolving them entirely after a short
period of time determined SCP 035 pushed
on plotting its host towards a storage
room if it remembered correctly the SCP
Foundation had stored a number of
temporary hosts for it mannequins that
while not human had enough of a humanoid
shape for the possessive mask to use of
course after all of his its attempts to
escape the foundation had rescinded its
privilege to be granted new hosts not
that it could stop it from taking them
by force using the last of Officer
riger's dwindling strength SCP 035 bared
its way into the store room sure enough
waiting there for it was a row of
discarded mannequins lifting riger's
hands before they had fully melted away
the possessive mask used him to place
itself on a new body elsewhere not too
far away in the foundation facility a
congol of security officers and research
Personnel was parading through the
corridors all happily dancing and Jing
to the music despite still no one being
able to figure out where it was coming
from dashing away from his spot at the
front of the line the mask zipped around
a corner his clothes having changed back
to his signature brightly colored Zoot
Suit never say no to a party he
exclaimed after having danced his way to
Freedom the sound of something shuffling
closer quickly caught the mask's
attention he turned around to find
himself standing green face to porcelain
face with SCP
035 you the masked mannequin raised a
hollow arm pointing a finger from its
host at Stanley you be a god of
mischief's carving I could sense its
presence since you arrived still in my
look nobody likes a copycat fella The
Mask replied although intimidation is
the sincerest form of flattery and
that's how Jim K's career
started he added exploding with rash's
laughter CE you're prattling SCP 035
hissed with spite say perhaps we're
related The Mask ignored it oh we could
be long lost family you know I always
wanted kids of my own Son of the Mask
has a nice ring to it right he paused
once again turning away to his unseen
audience on second that maybe not the
SCP 035 controlled mannequin leapt
forward gripping the mask's arm causing
him to scream and shock at the advanced
his eyes bulged out of their sockets
zooming in on the corrosive black black
secretions oozing from SCP 035 the
mannequin's other hand started reaching
upwards gripping his oversized green
head as if it were trying to lift the
mask right off of Stanley's face zooming
away again he sped down the nearest
Corridor his arm stretching behind him
still clamped in SCP 0 35's grip coming
to a screeching halt with the comical
sound of car breakes The Mask wobbled
his outstretched arm a ripple traveled
all the way along the elongated limb as
if it was made of elastic his wrist
still being held by the mannequin
sporting the possessive mask the force
of the flailing rubbery arm was so great
that it flung SCP 035 is host body
around sending it head first into the
ceiling then plummeting back down to the
ground its grip loosened allowing the
mask to reel back its stretchy arm
although it didn't return to normal
length right away his own hand pinged
back and hit him in the face only to
start urgently trying to communicate of
its own accord what's that b Boy The
Mask said to his hand as it started
performing a series of signals little
Timmy stuck down a well you'd like a
Friday night off there's a two- bit
chump wearing another mask walking
menacing down the hall towards us the
hand suddenly turned the mask's head to
look in the right direction sure enough
SCP 035 was using the mannequin to walk
down the hall towards him his elongated
arm quickly returned to its normal size
as the green-faced lunatic took a quick
draw stance facing his oncoming
adversary now you have to ask yourself
one question he sneered doing a fairly
convincing impression of a green Clint
Eastwood do I feel lucky with a sweep of
his hand The Mask had drawn an enormous
weapon the thing was a gigantic mass of
different artillery clicking and worring
there were barrels on top of barrels
rockets and other explosives locked into
place do I feel lucky The Mask continued
well do you punk SCP 035 did nothing to
slow its advance so the mask pulled the
trigger every one of his weapon various
components spat out a tiny flag with the
word bang written on it ah performance
issue he said doing his aside once again
not that I'm overcompensating for
anything clearly growing agitated
piloting its host SCP 035 started
charging towards the mask immediately he
spun around becoming a tornado of
hyperactivity and whooping noises as he
sped down the adjacent Corridor the
possessive mask staggered after him the
US leaking from the porcelain anomaly
was Dripping onto the man wearing it
causing the plastic to be melted away
exposing the flimsy metal skeleton
beneath it knew it had to merge with a
new host find something else to corrupt
SCP 035 chased after the cartoonish
Troublemaker knowing that if it could
catch him he'd be able to survive
merging with it his body while wearing
the other mask barely obeyed the laws of
physics making him invulnerable to
damage and possibly even the corrosive
substance oozing from the possessive
mask as if those were enough reasons his
power seemed virtually Limitless
combined with a green-headed lunatic SCP
035 could do anything reaching a stop at
the end of another Corridor The Mask
spun around wearing a comically
undersized baseball uniform he reached
into his pocket and produced an
oversized baseball bat then proceeded to
start hurling baseballs into the air and
swatting them as hard as he could as the
mask increased the speed of his swings a
volley of hard cork baseballs were fired
down the corridor like a barrage of
bullets ricocheting off the walls and
hitting the oncoming SCP 035 each one
struck its Target reeling the mannequin
but doing little much else to stop it
getting closer and closer until With An
Almighty swing The Mask brought his Bat
crashing into SC SCP 035 with enough
Force to send the possessive mask and
its host kening down the corridor it
sailed through the air bursting through
a wall then flew into a research lab
tearing a huge hole in the next wall as
it kept going finally it came crashing
out of the last wall the outer wall of
the facility and dropped multiple
stories to the ground outside changing
costumes back to his classic suit and
dashing after SCP 035 The Mask passed
through all the holes his adversary had
left in the multiple walls it had
crashed into he screeched to a halt
again and paused after getting through
the outer wall only to realize after a
moment that he was hovering in midair
not standing on anything reaching into
his suit pocket The Mask pulled out a
sign on a stick with a single word
written on it yikes he plummeted down to
ground level Landing with such an
immense crash that his body cracked into
the asphalt below it left a perfect
outline of him imprinted in the ground
causing the mask to go completely
pancake flat head to toe suddenly before
he could peel himself up off the ground
and go back to being three-dimensional
SCP 035 staggered to its host's feet and
pinned The Mask down finally it growled
I've caught you I've won your power is
mine once I've combined with you I will
be able to ravage this world I'm going
to fuse to your face then I'll start
with decimating those wretches that
imprison me the foundation will fall and
then so will the rest of their precious
World forcefully the mannequin's hand
wrenched the mask off the ground but as
SCP 035 turned to look at what it had
hoped to be its next host well let's
just say the tragedy frown carved into
its porcelain face had never been more
appropriate it wasn't holding the mask
it was holding a life-size cardboard
cutout of a photo of the Mask grinning
out from one side enraged the possessive
mask tore the decoy in half with its
mannequin's hands hey puko said a
cartoonish voice from right behind it
did you miss me the mask had reappeared
for real this time grinning with his
huge teeth clearly getting a kick out of
having someone to torment SCP 035 on the
other hand had been getting increasingly
irritated by all the wacky cartoon
Antics with all the aggression it could
Channel through its mannequin host had
gripped The Mask by the throat his eyes
bulging out of his head again J no need
to get all choked up over it he gagged
you are so tiresome the possessive mask
yelled having finally run out of
patience you know what I won't merge
with you I should just kill you and put
an end to your buffoonery let me take
this thing off you first though it's
mannequin finger started to hook into
the mask seam at the back of his bald
green head wait wait the mask begged
putting up both his hands in surrender
at least give me a final request huh
Master mask before the possessive mask
could respond the mask had swept it off
its dissolving mannequin feet he started
to spin it around in a wild over-the-top
dance number bopping and Swinging to a
tune that seemed to be coming from
nowhere the longer it went on for the
more and more of SCP 035 host's body
started to dissolve away until the
mannequin finally wasted away all that
was left was a bubbling pile of black
goo on the ground with the possessive
mask laying in the middle The Mask
chuckled noticing the fumes trailing
upwards into the air as the corrosive
substance melted away the last of SCP
035 host talk about
smoking what's up Gamers hello there
everyone my name's SCP explained a lot
of SCP fans have played the free
survival horror game SCP containment
breach the game story play es the player
in the shoes of a d-class at one of the
foundation's containment sites as they
try their best to survive a massive
catastrophic Containment Breach many
players including some of our viewers
feel as if the simulated experience has
given them the tools they would need to
survive a real life Containment Breach
but can playing a video game really be
sufficient training for encountering
some of the deadliest scps in
containment and escaping with your life
in order to answer this question we're
going to speculate based on one of the
games most most prolific players famous
YouTuber and gamer Markiplier if playing
this game counts as training then
Markiplier has enough hours log to be a
Bonafide expert in facing off against
the many dangerous anomalies at the SCP
Foundation so kick back crack open some
G Fuel and let's see if Markiplier lives
to game another day to set the scene
let's all imagine that somehow through a
hick up in time and space or by some
sort of wish on a cursed monkey's paw
Markiplier found himself inside of an
SCP Foundation containment site that
would be bad enough but the blaring
alarms and sounds of chaos signal that
he arrived at the worst possible time
during a containment breach the security
systems are down the cells are open and
danger lurks around every corner armed
with nothing but his wits and winning
personality the only thing he can do is
try to navigate the facility as
carefully as possible remember
everything he's learned from his time
streaming the video game version of this
place and hope he can escape with his
life let's start with one we know he'd
be well equipped to face SCP 173 the
next snapping sculpture is the main
antagonist of SCP Containment Breach so
Markiplier would be familiar with the
necessary precautions to avoid winding
up as its next victim if he happened to
walk into a room and spot the figure
Frozen in his gaze he would know to keep
his eyes on the sculpture no matter what
and slowly back out of the room without
blinking Plus with all of the time he
spends looking at screens he's
definitely used to keeping his eyes on
one thing for a long period of time
congratulations Mark you survived that
one he's managed to get away from SCP
173 with his neck still intact hooray
but as he sneaks through the hall trying
not to draw any unwanted attention a
French accented voice breaks the silence
behind him good evening my fine fellow
are you feeling quite well there behind
him is SCP 049 the pl doctor in all of
his beak masked black robed glory you
look feverish please allow me to
administer some simple tests in this
scenario mark would have to think fast
and use some of that patented Markiplier
charm to get himself out of a
potentially sticky situation before one
of those gloved hands can touch him he
would need to politely excuse himself
insist that he just saw his doctor
earlier that day and then before the
plague doctor can take another step
closer run as fast as he possibly could
in the opposite direction as Markiplier
stops to catch his breath having thrown
the plague doctor off of his Trail the
sound of sobbing in the corner signals
that he might have just escaped the
proverbial frying pan only to wind up in
the fire a quick cursory glance up and
the sight of a long limbed pale humanoid
form would confirm his suspicions yes
yes indeed he's found himself alone with
a CP 096 the shy guy remembering the
details of this particular anomaly from
the game he he would look back down at
the ground immediately making sure not
to Glimpse the creature's face as long
as he avoided looking at its face he
would stay in the corner of the room
scarcely even acknowledging him then he
would be free to make a Mad Dash for the
exit all the while as scp096 would stay
hunched over crying and completely aware
it was briefly in the presence of a
beloved YouTube personality things might
be going pretty well for Markiplier so
far but uhoh what's that sound the
Slither of tentacles on tile the
thumping of a large heart and the
murmuring voice of an elderly Englishman
poor marip bler video games definitely
wouldn't have prepared him for the
arrival of SCP 058 the Heart of Darkness
it's come out of its cage and it's doing
just fine but the same can't be said for
any living thing that this creepy
animate and highly hostile creature
encounters endless suffering is the woe
of ignorant men who never lack to see
the depth of their own hearts and only
see the wealth of a poor World suffering
of silver and brutal gladness the heart
Whispers as it scuttles towards the
hapless YouTuber without much prior
knowledge of the anomaly mark would be
thoroughly unprepared for any encounter
with it he would likely fall victim to
its Spike tentacles or the sharp stinger
and any attempt to physically fight it
off would be ineffective due to the
anomaly's resilience to physical attacks
we don't need to get into the details of
how that specifically might end and it
would be a bit tasteless but there are
friendly anomalies that marip might
stumble upon too suppose instead of
suffering an untimely end at the
tentacles of a heart monster that speaks
in creepy atmospheric gibberish he found
himself face to face with SCP 073 cane
it would be a nice reprieve to be sure
as C is generally Pleasant and congenial
to any humans he needs you never know he
might even be a fan of Mark's Work the
same can't be said for Kane's
counterpart as SCP 076 however it's
nothing personal AEL feels murderous
rage towards any and all human beings
but it's hard not to take it personally
when you see Abel running at you at full
speed brandishing a massive sword that's
poised to take your head off with one
swing if Markiplier faced Abel on his
own he would unfortunately not stand
much of a chance again it's nothing
personal he's a super powerful ancient
warrior with a taste for Bloodshed if
Kan was in the vicinity however then he
might just be able to Escape unscathed
Kane is one of the few anomalies that
can easily oppose AEL as any damage AEL
manages to do to him will only effect
able so the best case scenario for Mark
would be to let the two Immortals go at
it while he sneaks away quietly after
all the stress of navigating the
containment site Markiplier would
probably really need some cheering up
after all his entire sense of reality is
crumbling around him at a rapid Pace
good news because as CP 999 can always
sense when someone nearby by needs that
frown turned upside down the Tickle
Monster doesn't appear in the
Containment Breach game so Mark might
not know what to expect when he sees a
large mass of bright orange slime oozing
toward him at a rapid Pace but once SCP
999 wrapped him in a big hug and its
natural mood boosting properties kicked
in he would know that this particular
creature is friend not foe he would give
the slimy visitor some affectionate Pats
and the Tickle Monster would coup
happily in return SCP 999 might try to
follow follow Markiplier down the hall
but he would insist it stay where it is
needed helping the various humans and
anomalies of the foundation when they
need a little bit of sweetness and light
in their lives then the two would part
ways each with their spirits lifted and
with fond memories of their new friend
that would last a lifetime but you can
never let your guard down at the SCP
Foundation not even for a second as
you're enjoying a hug from everyone's
favorite happy slime Creature if you
relax and forget to keep your wits about
you you might not notice the the wall
behind you starting to warp and melt as
something horrible reaches through it
from a dark place outside space and time
if Markiplier turned around to find
himself face to face with the cold dead
eyes of
scp-106 the old man what would happen
next the rotten old man appears in
Containment Breach so mark would know
exactly how bad things can get if this
ominous octogenarian gets his decaying
hands on him he would also know that
doors walls and other solid object are
not enough to deter this entity once he
sets his sights on taking you it is
possible that Mark could run could stay
out of the old man's sight until the
creature gets bored or finds some other
more convenient prey to snatch up but
it's more than likely that SCP 106 would
be excited by the Chase and would
Delight in the fear and pain that he is
causing unlike in Containment Breach
where SCP 106's movements can be
predicted the real thing is far more
crafty and malicious and there's no
starting over if the old man and catches
up to you in the real world
unfortunately Markiplier would likely
find himself pulled through the wall and
into the entity's layer where only Doom
would be waiting how might Markiplier
fare against another prominent character
in Containment Breach though say one
very tricky possessive mask thankfully
his experience with the game would have
taught Mark in advance that SCP 035
cannot be trusted under any
circumstances however the mask in the
game is at least a little bit help
offering valuable information about
navigating the containment site and even
providing insight into other threats to
the player's safety the real thing is
nowhere near as generous it has no
desire to help humans or anyone but
itself really if it wound up in the same
room as Markiplier it would only have
one goal and one goal only get him to
take it out of its case and put it over
his face hopefully Markiplier would know
better than to wear the wicked porcelain
mask but its psychic influence is strong
we couldn't blame him if he wound up
succumbing to it putting it on and
becoming the mask's newest human host it
would be thrilled to have found such a
famous body to take over two who would
pilot Markiplier out of the containment
site take him back home and become the
first SCP with over 1 million YouTube
subscribers aside from this channel of
course I shuddered to think what SCP 035
would do with such a massive platform it
definitely wouldn't be anything good now
there aren't just anomalies at the
foundation
there are lots of Staff members working
to keep the well-oiled machine running
smoothly of course some are better at
this than others and some staff are just
agents of chaos all on their own but
that makes life more fun Imagine a team
up between the most fun-loving meable
researcher at the SCP Foundation and
markiplier that's right Dr Jack brigh
himself now many people don't know this
but Dr brgh is a big fan of gaming
YouTubers and has wanted to start a
Channel of his own for quite some time
the foundation won't allow him to run
any of his own social media concerned
about the potential for secure
information leaking to the public but a
chance encounter with one of his
favorite YouTube creators would be just
the kind of opportunity Dr brigh has
been waiting for sure Markiplier might
be caught a bit off guard by a strange
man in an ambulet asking him to collab
but Dr Brit's big personality sense of
humor and high energy would make him a
great guest to have on the channel at
least until he finds something else to
distract him from his own existential
dread and abandons his streaming dreams
for that he definitely get Markiplier to
autograph The Amulet first though that's
for sure lots of people love Markiplier
he's a congenial guy with a passion for
making enjoyable content but there's one
anomaly at the foundation that wouldn't
like him at all in fact it would find
him frankly
disgusting but that's not his fault SCP
682 hates all living things that's kind
of its whole deal well that and being
impossible to kill the massive revill
reptile is incredibly dangerous to
anything and anyone it encounters and
sadly Markiplier would be no exception
this creature doesn't care about
likeability or how much a person has
contributed to contemporary internet
culture it only cares about destruction
about snapping the poor YouTuber up in
its jaws or knocking him into the wall
with one swash of its enormous taale
unless Markiplier happened to have a
spare nuclear warhead on him it's not
likely that he would make get out of
meeting with SCP 682 in one piece oh no
not his head wait is that The Bite of 87
sorry I had to do it for the mem
speaking of 87 however how would
Markiplier fair if he stumbled upon SCP
087 the stairwell it's not the likeliest
of events seeing as the doorway leading
to it is constructed of reinforced steel
with an electro release lock and is
disguised as the entrance to a Janitor's
Closet in an undisclosed building but in
this world stranger things have happened
happened Markiplier has played more than
enough horror games to know that finding
yourself in a dark staircase that seems
to go on forever where you can hear the
distant cries of a distressed child
isn't something anyone would ever want
he could try and descend the staircase
looking for a way out but if he did all
that would await him is creeping dread
and paranoia and an encounter with the
frightening face of SCP
87-1 his best hope in this scenario
would be to take a seat at the top of
the stairs and wait for his loyal family
based to notice he hasn't been online
for a while the internet is a powerful
thing and it's possible they could track
him down and rescue him before things
got too dire otherwise well best not to
think about that over the span of their
careers many online personalities and
digital content creators have found
themselves in need of a Rebrand maybe
they decide to make a new type of
creative work maybe they wind up at the
center of a scandal or maybe they just
got bored of doing the same thing over
and over again again if Markiplier ever
decided to change things up there are
dozens of ways he could go about it but
there's one that he would need to visit
the SCP Foundation for it wouldn't be
necessarily advisable but what if
Markiplier decided to engage in some
anomalous self improvement using SCP 914
the Clockworks using live test subjects
with this machine is always a bit dicey
and he would need to be extremely
careful about what setting he used the
very fine setting could produce some
really exciting results maybe it would
improve his eyesight or give him the
ability to work long hours without
experiencing Creator burnout maybe it
would give him the ability to fly or to
spontaneously generate a Wi-Fi hotspot
no matter where he was or how little
phone signal he had maybe it would make
him the greatest gamer in the world
there's really only one reason to find
out just make sure to hit the right
button or several million people would
be very very sad speaking of
self-improvement what would happen if
Markiplier got his hands on an anomalous
computer program not one of the
Dangerous Ones but an educational one
intended to help children learn new
skills SCP 1594 Miss J's whiz kid
Schoolhouse would be a perfect fit he'd
have to find a way to play it on his
computer but once he did Markiplier
could live stream his experience with
the software it's uncertain how the
anomalous effect of SCP 1594 would
translate into a massive audience but it
would be amazing to see if thousands of
people could learn a new skill at once
it would be potentially life-changing
for everyone involved speaking of
helpful anomalies Markiplier would
greatly benefit from an introduction to
SCP 662 the butler's handbell running a
YouTube channel takes a ton of work and
having an eager Supernatural assistant
on call 24 hours a day would probably
really improve the quality of life for
everyone involved Mr Deeds would be
happy to assist with whatever day-to-day
tasks might come up and could even
become a beloved background character on
the channel whether it's bringing Mark a
bag of Takis or helping edit video
footage there's very little this helpful
British Butler can't do when you get
famous and successful and when you
become a public figure online it seems
like everyone out there wants a piece of
you people want money attention to ride
someone's coattails to fame but what
about an anomaly that quite literally
wants a piece of Markiplier or any
person really SCP 082 Ferdinand the
cannibal would love to meet Markiplier
and would love to make Markiplier his
meat he would probably use his habit for
lying and spinning elaborate stories to
attempt to entice Mark into a dangerous
situation hello Markiplier it's me your
friend Jack sethy he would say while
very visibly not being who he claims to
be it's time to film a new video
challenge see how long you can stay in
the Soup pot just hop in the pot of
boiling water don't mind me cutting up
carrots and onions into it as long as
Mark keeps his wits about him and
doesn't fall for the extremely obvious
lies he would likely escape this
confrontation without ending up in a
YouTuber stew Markiplier is somewhat
familiar with the layout of the SCP
Foundation containment site thanks to
the gameplay of containment breach but
what if after freeing himself from one
anomalous nightmare he stumbled into
another one alt together what if months
after his inexplicable teleportation
into the containment site after life was
starting to get back to normal he was in
the market for a brand new gaming chair
and what if he decided to prioritize
convenience and Scandinavian furniture
Engineering in his selection process and
what if on top of all of that he had a
craving for some Swedish meatballs
consumed in a public food court why all
of those factors might just lead him to
Ikea and while there are hundreds of
Ikeas around the country it's not
impossible that he might just pick the
wrong one and find himself lost inside
of SCP 3 2008 Markiplier is a fairly
observant guy so it likely wouldn't take
him long long to notice that something
is a bit off inside of this particular
retail store there wouldn't be any other
Shoppers around him the Isles would go
on forever and the employees inside
wouldn't have faces that last one would
probably be the biggest giveaway
unfortunately once someone is inside the
infinite Ikea it's pretty unlikely that
they will ever leave he would give it a
noble effort to be sure exploring his
surroundings and finding the best places
to hide from the Ikea staff when the
lights go out if his phone is fully
charged he might even be the first
person to live stream from the depths of
this anomalous furniture outlet and
spread the word to his fans about the
existence of SCP 3008 but sadly that
stream would probably wind up being his
last unless he somehow figured out a way
to recreate his YouTube setup inside of
his strange new home if he did though
that would be pretty cool almost cool
enough to make up for the fact that he
would never see any of his friends or
family ever again fortunately for
everyone involved it's highly unlikely
that Markiplier will end up interacting
with any SCP anomalies without the safe
barrier of a computer monitor in between
them but just in case reality ever bends
in on itself and worlds begin to collide
hopefully Mark will remember everything
he's learned and to anyone who's ever
told you otherwise see playing video
games can help you in the real world it
might even save your life good grief
said joto Kujo as he his grandfather
Joseph joar and the rest of their Allied
group of St users hid from the light of
day in the shadows of a ruined building
outside amorphous semi-humanoid
monstrosities roam free In Search of
Life how could this have happened jro's
family had been on some Bizarre
Adventures but this one was proving to
be the most bizarre of all the sun now
designated SCP 001 was burning with
intense bright red light and an
anomalous level of heat it beat down on
the world below like an evil and
sadistic god of the desert the entire
world was at the mercy of these
oppressive solar rays and high
temperatures were just the beginning
from the looks of it any living thing
exposed to the Rays of SCP 001 would
quickly dissolve into a horrible gooey
substance that would ooze towards other
organisms in an attempt to absorb them
into its biomass basically it was like a
zombie apocalypse straight out of an
easy bake oven the Stardust Crusaders
had been passing through this city on
their Globe trotting Adventure only to
find that morning had brought with it a
disaster the likes of which had never
been seen before by midafternoon when
the sun was highest in the sky most of
the people had already been converted
into slime monsters and those who fled
into the Shadows found themselves
relentlessly hunted down and absorbed
only the stand users of jotoro group who
were already on the lookout for strange
happenings had been clever enough to
pick up on the situation immediately
they had been the subject of many
unusual Supernatural attacks over the
course of their Journey so the initial
anomalous effects of SCP 001 seemed to
be another routine brush with an enemy
hey Juro this has to be the effect of an
enemy stand right Joseph said what are
you stupid or something old man spat
Jean Pierre ponre the Frenchman was ever
the impulsive one and he always found
something to complain about when a woman
wasn't present he was selectively polite
one might say it was fitting given the
fact that his stand silver Chariot took
the form of a sword wielding Knight and
its reaction speed was the fastest of
any of the Stardust Crusaders you think
one stand could do all this P was
adamant about making his point Joto's
fellow High School classmate noriaki
kakoen was the next to speak pner keep
your voice down we can't be sure it's
not a stand but either way those flesh
monsters are looking for us kakon was
younger than pner pretended to carry
himself with more composure this likely
had something to do with the fact that
herent green was the group's most
technical stand and often used for
reconnaissance what do you think avidol
kakan continued you're the expert here
Muhammad abdol a fortune teller who
possessed a stand that controls fire
magicians R was often knowledgeable
about the supernatural a stand this
powerful would have to be limited in the
range it could AFF avdol said what we
have to do is get further away from this
area then we'll see if the Str sunlight
Fades but what if the user is following
us Joseph interjected how will we know
we aren't putting more people at risk Mr
joar we can win this battle without more
information abdol replied kakun your
hant green has the longest range send it
to scout for a place outside of the
stand's reach our stand shouldn't be
visible to those transformed humans and
the heat from the sunlight won't affect
something without mass friendly reminder
to those of you at home unfamiliar with
the properties of stands stands are
spectral entities formed from the soul
of the user and are essentially
superpowered ghosts without physical
presence as such they won't be affected
by SCP 001 the way a living thing would
now back to this Bizarre Adventure right
kakun nodded heroin green kakun summoned
his stand and began threading heroin
Green's long stretchy body throughout
the ruins as far as it could go the
young man concentrated Looking Through
The Eyes of his stand as kakun and his
stand search for the end of the
anomalous effects of SCP 001 pner
continued to complain as usual so we're
still not sure what's going on but from
what I've heard you're already calling
it a stand did I get that right afol PF
grumbled do you have any better ideas PF
abdol said sternly Iggy barked Iggy the
last member of the Stardust Crusaders he
was a Boston Terrier who commanded a
sand manipulating stand known as the
fool Iggy didn't really have much to add
to the conversation but he liked to be
heard listen said Joseph joar when I was
a younger man I actually did go
head-to-head with some terrifying beings
who might be able to turn people into
monsters like these but every single
time the sun was the enemy of those guys
nobody is interested in hearing your
stories right now old man jotoro chided
his grandfather meanwhile far from where
the Stardust Crusaders were hiding out
heren green was reaching the limits of
its effective range and seeing no sign
of an end to the anomalous effects kakan
was baffled could it be true that the
entire world had been affected by the
frightening ability of the sun now that
it was as SCP 001 if that was true then
the apocalyptic Wasteland was more than
just the work of an enemy stand user
this would mean that the son itself had
become the enemy of all life kakun
wondered about his family back in Japan
would they manage to survive this
terrible catastrophe he couldn't help
but hope that there was some way out of
this utter devast station even though
the information gathered by a stand told
him otherwise kakon withdrew hant green
and brought his companions up to speed
however hard it was to accept the world
as they knew it was Gone with the
Daybreak P was beside himself in sadness
while avdol and Joseph exchanged a
meaningful glance for once Iggy's bad
attitude subsided and the dog simply
whispered only joto remained determined
to carry on good grief would you all get
a hold of yourself
jotoro said we'll remain human as long
as we aren't caught in that light so
I'll use star Platinum to Tunnel our way
underground jotoro star Platinum was a
short-range stand but in terms of raw
power it was off the charts its punches
could easily tunnel through solid rock
and create a Subterranean passageway for
the Crusaders to retreat to a safer area
that a boy joro Joseph exclaimed we'll
make our daring Escape mole style joto
nodded and called star Platinum shouting
its signature battlecry of or or Star
Platinum smashed through the earth below
instantly creating the entrance to a
tunnel at that exact moment every flesh
monster in the nearby vicinity turned
its attention towards the sound the
stand users had to move quickly because
they would soon be completely surrounded
oh my God shouted Joseph in his usual
way as a couple of Flesh monsters began
to enter the ruined building luckily
pner and avdal sprung into action and
summoned silver Chariot and magicians
red to fend off the flesh zombies silver
Chariot delivered an inescapably fast
Fury of Sword strikes to one of the
monsters while magician's red burned
them away with its Supernatural Flames
the two men high fived at a job well
done just then the wall next to them
burst open revealing a new monster and
caused the sun's Rays to enter into the
building's interior with split-second
intuition avdal pushed P further into
the shadow Shadows the Frenchman tumbled
backwards into the hole jotoro made and
before he could get his bearings he
caught a glimpse of abdol being absorbed
into the monster's Mass abdol he cried
out but it was too late avdal was
already starting to show signs of
transformation into an ooike zombie
himself the fortune teller breathed in
deep and called the name of his stand
with determined fervor magician's red
before abdal could be fully taken by the
slime he unleashed the totality of his
Firepower on every zombified life form
within range its destructive heat
enhanced by the dryness of the
atmosphere abdal turned back to his
friends and gave them a heartfelt thumbs
up before he disappeared into the Flames
pner cried out for his friend again with
tears in his eyes but Ken and Joseph
grabbed him and made their way deeper
into the tunnel as badass and heroic as
it was abdol sacrifice wouldn't keep
those hordes of monsters at Bay for long
while kaken and Joseph dragged across
fly p through the underground Escape
Route J and igy were already at the
front of the group using a combination
of star platinum's digging ability and
Iggy sand manipulation to stabilize the
tunnel the Stardust Crusaders were deep
beneath the surface of the Earth now so
a caveen could be a real problem we have
to go back P shrieked adol needs our
help it's too late PF Joseph said with
grim conviction abdol is gone we we
don't know that for sure P carried on
let me go but kakin and Joseph held on
to P tightly and continued to drag him
down the passageway hoping not to lose
him to this daytime nightmare as well on
the inside jotoro was shaken by the loss
of one of his companions but nobody
would have been able to tell by looking
at his stoic exterior he was solely
focused on keeping the tunnel expanding
so that he and the remaining Crusaders
could survive this ordeal together
suddenly a noise from the opposite end
of the passageway put the group on high
alert like a flood of liquefied horror
the flesh monsters had begun pouring
themselves into the pit and were now
moving towards the group inch by inch oh
no Joseph shouted he loosened his grip
on PF and both of them immediately
booked it towards jotoro and Iggy kakin
however stood in place and braced
himself he didn't like it but he knew
what he had to do right now his stand
had the ability to stop these things but
first he had to slow them down down
Emerald Splash kakun shouted prompting
heroin green to launch a stream of
concussive green gemstones from its
hands as planned the attack slowed the
Slime monsters down kin was then able to
put the second part of his plan into
effect he identified what appeared to be
a face on the monster in front and sent
hant green to make its way inside the
creature's body this was his stand's
most terrifying ability and one cockin
seldom used heroin green had the power
to control contr the bodies of other
physical entities from within once his
stand had established control kin forced
the massive ooze to stop in place
instantly plugging the tunnel and
preventing the rest of the monsters from
getting any closer how long could he
keep this up he didn't know but because
of heroin Green's properties as a remote
stand cun was able to run and rejoin
jotoro and the others at the front of
the tunnel the tether between himself
and his stand was stretching farther by
the minute but he dared not let his
control of the oozing entity slip lest
he and his companions suffer the same
fate as avdol before long jotoro felt a
different sort of surface at the front
of the tunnel rather than Earth it was
brick with one punch from Star Platinum
he smashed through and into what
appeared to be an abandoned subway
station the power was still on though
most of the lights had faded it was
fortunate that there was no natural
sunlight in this place as everyone's
eyes adjusted to the light the stand
users crossed the tracks and made their
way onto the somewhat safer area pner
drifted over to the magazine kiosk
searching for signs of anyone behind the
counter there was nobody here and Iggy
soon helped himself to some of the
coffee flavored chewing gum at the
concession stand the dog couldn't resist
his favorite snack after all jro stood
by the tracks as if Waiting for a Train
while cockin did his best to maintain
his hold on the monsters further behind
them in the tunnel with a bit of
searching Joseph found a large port
music player designed for CDs also known
as a boom box with the use of his
divination Focus stand hermit purple
Joseph created purple thorny Vines which
weave their way into the wires of the
device and generated a psychic message
hermit purple could usually be counted
on to provide more detail about a
situation but its powers were limited by
the device used to gain the information
in this case the CD within the boom box
had a copy of the Beatles famous 1969
album Abby Rome mode so hermit purple's
message to Joseph came out as a garbled
but oddly appropriate rearrangement of
the lyrics to Here Comes the Sun little
darling I see their faces slowly
melting little darling it seems like
years since it's been all right here
comes the
[Music]
sun Here Comes the Sun and I say
I feel I've been slowly
melting sun sun sun here it comes oh my
God Joseph said to himself quietly just
then kakin felt the body that heroen
green was controlling give way
apparently the pressure of so many other
ooze monsters had been too much for it
to hold back and now these things were
barreling down the tunnel towards the
Crusaders rather than pulling heroin
green back completely kakun Unleashed
his Emeral Splash over and over again in
an attempt to force a cave in but the
creatures were too resilient and their
ooike structures meant they could
squeeze past mere rocks in their path
kakin told the rest of the group that it
was time to leave and as if On Queue a
train began to pull into the station
unfortunately the crazy train pulled
into the station with several Cars full
of oo zombies ready to grab the poor
team and dragg them into the sun there
was no way out but up the stairs back
into the sunlight they had done
everything possible to escape from as PF
joto Joseph and Iggy did their best to
fend off the attacking creatures using
their stands kakin made one last ditch
attempt to contain the monsters he
stretched hin green down to its most
basic form a series of long green
fibrous strings and created a net to ens
snare the creatures while the uses could
still seep its way through its wiry form
kakin rigged his stand to set off an
emerald Splash on every bit of anomalous
goo that made it pass the Net's defenses
it was a sustainable and effective wall
against the monsters using both the
tensile strength of the stand and its
energy attacks to effectively stimy
their progress there was only one
problem in order to maintain this
Perfect Defense kakun would have to stay
behind I'll hold them go on without me
kakun said Kaki Owen Joseph shouted as
the rest of them ran as fast as they
could out of the subway having
effectively lost two members of the
group The Stardust Crusaders were low in
spirits looking up through the subway
exit they could see that they would soon
be in contact with the sunlight meaning
that even their survival would become
unlikely but jot wasn't about to give in
he grabbed Iggy and held the dog out in
front of him all right Iggy it's now or
never either show us you can be a team
player or be the first to turn into one
of those blob Monsters Iggy struggled in
jro's grip but to no avail the dog knew
that jotoro was serious so in an act of
self-preservation that was unusually
generous of him Iggy used the fool to
stir up the sand on the ground above
into a gigantic Shady sand Dome moments
later he compressed it into a compact
Fortress of sand Iggy's Moving Castle as
it were no light could enter this
Fortress but because of the granular
nature of sand oxygen was flowing freely
the Stardust Crusaders now had a method
of train travel in this world torn apart
by SC SCP 001 of course there was still
the matter of dealing with the flesh
creatures outside even if the Fortress
of sand could move across the surface
without sunlight getting in the
surrounding ooes could still impede its
progress with the help of all three of
jotoro Joseph and pner stands a solution
soon became clear Joseph would use
hermit purple on the sand to Divine the
location of any approaching threats
while jro and P would Patrol the outside
side of the miniaturized Fortress with
star platinum and silver Chariot
respectively that way whenever a flesh
creature got too close the two attack
type stands could unleash full force
barges to knock them away the next thing
to do was for Iggy to increase the speed
of the sand construct by adding Wheels
to it it was like a gigantic sand
monster truck zooming through the ruins
with a platinum brawler and a silver
Knight repelling anything that came too
near once Iggy gained enough velocity
with the f
Joseph used hermit purple to discern the
location of a bit of rubble shaped
conveniently like a ramp the sand castle
vaulted off the ramp and into the air
while Iggy augmented his creation once
again with a pair of gigantic gliding
wings now they were soaring out of the
reach of the flesh monsters Joseph and
PF shared sympathies over the loss of
their two important friends avdal and
kokin had both bravely given themselves
to protect the team and none of the
Crusaders would be here if it wasn't for
them jro focused on helping Iggy pilot
the sand glider using star Platinum to
kick the ground whenever the vehicle got
too low nobody was sure what they would
encounter next in the Daybreak or what
Bizarre Adventures were yet to unfold
but they had each other and for now that
was enough everyone in the Sleepy
Mountain Town had heard stories about
the abandoned mall and the malevolent
creature that lurked in the wreckage
there there had been enough missing
persons case
lost children teenagers sneaking out to
explore and never returning home Urban
explorers who stumbled out of the
darkness disheveled and traumatized with
an eyewitness account no one wanted to
believe there wasn't anyone left in the
surrounding area willing to set foot in
that cursed place but that didn't stop
opportunistic outof Towners from paying
the occasional visit especially if they
felt like there was money to be made in
those crumbling corporate walls Grant
and J
the hosts of upand cominging
investigative reality show ghostly
happenings were two such visitors when
they heard the rumors about an abandoned
Mall haunted by some sort of dark
presence blamed for The Disappearance of
local children they packed up their van
picked up their underpaid cameraman
Derek and headed straight for the
infamous building are you sure we're
allowed to be here Dereck asked shakely
as he began filming nope Grant answered
cheerfully that's part of the fun Jason
laughed look man this place has been
left to rot by the city no one cares if
we're shooting some footage besides
worry less about the cops and more about
the ghost of the mole Grant grinned oo
not funny Derek crumbled come on serious
faces were rolling Jason nudged his
co-host and the two snapped into their
on camera personalities once a bustling
Center of suburban American life this
shopping mall has transformed into a den
of Terror Grant's voice dropped into a
lower register his expression intense
locals swap stories of something inhuman
that calls this place home something
that doesn't take kindly to trespassers
Jason added a ghost a demon just an
urban legend that's what we're here to
find out Grant pulled out an EMF reader
which began beeping as he turned it on
ah there seems to be a lot of activity
in here already I'm picking up something
don't know if you folks at home can see
this put the meters going crazy Jason
expl claimed it was a fake meter of
course one that they rigged up to beep
and react when Grant press certain
hidden buttons but the audience didn't
need to know that they were tuning in
for story for spectacle not for the
truth if they wanted that they could
flip over to the nature Channel and
watch some lions chasing a gazelle on
this show they were chasing pure
entertainment they continued deeper into
the building taking in the massive
echoey space the dusty storefronts the
beams of Rock Cotten wood strewn across
the ground the rats that skittered
across the floor it was the perfect
creepy atmosphere maybe a little too
perfect a little too creepy what was
that Derrik practically jumped out of
his skin spinning around to look at
something behind him hey stay on us
Grant snapped I saw something moving
back there Derek insisted it was a rat
Jason rolled his eyes there are tons of
them in here Derrick shook his head no
it wasn't a rat it was way too big okay
a raccoon then come on get it together
we've been in way worse locations than
this remember that old tuberculosis
Hospital Grant shuddered God now that
was scary this is nothing well not
nothing Jason elbowed his partner I did
a good job scouting this place right
grant was about to answer when his foot
bumps something on the ground he looked
down and saw a Polaroid camera next to a
long empty water bottle and a small
backpack oh man get a shot of this Derek
obliged while Jason took a closer look
this must have belonged to one of the
urban explor Flor types who came in here
he unzipped the backpack rumaging around
hey look photos tons of them he dumped
the pictures out onto the ground think
he got some Spirit photography done
before he bit the dust well might as
well see Grant joined Jason on the
ground sifting through the photos as
Derrik watched anxiously boring boring
deer dog Sunset now wait a minute he
stopped holding up one specific Polaroid
this is the money shot right here Derek
zoom in on this all three men looked at
the picture illuminated by the camera's
light it showed a tall long limed pale
creature vaguely humanoid in shape but
at the same time distinctly not quite
human its mouth was stretched wide in a
wordless screech its eyes bloodshot and
wild its long tapered fingers were
reaching towards the camera damn that's
spooky Jason laughed a bit of
nervousness creeping into his voice how
do you think he set this up Grant asked
what if it's real dererk swallowed the
lump in his throat don't be an idiot
Grant scoffed but then then from the
outside not 100 ft away they heard a
scream ears splitting loud filled with
rage pain and animalistic Instinct it
was like nothing any of them had ever
heard before the scream was followed by
the sound of splitting wood branches
crashing to the ground and horrifyingly
the sound of something breaking down a
nearby wall what did you do Jason backed
away from the sound me you open the
backpack Grant shot back guys I've think
we need to get out of here Derrik
watched in wide-eyed Terror as two pale
hands ripped a hole in the wall in front
of them making an opening for that pale
hairless head from the photograph to
poke through all three men prepared to
make a break for it and run for their
lives but as soon as the creature saw
them it was already too late with
another scream scp096 sprinted toward
them grabbing each man and throwing them
to the ground the camera shattered into
pieces from the impact and Derek skidded
painfully across the ground as he rolled
onto his side to try and push back up to
his feet he caught a glimpse of the
monster opening its mouth impossibly
wide and descending on his bosses he
really didn't want to focus on what
happened next but suffice to say there
was nothing of them left afterwards
Derek tried his best to escape but he
was no match for the brute strength and
speed of scp096 from the moment he saw
its face his fate was sealed there was
no Escape soon the beeping em enough
meter the scattered photographs and the
broken pieces of the camera were the
only thing left of the crew from ghostly
happenings their devoted fans would
never get another episode but at least
one being in the abandoned Mall could
rest easy now scp096 was safe again no
one was living who had seen its face it
slowly crawled back to the hole it had
made in the wall ready to return to the
forest and climb back up the mountain
there it could curl up beneath a tree
and stay there there for as long as it
wanted but as scp096 reached the hole in
the wall where it had once been able to
see night sky stars and the trees in the
distance there was only Blackness it was
as if something dark was stretching over
the opening blocking the outside world
from view 096 reached out a hand to push
the blockage out of the way but whatever
it was slithered away from the touch
faster than the pale hand could move the
wriggling darkness crept back into the
building weaving in and out of the
shadows as scp096 watched it curiously
whatever it was it hadn't looked at the
creature's face yet it wasn't sure if
this thing even had eyes but then
stretching out of the darkness and into
view was a garish face with wide white
eyes with massive pupils a round nose
and a wide wide mouth stretched into a
toothy Grimace that might have once
looked like a smile this was the
creature that had made the mall its home
the apex predator of this biosphere and
it was staring directly at scp096 his
face its face with a shriek 096 flew
into a Primal Rage clawing at the
catlike creature but before 096 could
reach it the thing was gone where was it
where did it go 096 roared tearing at
the floor ripping up the tile and
gouging long deep scratches in the
concrete beneath a sound in the distance
Drew 09 six's attention and it bolted in
the direction of the noise swinging at
any obstacle in its path as it went it
ripped down a banner advertising free
frozen yogurt samples crushed an empty
cell phone kiosk and threw a gumball
machine to the floor with a crash would
rip the entire Mall apart if it had to
if that was what it took to destroy the
being that had caught a glimpse of its
face and disappeared then 096 could see
it that face that wide-eyed grinning
face it sprinted toward the face as fast
as it could the cartoon cat was looking
at 096 not from a place in the room but
from behind the screen of a television
in the electronic store window somehow
defying the laws of physics and reality
it had made its way into the TV 096
didn't pause to ponder the logic of this
there was no room for critical thought
there was only the need to shred to
consume to destroy it burst through the
window sending shards of glass in every
direction and reared back to attack the
screen it was so focused on its singular
task that it didn't notice the long
black arm snaking across the floor
winding around its feet all of a sudden
096 lost its balance as its legs were
pulled right out from under it those
stretchy arms dragging it into the TV
screen itself when 096 regained
Consciousness it was in a place it did
not recognize gone was the inside of the
mall or the familiar forest and
mountains outside instead scp096 was in
some sort of handdrawn world a massive
house with a hallway that seemed to go
on forever lined with infinite doors
leading to who knew where the floor
tipped and tilted at odd angles and the
geometry made no three-dimensional sense
it was dizzying and deeply off-putting
scp096 had no frame of reference to
compare it to but a human witness might
have noticed that this place looked like
something out of an old cartoon from the
days of Steamboat Willie and the like
scp096 did not think such a thing it
only knew that it was in an unfamiliar
Place one that felt threatening though
there were no visible threats and it
knew that it still hadn't gotten its
hands on the creature that had seen its
face all along the walls between each
door there were clocks in the shape of
that horrible cat eyes ticking back and
forth with each second while wide smile
mocking scp096 as if to say try and find
me scp096 would not be discouraged there
was no room in its mind for that sort of
thing there was only the singular goal
of finding the cartoon cat and tearing
it limb from rubber ho limb
psychological warfare would have no
effect still cartoon cat would give it
his best shot this was his world and he
could do whatever he wanted here cartoon
cat poked his head out through a random
doorway waving to 096 with one of his
puffy white gloved hands as 096 wailed
and began to give Chase cartoon cat
slammed the door shut only to open
another door down the hall and poke his
head out of that one he did the same
trick over and over jerking scp096
around from end to end of the ever
expanding animated hallway after some
time pass however it appeared scp096 was
not going to get tired and was not going
to give up hope hope of catching its
prey it was time to end this cartoon cat
wrapped one long arm around SCP 96's
neck restraining it against the wall and
began to squeeze Tighter and Tighter but
nothing happened scp096 did not collapse
did not react at all except to tear at
the arm around its neck until it broke
free then it returned to the Relentless
Pursuit tearing door frames apart
pulling up floorboards punching through
walls every time it dealt damage to the
environment the space filled itself back
in an unseen pen scribbling in the gaps
in the floorboards sealing up the holes
in the walls two powerful beings going
back and forth locked in a seemingly
equal matched battle cartoon cat tried
to destroy scp096 in a myriad of ways he
tried to rip the Beast apart to snap its
neck to do any manner of unspeakable
violent acts it had done before with
great sadistic Glee but this pale
abomination would not fold would not
break this wasn't going to be any fun if
there was no ending and if 096 kept
destroying one of cartoon cat's favorite
pocket worlds that was quite enough
cartoon cat grabbed hold of 0 96's arms
and legs the creature thrashing
viciously as he did so and threw it into
the blank space just beyond the
Illustrated world back in the mall SC
scp096 crashed back to Earth was about
to resume its search for cartoon cat
when suddenly a bright light illuminated
its face a police officer stood a few
feet away holding a flashlight excuse me
you can't be in here you're trespassing
the officer started to warn but his
words were interrupted when 096 began to
scream soon he would be screaming too
the Aftershock shuddered through the
foundation emergency alarms wailed as
injured staff and security helped each
other out from underneath Rubble that
had fallen on them as the building was
Shak shaken by the Quake it had only
lasted a few short seconds but still
managed to leave a trail of Destruction
in its wake while the wounded were
bandaged up anyone and everyone who was
still able to started frantically
checking the containment of every
anomaly on the site the foundation could
worry about the origin of the Quake
later first and foremost they needed to
assess the damage luckily multiple rapid
sweeps of the facility revealed that
there weren't all that many highle
threat anomalies whose containment had
been breached a few of the safer ones
were found cowering under tables or
buried under Fallen Rubble in their
quarters but for the most part every
anomaly was accounted for and none had
been provided with an opportunity to
escape and cause further Havoc at least
that's how things seemed at first it was
only when the chaos started to die down
and repair efforts were underway that
Personnel noticed an odd change
something was missing but nobody could
quite put their finger on exactly what
as a matter of fact most could pinpoint
exactly when they noticed this odd
feeling it had only begun after the
emergency alarms had been shut off there
was a sound that everyone working at the
foundation had gotten so used to that
they practically stopped hearing it or
at least they'd stopped noticing it it
was only now that the noise was gone its
absence no longer drowned out by blaring
alarms that staff realized it had always
been there everyone had just learned to
subconsciously tune it out crying the
low soft whimpering that could be heard
emanating from SCP 96's Containment
chamber it had stopped the cell within
had fallen silent and once someone at
the foundation made the right connection
and investigated they happened upon a
startling Discovery scp096 had vanished
Panic immediately engulfed the facility
yet again the shy guy could be anywhere
and a search effort to find it would
only end in deaths after all in order to
find something you have to look at it
and that was a fatal thing to do when
scp096 was involved closer examination
showed no trace of the missing creature
there had been no reported incidents of
incursions with it anywhere in the world
every known photograph video recording
or other visual depiction of scp096 was
either securely stashed away or
destroyed completely by the foundation
there was no no way it could have
possibly escaped and it was seemingly
nowhere at all but still the question
remained where in the world had the shy
guy gone to if it was still even in this
world from SCP 96's perspective one
moment all had been normal the next it
was lost somewhere strange unfamiliar
and above all unsettling even to the shy
guy before the sudden Quake had hit it
had spent the day the same way it
usually occupied its time alternating
between aimlessly pacing the far wall of
its containment chamber and sitting in a
fetal position in the corner sobbing all
the while but then the room had started
shaking and in the blink of a deeply
sunken eye the shy guy found itself well
it had no idea where around it was a
large carpeted room open and sparse with
little occupying all the space the
wallpaper was a nauseating sickly shade
of yellow made all the more garish by
the rows of fluorescent lighting from
the ceiling above the entire Place
seemed to resemble an office space
although seemingly one that was in a
total state of disuse there was no
furniture not even one solitary
inanimate object to make the place seem
at least the tiniest bit closer to
normal little was as CP 096 aware it had
somehow been transported to a strange
and terrible place the back rooms unless
someone remains wary and ever Vigilant
they can unknowingly slip their way out
of reality it can happen anywhere all
that a person needs to do is be in the
wrong place at the wrong time and they
will noclip into the back rooms all
around scp096 was the stench of old wet
carpet and a Labyrinth of uninhabited
rooms with the same drab yellow walls
the endless Buzz of the fluorescent
lights stretching out for who knows how
many square miles of empty rooms in
short the shy guy was trapped in a
Purgatory like nightmare however there
was at least one small Mercy for scp096
as it wandered around its new
surroundings there was nobody else
around no other signs of life no SCP
Foundation No Ordinary human beings no
one who could see it here in the
solitary confinement of the back rooms
scp096 could not be perceived and yet
this brought the self-conscious creature
very little in the way of comfort
despite being completely alone there was
an awful Ling ring feeling that hung in
the air like the smell of the old carpet
underfoot scp096 still felt like it was
being watched and yet if someone or
something really was watching it wasn't
triggering the Shy Guy's usual rage
State as it lur through the various
rooms and corridors the creature kept
expecting to find someone to look them
in the eye directly and get the same
inescapable urge to race towards its
Observer and kill them but it never came
because there was nobody else around at
least for a little while Adam Jenkins
had been out riding his bike when it
happened pushing one pedal around than
the other he gradually climbed higher up
the slope of a hill his house was down
at the bottom of the other side and Adam
knew once he reached the peak he could
slip nice and easily down the rest of
the way as long as he was careful not to
let the extra momentum carry his bike
too far and too fast he just had to keep
in control and gently compress the brake
if he needed to he made the the same
Journey every day nothing could go wrong
sure enough Adam reached the top of the
hill and allowed the bike to slowly tip
ever so slightly over the other side
gravity started to do the rest the
wheels starting to spin rapidly the
pedals pistoning his legs as he
plummeted downwards it was one of the
few childlike Joys left in Adam's life
those few brief seconds of the day where
he got to speed down the hill back home
with Reckless abandon he was blissfully
unaware that he wouldn't have enough
time to miss how much he enjoyed it
without warning a car came speeding out
from around a corner on the way down the
hill it was dark and the driver had
carelessly decided to leave their
headlights off so when Adam saw the
vehicle he only had a split second to
react he was still going too fast so if
he applied the brakes now his front
wheel would stop too suddenly and send
him flying forward over the handlebars
instead seconds before colliding with
the car's Hood Adam wrenched his bike's
handlebars and swerved around the car
but the added speed of going down
downhill caused the entire bike to
topple as it turned so violently
launching Adam off and sending him
hurdling towards a nearby wall Adam
could tell in the Split Second after
coming off his bike that he was about to
collide with the wall his brain and body
anticipated the impact bracing him for
the painful crash but it never came
instead of hitting the wall Adam passed
through it that may well have spared him
a devastating injury but now a whole new
problem now faced him just like no
clipping through a virtual environment
in a video game Adam had passed directly
out of reality right into the back rooms
the first few hours were the worst
shouting as loud as he could for someone
anyone to come and find him each yell
rapidly growing more and more frantic as
Adam rushed around his haunting new
surroundings the whole place was
unsettling just to be in it gave off a
hostile unwelcoming energy that was
impossible to ignore it was only after
an hour of trying to find a way out that
Adam realized he was well and truly lost
he'd strayed too far away from his
original point of entry and just as he
had the idea of trying to make his way
back to the world from the same place he
came in it was already too late the back
rooms at least on this first level all
looked the same no two rooms were
distinct enough for him to figure out if
this was somewhere he'd been before or
an entirely new area it didn't take long
for an overwhelming sense of
hopelessness to set in Adam had quickly
given up calling for help there was no
sign of anyone around that would be able
to help him until the shuffling of
footsteps came from nearby it was such a
noticeable break in the dull unsettling
quiet of the back rooms that it made
Adam's ears prick up the yellow hued
maze had been so void of life since he
had arrived so unnaturally empty that he
wasn't entirely sure he had made the
sound himself by his jacket brushing up
against the wall but no there was
definitely something here with him he
could hear at wandering nearby and it
had certainly hurt him too calling out
yet again with more caution in his tone
Adam Jenkins turned the next Corner met
with yet another dingy yellow Corridor
although unlike the others this one had
a key difference scp096 stood right in
the middle of it the split second that
Adam's eyes fell over the shy guy it was
already too late he barely had time to
process the sight of the creature its
tall humanoid shape wiry thin and pale
skinned jaw hanging unnaturally wide in
fact scp096 dashed towards Adam so
quickly that he couldn't even finish his
startled scream meanwhile back at the
SCP Foundation efforts were still
underway to retrieve the shy guy
researchers were baffled that there was
not a single trace anywhere on the globe
of SCP 96's presence they had quickly
rolled out their usual method for
recalling the creature to containment
requisitioning one of d-class personnel
this individual was in instructed to
stand in scp096 C and then was given a
photograph of the monster to look at
knowing that the shy guy would track
down anyone that saw its face even as a
single tiny pixel in a picture the
foundation expected the creature to
Simply reappear in its containment
chamber to kill the d-class they had
used as bait but nothing happened the
d-class was able to look at the photo of
scp096 and survive it was almost as if
the creatures link to reality was
weakened wherever was it might still be
aware someone had looked at it but the
shy guy was somehow being blocked from
traveling to its most recent Observer
having drawn a blank on trying to
determine SCP 96's whereabouts the
foundation eventually turned to SCP 343
for his input naturally the powerful
reality Bender was reluctant as ever to
get involved the foundation insisted
knowing that SCP 343's omniscience meant
he would already be aware of where they
could find the missing Shy Guy he
refused multiple times admitting he did
have the answer they were looking for
but not wishing to divulge that
information fine SCP 343 side coming to
a compromise I can't tell you exactly
where 096 is but when I tell you where
to look for answers you'll know async
the researchers were stunned into
silence nobody in the foundation had
heard that name used in a long time but
SCP 343 was right they knew exactly what
it meant back in the 1980s async was
another shadowy organization that had
been investigating the existence of a
Lial space connected to reality a place
they had called the back rooms Gathering
up a mobile task force the SCP
Foundation dispatched its agents to a
site that had long since been abandoned
they'd kept a watchful eye over the
disused lab keeping the public away
making sure nobody stumbled in by
accident and got trapped as the MTF
Commander gave the word the outd dated
80s technology was fired up and async
great achievement was reactivated they
had constructed a portal into the back
rooms moving information the MTF
operatives filed into the empty yellow
space unsure if they'd find scp096 alive
or if it would even want to come back
meanwhile in the back rooms level zero
only the shy guy remained having
completely annihilated Poor Unfortunate
Adam he was enjoying the Solitude once
again knowing that now nobody was here
to see him until one wrong step changed
everything he no clipped from Level zero
to level one where he would have a lot
more company man it's even better on the
15th read oh hello I didn't see you
there dear viewers of SCP explained I'm
on break between supervising SCP 682
termination attempts and inspecting the
mops we use on scp1 73's leavings so I
decided to do what all the cool people
are doing in their spare time right now
rereading chainsaw man the hit manga by
Japanese author and artist tatsuki
Fujimoto for the uninitiated it's the
story of denji a poor young man from
Japan who makes his living hunting
Devils dangerous creatures that are
embodiments of Mankind's greatest fears
but when that living leads to him dying
at the hands of a gang of zombie Yakuza
believe me it makes sense in context he
bonds with the legendary chainsaw devil
and is reborn as chainsaw man an
unconventional superhero who chainsaws
first and asks questions later naturally
I was eager to see how one of our own
bloodthirsty Killers would fare against
dji's chainsaws of Fury so I selected
the most violent battle hardened and
Carnage hungry anomaly out there SCP
076-2 The Immortal Warrior known as Abel
the two of them have a surprising amount
of things in common both are effectively
Immortal and can revive after after
sustaining massive physical injuries
both absolutely loved to fight with
their array of deadly weapons and
anomalous strength both have been part
of experimental operations groups with
denji being a member of Japan's Public
Safety devil Hunters division 4 and Abel
being an ex-member of the SCP
foundation's disastrous Pandora's Box
mobile task force most of which he later
massacred out of boredom you can
probably see why these two really did
feel like the perfect matchup so after
forcing the trusty
anamatronic for your viewing pleasure
and hey fellow fans of the manga isn't
it horrifying that even we beat mappa to
the punch of animating this
[Music]
thing oh God that joke will age poorly
if that anime comes out before this
anyway let's crank this machine into
action and let her rep Japan
1997 everything is roasting in the July
heat Men In Black Harrison Ford's Air
Force 1 and airbud are hitting theaters
for the first time everything is right
with the world that's why over in the
headquarters of the public safety devil
hunting Department denji our chainsaw
loving hero is being praised by his kind
boss and Mentor figure Mima a lovable
supportive woman who will never do
anything wrong she even loves dogs how
could a person who loves dogs ever be
evil that very morning denji and his
chainsaw man form managed to defeat the
accidentally making a mistake on your
tax forms and now you're going to prison
devil who had been terrorizing downtown
Tokyo it was a challenging battle but in
the end he' managed to turn the tables
and defeat the creature by setting it on
fire needless to say Mima was extremely
pleased with dji's work here but now she
had considerably more Graver news to
impart she'd gotten word from an end
Envoy of another organization that hunts
down dangerous and anomalous creatures
the SCP Foundation that an extremely
lethal entity had breached their
containment and was now somewhere in
Japan the entity in question was not a
devil and thereby would be working on a
different rule set Mima opened a file
fact to her by the foundation yes
remember this is set in 1997 and gave
denji The crucial Lowdown several hours
ago the entity known as a had
resurrected from his huge black
sarcophagus in the underwater chamber of
the classified facility containment area
25b after waking up Abel had slaughtered
his way through the entire base killing
every SCP Foundation operative in his
path and then swimming out into the
Pacific Ocean sometime after that he
infiltrated a Japanese cargo ship and
murdered all the workers on board before
steering the ship back towards the Land
of the Rising Sun where he hoped to
claim even more more victims Mima told
denji that it would fall to him and his
associates to stop this AEL With a
Little Help from the SCP foundation's
intelligence but be warned Abel is an
incredible combatant with extreme
physical strength and durability as well
as surprising tactical intelligence it
wouldn't be an easy fight but Mima
promised that if denji won she'd hug him
and go to a nearby karaoke bar with him
denji replied consider him dead already
Miss Mima meanwhile Abel was walking
through the slums of Tokyo marveling at
the neon signs for bars and clubs his
journey to Japan hadn't been an accident
Abel had been to Japan once before in
the year
1605 he'd fa the legendary Japanese
philosopher and swordsman Miato moushi
considered by many to be one of the
greatest warriors in human history Abel
had dueled moushi who famously wielded
two katanas at once in the hills of the
harim a province where after a tense
battle moushi cut him down Abel would
not resurrect again during mhi's
lifetime but the battle gave him a deep
and abiding respect for the legendary
Warrior Abel knew that if the
opportunity ever rose again he would
return to Japan in hopes of experiencing
such a brilliant battle yet again but
the industrial and technological boom
had changed so much it was no longer the
quiet and pastoral Japan he'd
experienced but a booming epicenter of
trade and commerce he found it all
strange and perplexing suddenly he found
himself surrounded by a group of
Japanese street thugs many of them
wielding switch blades they laughed at
his strange outfit which to them looked
like an old worn bed sheet one of the
smarter members of the group had already
decided to go home when the others made
up their mind to mug Abel the Warriors
extensive tattoos made him look like a
middle Easter Yakuza Dawn the rest
however were happy to take their chances
with him empty your pockets if that
goofy toga even has pockets the leader
said holding up his switchblade unless
you want to get cut Abel just smirked
and Drew a pair of long obsidian daggers
in the following Moment The Alley was
filled with screams then was silent yet
again Abel walked on breathing a sigh of
disappointment at how incredibly
mediocre this first fight had been his
blades dripping with fresh blood moushi
is rolling in his grave Abel thought to
himself meanwhile across town denji and
the rest of division 4 were mobilizing
it was him the serious sword Wheeling
Aki and the adorable pathologically
lying blood feiend power they'd been
told over the phone by a man named Dr
brigh that Abel would be relatively easy
to track down he's not known for his
subtlety all you need to do is follow
the trail of Carnage he causes wherever
he goes from the way he talks about him
it seems almost as though Dr brigh Bears
a personal grudge against able how
strange power didn't seem intimidated
she proudly proclaimed I don't think
this battle will be difficult at all in
fact I faced this AEL before and
defeated him handily Ai sighed and asked
when did this happen last Tuesday of
course she replied power had only heard
about Abel this morning but denji and
Aki had learned better than to dispute
her at this point suddenly a large
television screen that had been
previously relaying an ad for a Cutting
Edge stereo system cut to an emergency
news report there had been a horrific
incident in downtown Tokyo where a bar
had been attacked and most of its
patrons murdered by a deranged tattooed
man carrying a pair of huge swords Aki
immediately recognized this place the
bar was Yakuza owned if this able was on
the hunt for worthy opponents it makes
all the sense in the world that Japan's
iconic crime syndicates would be his
first Target then G Aki and power knew
exactly where they needed to go over at
the bar Abel was having a whale of a
Time innocent patrons were running and
screaming while the Yakuza engaged in an
allout war with a terrifying inhuman
Warrior several of them had already been
cut down two Yakuza soldiers behind the
bar were reloading illegal Uzi and
preparing to return fire both were
sweating terrified by the sudden random
attack when they'd shot him before he'
managed to dodge most of the bullets and
expertly blocked the rest with his
swords who the hell had sent this
monster was he with the Triads the
Russian mob or some devil summoned by
the Japanese government to crack down on
them whatever the case he seemed almost
impossible to kill the two men stood
back up and open fire AEL held his two
swords and spun like a propeller
blocking all the bullets almost
effortlessly he then produced another
dagger seemingly from thin air and threw
it directly into the heart of one of the
two remaining Yakuza behind the bar he
dropped to the ground dead instantly
leaving only his friend alive in a bar
full of corpses that's when Abel noticed
a decorative katana behind the bar he
smiled and ordered the surviving Yakuza
Soldier to pick up the sword and give
him a real fight the hapless mobster
realized in that moment that this guy
was truly crazy whoever he was but what
choice did he have now with Terror in
his heart the last surviving Yakuza
grabbed the katana and un sheathed it
good Abel said his voice deep and
menacing now come fight me let's see if
you last a few seconds longer than your
worthless friends shall we he did not
the second the Yakuza ran towards Abel
and the ancient swordsman swiped at him
with one of his blades cutting through
the katana and the opponent holding it a
puny gangster never stood a chance
against a deadly Immortal Warrior and
Abel was Furious the last time he was
here he faced a a truly expert killer
who even managed to end Abel's life in a
single combat and now he was slaying
insects in a karaokey bar pathetic
suddenly his ears picked up he turned to
see a red axe flying at his head at
incredible speeds with his superhuman
reflexes he managed to dodge just in
time but the axe still cleaved off a
chunk of his hair as it passed Abel
could see the one who threw it standing
at the entrance to the bar it was the
blood fiend power who made the axe out
of her own own blood standing next to
her were denji and Aki denji wielding an
Axe and Aki stoically observing damn
Miss Mima promise we do karaoke at this
bar if I beat you denji said you're
going down for this Abel smiled and
pulled out another pair of blades
finally he roared Warriors who fight the
oldfashioned way I feared the years had
stolen you all from me power stepped
forward producing another Blood axe from
nowhere she yelled Tre emble in fear
Abel is I your arch nemesis the mighty
power Abel had literally never seen her
before in his thousands of years of life
but he appreciated that these warriors
were at least able to match his level of
drama as far as he was concerned the
fight was on but even Abel didn't know
the level of fighting he was getting in
for here as he charged forward the trio
split immediately surrounding him good
tactics Abel thought to himself already
this was promising Aki who had remained
quiet up to this point attacked first he
drew a tatano knife from his suit jacket
and slashed at Abel with impressive
speed but unlike three of the other
combatants in this situation Aki was
only human which gave him a serious
disadvantage Abel decided it would be
best to put him out of commission first
with a quick and brutal kick to the
chest AI was thrown against the wall
with the majority of his ribs broken
revved up by his own blood lust Abel
turned to denji in power and grinned
like a maniac back this was already the
most fun he'd had in a long time who are
these people doesn't matter he thought
they'll be dead soon anyway while Abel
was still locked in thought power pulled
out a comically large Hammer made out of
her own blood and brought it down
towards Abel he was surprised by the
sudden attack do this girl have the same
weapon producing Powers as him this just
keeps getting more interesting is the
end able power screamed as the hammer
came down you have once a again been
defeated by the mighty power again just
to clarify these two had never met each
other but it was already too late Abel
punched upwards his clenched fist
colliding with the hammer he hit it with
such terrifying force that power's blood
Hammer shattered against his knuckles in
that same instant Abel noticed denji
running at him with an axe from behind
AEL produced another obsidian dagger and
threw it into Den's forehead dropping
him to the ground immediately pathetic
power tried to produce another weapon
but she used up too much blood already
before she had a chance to make anything
substantial Abel sprung forwards with
terrifying speed trying to land a
killing blow but even weakened power was
freakishly fast she was able to dodge
his blow and kick him in the ribs
momentarily stunning him of course she
took the time to gloat putting her hands
on her hips and laughing victoriously
need a second to catch your breath Abel
it is to be
expected none can keep up with me she
grously announced perhaps you should
just give up and agree to become my
servant I might even teach you a thing
or two about fighting suddenly Abel was
standing right in front of her squeezing
her throat with his iron grip he smiled
flashing teeth and said if you want to
kill kill don't talk with a surprisingly
minimal amount of strength he squeezed
and H a crunch from power's neck he
dropped her limp body to the ground
lucky for power Abel wasn't aware that a
fiend like power can survive an injury
like this as long as she's fed some more
blood instead he just sighed in
disappointment is that all you weaklings
have to offer he bellowed Aki barely
conscious after being kicked against the
wall remain just conscious enough to
activate his contract with a Powerful
Beast known as the fox devil he twists
his hands into a strange gesture and
Whispers the word con before falling
unconscious but that's still enough
suddenly a gigantic demonic Fox claw
burst through the wall of the bar
spraying dust and Rubble everywhere Abel
was definitely not expecting that he
dodged several times as the claw swiped
for him often barely missing him for its
last Strike It lunged Forward and Rak
four claw marks across his chest Abel
was shocked by the sudden pain it felt
fantastic he pulled a long obsidian
spear out of one of his pocket
dimensions and forced it down through
the fox Devil's paw and into the ground
pinning it in place after a moment of
thrashing the claw dissipated into smoke
lending able another Victory though even
he would admit this was a more exciting
fight than the other ones had been was
that it had he gained total Victory once
more just like he so often did these
days he was about to take pity on
himself when denji rose up behind him
how about a rematch denji asked Abel
grinned he liked this kid challenge me
child Abel said well since you asked
denji smirked denji reached into his
shirt and grabbed the rip cord emerging
from his chest it was time to go into
overdrive on this thing he gave it a
mighty yank and like the Rev of a
chainsaw the madness began denji
transformed giant blades emerging from
his arms and his head transformed into a
toothy saw blade nightmare he gave a
mechanical Roar that spewed smoke this
wasn't just denji anymore this was
chainsaw man now this Abel thought
feeling his adrenaline spike is more
like it following denji lead Abel
reached into one of his pocket
dimensions and pulled out one of his
favorite weapons one he'd only
previously used against the mighty hard
to destroy reptile SCP 682 the chainsaw
Claymore a huge two-handed sword with
the eternally twisting shredding teeth
of a chainsaw ever circulating around it
it was time for Chainsaw versus chainsaw
what the hell are you waiting for
chainsaw man roared are we going to
stand around all day or are we going to
fight Abel couldn't have said it better
himself the two charged at one another
at lightning speeds chainsaw clashing
against chain sword the sheer force of
the contact was enough to send a shock
wave blasting through the bar it rapidly
became a power struggle each of them
trying hard to force their chainsaws out
of the stalemate realizing that this
time he perhaps couldn't win with raw
strength Abel back flipped away to
reassess his options but chainsaw man
had no intention of giving Abel time to
think about it he darted towards Abel
with the weight and momentum of a Runway
freight train if Abel hadn't raised his
Claymore to Perry he would have been
shredded to Pieces by the devil saws in
an instant instead the two of them
rocketed out of the nearby wall in a
Cascade of debris causing everyone on
the outside Street to run for their
lives the two quickly stood from the
stumble the two quickly stood up
catching their breath impressive Abel
said you're much better than the others
instead of replying denji briefly
retracted his arm chainsaws and grabbed
a nearby parked car throwing it directly
at Abel Abel reacted quickly cleaving
the car in half with his Claymore and
charging for chainsaw man again just
before AEL could land a lethal strike
chainsaw man deployed his chainsaws
again blocking the blow Abel sped around
him trying to strike again and again but
chainsaw man blocked every strike with
stunning efficacy Abel was astonished
few had never been able to go toe-to-toe
with him like this before he could feel
his heart pounding gloriously in his
chest he would give denji A Warrior's
death with a furious yell Abel brought
down the chainsaw Claymore for a
devastating vertical strike but chainsaw
man was ready he arranged his arm
chainsaws in a cross formation like a
giant pair of scissors and caught Abel's
chain sword between them chainsaw man
pulled his arms in opposite directions
slicing Abel's mighty sword in half the
immortal swordsman skidded backwards to
to avoid the Fallout producing two
smaller blades immediately this chainsaw
man just kept exceeding expectations
didn't he Abel would need to change
tactics if he wanted to win this one
chainsaw man was impressed by the speed
and tenacity of his Foe for someone who
apparently wasn't even a devil Abel sure
packed a hell of a punch did he ever run
out of those damned weapons as though
attempting to answer chainsaw man's
question for him Abel began running
around his flank rapidly producing and
throwing blades and axes in in a
startling volley chainsaw man was able
to use his chainsaw arms and face to
block most of them but not all of them
several daggers and small throwing axes
splattered into the tender flesh of
Chainsaw Man's Chest Abel had
successfully wounded him and he wasn't
done feeling a little more confident now
Abel decided to take a different tactic
he produced a large spiked mace from
thin air and ran at chainsaw man while
the devil was still recovering from his
projectile attack with one brutal whack
he s denji flying down the street
carving a rut into the concrete beneath
him but Abel wasn't done while chainsaw
man was still trying to recover Abel
leaped onto him and began beating him
into the ground with his mace the
strikes were so brutal they shook the
Earth and sent cracks across the
surrounding ground then Abel stopped he
realized for a moment that he was
letting his blood lust get the better of
him this was dishonorable where would be
the fun in beating this boy to death
while he lay on the ground and depriving
himself of one of the greatest opponents
he's had in quite some time no that
would not do at all he'd give him one
more chance on your feet boy Abel said
you fight well get up and carry on I
won't let a beast as rare as you die
like a common dog rise and fight me and
Chainsaw man did as he was told Abel was
shocked to see the very ground shatter
underneath him as chainsaw man burst up
through it all his swords at the ready
the mace was thrown from Abel's hands as
chainsaw man launched up towards him all
metal teeth and fury luckily for Abel he
pulled out a battle axe just in time to
blocked the flurry of brutal strikes
from the patron saint of chainsaws now
this was a fight even moushi would be
proud of yes Boy Yes Abel yelled this is
true combat chainsaw man replied with
the swing of his blades which Abel was
nearly able to dodge the two finally
landed back down on the ground and Abel
was fast enough to bury his battle axe
in chainsaw man's shoulder before the
devil could return a blow to Abel the
anomalous swordsman pulled out a pair of
his favorite swords and locked chainsaw
man's arms in place chainsaw man was
undeniably incredibly powerful but it
looked like Able's Superior experience
and tactics might save him this time
what the hell are you chainsaw man
roared you've been aware the opponent
boy those are few and far between AEL
said I'll remember you for this but
before Abel could execute a killing blow
he felt a blood red throwing ax stick
into his back Abel winced in pain to see
Power and Aki about 30 ft behind him
power was propping Aki up he donated
some of his blood to bring her back to
life and she was just as delusionally
cocky as ever Abel was about to say
something but he already made a fatal
mistake letting his guard down before
another word could pass the cursed
Warrior's lips one of Chainsaw man's
armed chainsaws passed directly through
his heart tearing it apart within Abel's
chest it was a sudden and decisive
killing blow chainsaw man pulled his saw
back out of Abel's chest stained with
the deadly anomalies blood Abel
collapsed to the ground wheezing and
bleeding profusely from the hole in his
chest but strangely as power Ai and
Chainsaw man converged around him they
realized he was smiling thank you Abel
said and died yet again with the battle
W like an Incredible Hulk made of metal
chainsaw man transformed back into denji
the trio stood around Abel's corpse
deeply confused as to what had just
happened if this was the kind of thing
the SCP Foundation normally dealt with
they all silently agree that perhaps it
would be better not to get involved with
them in the future except power of
course who said you two should be
thanking me for defeating him you both
owe me drinks for this hundreds of miles
away in a black sarcophagus deep
underwater surrounded by professional
SCP Foundation Di
Abel's body once again returned who
knows how long he'd remain sleeping in
there but what we do know is that his
deathless sleep was suffused with the
sweet dreams knowing that this world
still held wory opponents and for AEL
that was everything reality warpers real
pieces of work aren't they it's one
thing when an anomaly is all Claws and
fangs like SCP 682 or if their attack of
choice is snapping necks like SCP 173
but it is an entirely different story if
an anomaly can turn the air you breathe
into chocolate pudding or shove you into
a pocket Dimension that looks almost
like our own reality except everyone is
just a walking talking pile of spiders
see what I mean reality warpers real
handfuls though of course not all
reality warpers are created equal some
are relatively weak only affecting the
world around them in a mild ambient
fashion others can rattle whole
Dimensions with their tremendous power
the same also goes for Morality some
reality warpers are loving and
benevolent such as SCP 343 the kindly
old all powerful being known to some as
God and some are pure evil beings who
want nothing more than to use their
immense power to seow chaos and misery
among everyone else and personally we
can't think of a better example of the
ladder than Bill Cipher from Gravity
Falls this demonic Dorito wants nothing
more than to take over our Dimension and
rebuild it in His image of absolute
Insanity so naturally we started
wondering if these two reality warping
Titans SCP 343 and Bill Cipher ever came
to blows who would win we were so
curious in fact that we fired up the
anamatronic supercomputer to see how
exactly the two might meet and how their
epic battle would play out who do you
think would take the coveted W on this
one let us know down in the comments
along with any other out of universe wha
if situations you'd love to see but in
the meantime let's fire up the machine
be warned folks it's going to get weird
the date was July 12th 2013 for SCP 343
it had started out as a relatively
normal day he'd spent the night playing
solitire on the astral plane before
warping back into his humanoid
containment cell by morning leaving the
foundation none the wiser after all he
was really here voluntarily if the
foundation had truly wanted to try to
confine him here they were welcome to
give it a go but it would be about as
effective as trying to catch a whisper
in a butterfly net while God had come to
this place to experience the joyful
illusion of giving up control it truly
was little more than an illusion to him
if he wanted to he could exterminate the
SCP Foundation in less than an afternoon
then retire to Burger King for a Whopper
so really they're all just lucky he is a
benevolent being more interested in
hanging out than dispensing wrath on
those he perceived as insolent that was
Old Testament him he done a lot of soul
searching and growth since then it' been
at least a millennium since he'd smoted
anyone for that matter and the last guy
really had it coming however today was
going to be a little different God knew
that something was going to happen today
he sensed a great source of energy
emerging something dark and malevolent
he sighed and he closed his eyes for a
moment focusing himself he knew whatever
the nature of this threat it would fall
upon him to face and destroy it how
irritating he was hoping to finally
binge stranger things today elsewhere in
sight 19 things seemed to be
inordinately peaceful there hadn't been
any containment breaches or new
anomalies brought in there hadn't been
any attacks from rival groups of
Interest Dr brgh hadn't even done
anything stupid or started any fires to
borrow an old cliche it was quiet too
quiet perhaps the only person who wasn't
having a relatively mellowed day was
security officer Frederick Simmons a
midlevel guard who'd been stationed at
site 19 for 4 years now he just wasn't
really feeling himself today the work
didn't bother Simmons emotionally at
least typically even after seeing rather
traumatic things or being in near-death
situations while in containment breaches
it hadn't left any lingering effects but
lately he'd been having the strangest
dreams it always played out the same way
shortly after going to sleep he'd open
his eyes in a strange multicolored void
surrounded by bizarre seemingly random
floating objects none of which seemed to
have any real relevance to him or his
life and just when he'd begin to
question it the other recurring element
of the dream would occur out of the
shimmering oil slick rainbow of
mindboggling colors a strange being
would suddenly emerge a glowing Golden
Triangle almost like a drawing of a p
pyramid the Eye of Providence with a
stovepipe hat a little bow tie thin
black arms and legs and most notable of
all a single large eye with a slit pupil
staring out from the center the eye
almost seemed to have a strange hypnotic
quality to it Simmons felt Bewitched
whenever he looked into it he wasn't
afraid quite the opposite actually for
reasons he couldn't understand this
strange creature from the world of
Dreams seemed like a good friend of his
he said well well well well well if it
isn't my number one guy the Fred Meister
in the house I missed you have you miss
me put her there good buddy The Entity
extended his hand and Simmons shook it
the foundation guard could feel a
strange tingling sensation jolting down
his arm the first time Simmons had
encountered The Entity he told him his
name Bill Cipher and he told him how
incredibly important it was that Simmons
kept their little nighttime meetings a
secret and Exchange bill was here to
listen Simmons would spend his time in
the mindscape pouring out his worries
and frustrations with his daily work as
bill paid impeccable attention the
strange Little Dream entities seemed
fascinated by the work Simmons did all
the peculiar and wondrous anomalies he
guarded at site 19 but to Simmons it was
all just boring work zombie creating
Supernatural plague doctors and Immortal
men with metal limbs lose their shine
after you see them day in day out for
years on end frankly Simmons needed a
day off but he'd already used up all his
PTO when he'd gotten the flu earlier
that year he just didn't know what to do
luckily for him Bill had a solution bill
as it turned out had a fancy little
ability he could occupy the body of a
human being and operate it for them bill
could take the wheel while Simmons took
a load off in the mindscape how hard
could standing around pretending to look
busy at the SCP Foundation really be as
Bill explained the offer to him Simmons
couldn't really see any flaws in his
reasoning after all bill was a friend
why would he have any ill will towards
him with that he shook hands with the
bizarre Supernatural triangle and felt
the sudden rough sensation of having his
Consciousness ripped from his body only
for Bill to Slither in and take his
place the new Simmons the bill occupied
Simmons opened up his demonic yellow
eyes and grinned he gave a demented
laugh to Simmons floated disembodied
Soul oh man he said wiping away a tear
of laughter with Simmons finger with
your body I can use the SCP foundation's
technology to take over the Multiverse
see you sucker and with one last
demented chuckle Bill left for work at
the SCP Foundation with Simmons being
the latest in his long line of Meat
Puppets after arriving at site 19 he
sneaked through the facility no knowing
exactly where he needed to be you see
Bill is a native entity of the second
dimension the world of flat shapes but
he's able to access the minds of beings
in the third dimension like us through
the medium of the mindscape rather than
the Physical Realm Bill's life goal has
always been to find a way to permeate
and take over the third dimension
turning it into his personal playground
all he needed was the right anomaly to
bring him forth into our world in this
case a little anomalous device favored
by Dr C pathos Crow SCP 158 also known
as the soul extractor while Dr Crow Left
To the courtyard for his evening walkies
the being that most people assumed was
Fred Simmons secreted himself into a cp1
158's containment chamber and locked the
door behind him he didn't have much time
he'd need to do this perfectly if he
wanted a real chance at taking over the
universe he was amused by the irony at
the least the the fact that in order to
take over he needed to sneak into the
midst of the people most likely to
destroy him still where's the fun in
life with no risk at SCP 158's control
console he inputed the data to Soul
extraction and set a timer however there
was one difference between this and the
usual procedures performed with the soul
extractor there was no containment
receptacle on the other end whatever was
extracted would just be released into
the world and this was exactly what bill
was counting on he laid Simmons's body
down on the gurnie and watched with Glee
as the robotic arm lowered towards him
it reached into his chest and pulled out
the essence of one three-sided threat to
reality Bill Cipher one quick Journey
Through the bowels of the machine later
the nightmare scenario had come to pass
Bill floated around the room dragged
into physical reality he let out a long
conceited cackle and spun his Cane
around this was going to be fun
elsewhere in the facility alarms were
going off and guards were deploying
nobody was meant to be in containment
chamber 158 so how was the soul
extractor currently operating this
couldn't possibly end well bill on the
other end was having a wonderful time he
was pondering all the different ways he
could make the drab clinical corridors
of the SCP Foundation into his vision of
perfect weirdness maybe he turned all
the researchers into mice and turned
site 19 into a giant maze to run them
through maybe he'd turn the air into
farts and release winged beasts from the
hell Dimension to ravage Humanity maybe
he'd go out into the parking lot and key
everyone's cars oh the Diabolical
possibilities were endless as he floated
out into the Hall his fantasizing was
interrupted by a group of foundation
security operatives wielding assault
rifles they entered an attack formation
and trained their rifles on him before
opening fire bill just found himself
laughing again the gunfire just tickled
wow you guys are hilarious Bill said
between fits of laughter but wait I can
think of a better way to make you even
funnier he snapped his fingers and
suddenly the guards were transformed
instead of the serious first line of
defense for the SCP Foundation they were
now a gang of literal clowns straight
from the circus holding balloon animals
molded into the shapes of assault rifles
they giggled and threw pies at each
other bill was right this did make them
even funnier and he was just getting
started turning this Foundation
snoozefest into a party of cosmic
proportions Bill began running a rampage
of weirdness across the site essentially
being the ultimate Cosmic troll he
decided he'd simply bother every single
anomaly he could with his demonic Antics
first he appeared in scp096 his chamber
and pulled a brown paper bag over his
head with the words ugliness lies within
written on the front and just for fun he
then teleported the temperamental Beast
to a nearby Amish community it quickly
became enraged when a gust of wind blew
the bag off its head and a man named
jebadiah saw its face it then killed
several others also named jebadiah
during the Rampage Bill thought it was
hilarious he then released SCP 682 into
site 19 and just to annoy the creature
into further violence he stuck an
indestructible party hat on the
monster's head no matter how hard 682
tried it couldn't remove the party hat
this caused it great frustration which
it took out on any foundation staff it
happened to find in the area it had
fulfilled Bill's expectations
wonderfully but his quest for amusing
Carnage didn't end there next he went to
bother SCP 049 the plague doctor who was
in the process of doing surgery on a
foundation provided Dead Goat with a
snap of his fingers Bill transformed the
plague doctor's surgical tools into
colorful Play-Doh cutting tools needless
to say the supernatural surgeon was less
than pleas pleased he was about as
annoyed as Dr cleff was when bill turned
his favorite shotgun into a bouquet of
flowers then sealed his feet into the
floor or how vexed Dr gears was when
bill turned his plain beige necktie into
a considerably more loud and colorful
tie people there at the time reported
hearing Dr gear say I just don't think
that was necessary oh and he also did
some more minor ax of malice he filled
the break room with an army of flesh
eating zombies he made a mod filled with
molten lava around the site that
prevented anyone from escaping from his
reign of terror and he even covered all
the walls in cognito hazardous Doodles
that instantly drove any weak-minded
human who saw them into complete
gibbering Madness it was clear this
reality warping nightmare needed to be
stopped before he got bored of playing
with his new Foundation toys and decided
to go remodel the universe in his own
image thankfully there was one anomaly
on site who was up to the task bill was
treating himself to another evil laugh
in the site 19 canteen when something
peculiar happened he looked down to see
a man in what looked like a tunic with
graying hair and a beard he walked with
a peculiar kind of calmness his face
blank why wasn't this guy panicking was
he stupid bill would seemingly need to
teach this guy a thing or two about fear
hey Gramps don't know if it's escaped
your attention but I've been giving this
place an Extreme Makeover did you forget
to put on your glasses this morning or
you just had seen
The Stranger remained calm as could be
he replied with a voice that was
measured as it was deep now Bill let's
not resort to name calling that's just
childish don't you think Bill's single
eye widened at this wait wait hold up
how did you know my name Bill asked
irritated are you a friend of the time
baby or something he floated over and
began circling the stranger hoping to
intimidate him much to Bill's
frustration it didn't appear to be
working I know lots of things Bill lots
of things The Stranger replied that's my
line Bill screeched turning red who Do
You Think You Are The Stranger gave a
quiet reserved chuckle that infuriated
Bill oh personally I just like to think
of myself as a humble Craftsman watching
his beautiful creation play out he said
but I suppose some of the people around
here like to call me God Bill didn't
like this
this whole universe was going to be his
and he certainly didn't appreciate some
insolent old man acting like he ran the
roost around here bill would give him an
education in who was really holding the
Reigns and it would be the kind of
education that left scars if it left
anything at all he extended his spinley
black arms and released bolts of
lightning against the stranger who
simply continued to smile as the
electricity rippled around him seemingly
causing no effect are you done the
stranger asked Bill laughed hoping to
hide his irritation I'm just getting
started he bellowed with a thunderous
Roar that shook the very foundations of
site 19 Bill began to grow and shift no
longer a silly little triangle he became
a huge Red Pyramid of pure nightmares
covered in glowing Golden Arms and teeth
with long black tongues drooping out of
each level it was the most terrifying
and demonic form in his entire Arsenal
and yet he was a astonished to find that
the stranger still didn't seem to show
any kind of fear very impressive Bill
The Stranger said sounding almost bored
but I think you might be trying a little
too hard oh that does it bill would
simply have to destroy him it was a
matter of Pride now he raised several of
his huge golden fists and began pounding
down on the comparatively tiny humanoid
stranger it was an assault so powerful
that the ground began cracking around
their feet and yet it seemed that with
almost no effort The Stranger was able
to intercept and block every single blow
naturally bill was infuriated it was
time to finally unleash the full breadth
of his power on this beardy wise guy he
launched Thunderbolts Fireballs Legions
of giant mutant wasps hail storms
maelstroms bubbles of pure Madness
snakes made out of barbed wire and even
incredible coarse language but despite
it all this man the one who claimed
people called him God
was utterly unfazed you can dish it out
he said but let's see if you can take it
Bill began to laugh what the heck's that
supposed to mean you can't God snapped
his fingers and Bill was gone vanished
and with a flick of his wrist all the
damage and Transformations that Bill had
performed had disappeared it was as
though the Demonic triangle had never
even been there in the first place
though Dr brigh Who was acting site
director at the time had some Scranton
reality anchors turned turned on around
the perimeter just to be safe you can
never be too careful with reality
warping demons after all later that day
Dr Bri approached God and asked him what
he'd actually done with Bill God
chuckled and replied for a being of such
a men power he really had a rather
childish mindset so I sealed him away
inside a children's cartoon where he
couldn't do any further damage what was
the cartoon Dr brigh asked a Charming
little Disney show called Gravity Falls
replied well hello there SCP fans let's
get this out of the way first you've
seen the title and thumbnail and you're
probably wondering wait is siren head an
SCP and the answer is no siren head is
not an SCP it's a freaky internet
monster created by renowned Canadian
horror artist Trevor Henderson your next
question is probably what's with this
crazy looking server Bank behind me
allow me to introduce you to the
6,000 the latest advancement of
supercomputing owned and operated
exclusively by the SCP Foundation it's
capable of a whole bunch of interesting
features calculating ideal containment
methods running state-of-the-art
Foundation WebCrawler software making an
editing fun SCP YouTube videos but the
most interesting feature that the
anamatronics regarding all things
anomalous with data fed into it by
thousands of real life experiments
conducted by the SCP Foundation it's
going to save countless dollars and
lives for foundation researchers but way
more importantly it's going to let us
explore all kinds of weird and wacky
what if scenarios that would never
happen organically could SC SCP 343 beat
Goku or Superman who's a deadly or
Supernatural killer SCP 106 or Freddy
Krueger would the world simply explode
from adorableness if SCP 999 and baby
Yoda ever crossed those multiversal
barriers and met we can explore all of
these questions along with any others
you may have down in the comments
seriously comment it we dare you but to
get things started we figured we'd make
the
anamatronic anymore so without further
Ado let's kick the
CP 096 versus siren head Ricky and
Elliott a pair of aspiring travel
YouTubers from California were taking a
vacation to the Pacific Northwest to
spend some time in the area's beautiful
Lush forests however while the duo were
both big fans of travel for its own sake
they weren't just here for the trees and
fresh air you see despite their jet
setting lifestyle Ricky and Elliott
subscribers and Views hadn't exactly
been phenomenal lately turns out hiking
Vlogs and GoPro footage of the two of
them jumping into into absurdly blue
water and Bali weren't exactly that
interesting to people who weren't
actually there but Ricky had formulated
an ingenious plan to pull the two of
them out of obscurity they would hunt
down and film real footage of the
legendary siren head a supernatural
monster said to haunt forests and
isolated graveyards there were plenty of
fakers out there on YouTube but if the
two of them could get real footage of
siren head and also preferably survive
the experience they'd be framing their
golden PL buttons in no time but they
were already encountering certain issues
for starters the two Californians had
severely underestimated just how cold it
was in the Pacific Northwest and as such
were already shivering from bone deep
cold the second issue was food while the
two of them had thought ahead and
brought a selection of tasty protein
bars they'd also gotten hungry during
the early hours of their walk and eaten
all of them leaving them feeling
severely out of luck by the time dinner
rolled around and the third and perhaps
most problematic issue of all was the
fact that Ricky and Elliot didn't
exactly have a great sense of direction
during all of their previous trips
they'd been on guided tours with local
experts in this instance wanting to take
all the siren head glory and clout for
themselves they decided to come in alone
with the incredibly janky Google Maps
app to guide them as such as the night
was creeping in the two aspiring YouTube
celebrities had no idea where they were
needless to say it wasn't exactly an
ideal situation and to make matters
worse Ricky and Elliot had been
experiencing some strange feelings for
the last couple of hours when they'd
gotten particularly deep into the forest
that dread inducing sensation of being
watched by something lurking just out of
sight a gaze with some unknowable and
Darkly malicious intent boiling behind
it these two poor saps had no idea what
was in store for them tonight and
wouldn't you know it the one watching
them right now wouldn't even be the only
monster after them after an expectable
amount of bumbling and buffoonery Ricky
and Elliot managed to gather up enough
Tinder to make a semi- reses campfire
they could sleep out here tonight then
set off in search of siren head or
civilization whichever came first in the
daylight the next day the duo did what
they could to remain chipper in spite of
the ominous circumstances sure they were
trapped in the depths of the woods alone
but think of the amazing Vlog foot
they'd get they'd be like the next Blair
Witch crew except they'd live hopefully
but as the duo sat next to their
campfire they felt that ominous
sensation again the hairs on the back of
their neck started standing up they felt
Shivers that didn't just come from the
cold more and more they started to feel
certain that something in this forest
was watching them something ancient and
powerful and evil that's when they heard
The Telltale crackle of radio static and
their skeletons almost almost jumped out
of their skin could it be him the patron
saint of Gone Missing without a trace of
creeping dread of bad things coming
siren head himself both men fell silent
all they could hear was the crackling of
their own fire had the sound before just
been an illusion a product of a pair of
paranoid Minds also predisposed to sense
siren headed monsters lurking amongst
the trees they'd been reading about a
higher rate of disappearances in this
area along with number of frightening
sightings of tall thin beings and
radiostatic that seemed perfectly
consistent with siren head activity
that's why they'd come here in the first
place but had they come here to their
deaths the two needed to distract
themselves or they'd go mad from the
paranoia they decided to share a few fun
little anecdotes of the travels they had
had before meeting one another showing
the photos they' saved on their
smartphones Ricky had been to Hawaii
Tahiti borabora Fiji St Lucia and the
malds clearly he liked his vacations
warm and Sandy Elliot on the other hand
tended to like his trips to be a little
more adventurous he'd seen volcanoes
waterfalls deep and treacherous cave
systems and of course a little guided
mountaineering one photo that Elliot
showed Ricky was particularly
breathtaking he was standing in the
foreground of a snowy landscape with an
incredible mountain range behind him
when Ricky asked Elliot where exactly
he'd taken this picture Str strangely
enough he drew a complete blank maybe
somewhere in Canada or Siberia or
something like that but it was a hell of
a trip whatever the case he remembered
having a great time it was such a tiny
detail but when looking at the photo
Ricky couldn't help but notice something
in the background a speck of white sure
not exactly newsworthy in the snowy
mountain range but this wasn't snow it
was a speck of white that seemed to be a
slightly different shade than the rest
of the mountain strange perhaps it was
just some tiny particle stuck on the
lens whenever the photo was taken the
two continued to chat and warm their
hands against the fire having no idea of
the horror they just awoken in doing so
over a 100 miles away at an SCP
Foundation containment site researchers
and guards walked around the perimeter
of a huge airtight metal cube reading
off Diagnostics and audio recordings for
reasons that should be obvious to
everyone who's a fan of this channel
there were no camera feeds coming from
the inside of the Great Cube only a
faint whimpering sound like a sad
wounded animal and the clanking of
pacing feet moving back and forth over
the metal dragging forlorn Knuckles it
turned every head in the room when the
crying started to get louder soon it
wasn't just quiet weeping it was a
series of horrendous slobbering sobs
whales of pure pain and despair someone
in the room screamed close your eyes and
hit the deck knowing exactly what had
happened they learned well enough from
the infamous incident
0961 Containment Breach that there was
no way of stopping this thing until it
run its course the best they could do
was minimize their own fatalities in the
process everyone in the room did as they
were told hitting the ground closing
their eyes and covering them with their
hands just to be safe that's when the
solid steel of the cube was torn open
like crape paper and the howling raging
scp096 Broke Free Galloping on all fours
through the nearest wall shattering it
and spraying debris everywhere as mobile
task forces were dispatched should track
the rampaging Abomination and try their
best to clear the path ahead as it
sought out its Target one thought was
going through the minds of everyone in
the room woe be tied the poor fools who
saw that Monster's face back in the deep
dark forests of the Pacific Northwest
the presence of some unnerving force was
becoming far harder to deny for Ricky
and Elliot they heard the sounds of
garbled voices out in the woods the
squeals and crackles of radiostatic they
saw shapes moving amongst the trees tall
and thin like long spindly limbs while
neither wanted to voice Their Fear they
were both thinking similar things if
there really was a monster out here why
hadn't it killed them it had all the
Time in the World to do it but that was
just it wasn't it it had all the time in
the world so why rush it had every
Advantage it could take its time and do
this exactly how it wanted to Ricky and
Elliot had made themselves the perfect
prey and as they saw a huge lith figure
suddenly separate itself from the trees
they began to wonder if it was really
worth it to risk both of their lives for
YouTube clout either way it was now
probably too late for regrets Ricky and
Elliot's Jaws fell in horror as the
monster emerged from the darkness before
them they recognized the awful modeled
skin stretched over the monster's 40t
frame they saw the grasping hands and up
above the nightmarish faceless head
split into a pair of sirens pointing in
different directions each one filled
with nashing teeth and slithering
tongues it was even more terrifying than
they could possibly have imagined siren
head speakers crackled into life and
hissed out 9 18 1 child 17 remove
vile Ricky and Elliot stumbled backwards
as siren head Advanced its speakers
still bleeding hateful static neither
could move or speak only watch as its
long gnarled fingers reach from the dark
to grasp them there was a terrible
pained whale in the woods after that but
it wasn't coming from Ricky Elliot or
siren head it was distant at first but
soon became louder and louder as the
Force's point of origin came barreling
towards them even siren head couldn't
help but turn to see scp096 a flash of
terrible white Fury come charging
towards them in the dark dark knocking
down all the trees in its path leaves
and pine needles scattered trunks
exploded into splinters nothing would
stop the shy guy from claiming its prey
nothing would stop it from destroying
Ricky and now as it approached Elliot
made the Fatal mistake of looking at its
face too 096 lunge ready to go in for
the kill when siren head's hands closed
around the shyy Slender torso in one
fluid motion with surprising strength
for its scrawny build it hurled the Shy
Guy into the distance smashing another
several trees in its path the words my
pre my prey my M mine pissed out of its
speakers but 096 was only down for mere
moments it sprung back up on its hind
and four legs and started Galloping
towards Ricky and Elliot again who were
still frozen in place this time just
before the shy guys terrible claws could
close around the two hapless wannabe
YouTubers down came siren head's
clenched fist pounding 0 96's head into
the dirt overhead mobile task force
helicopters circled wearing their
scramble goggles and trying to get a
visual on the situation unfolding below
they could hardly believe what they were
seeing down there was some other
unclassified anomaly managing to
intercept 096 in its rage state only a
handful of anomalies on record have ever
been shown of being capable of such a
feet it seemed that they were dealing
with something serious here down below
the battle continued siren head had a
unique advantage over most other
combatants facing scp096 it was an
extradimensional being with no eyes
merely an innate psychic awareness of
its victims around it not unlike how
scp096 detect people seeing its face in
photographs or videos without need for
any kind of direct contact as such it
was impossible for siren head to see the
shy guy's face and thus impossible for
the shy guy to ever actually direct its
aggression against it whether or not 096
would kill steel siren head's intended
prey was another matter entirely in the
night's first minor miracle Ricky and
Elliot remembered that they'd been born
with working legs and decided that right
now would be an excellent time to use
them they turned and began to run while
siren head continued beating the shy guy
into the dirt sprinting with all their
might however the growing distance
between them only aggravated the shy guy
further it sprang out from the dirt with
unstoppable force and broke away from
siren head's grip the shy guy never
wasted time ever it always made a beine
for its intended victim with one
directive in mind total Annihilation
tonight is no different Ricky and Elliot
screamed as they heard its pounding
Gallop on the ground behind them closer
closer closer then suddenly defying all
spatial reasoning siren head emerged out
from the darkness between Ricky Elliott
and 096 being 40 ft tall siren head
dwarfed even the shy guy it lunged and
grabbed The Wailing white monstrosity
holding it as one would a particularly
vicious cat and trying to keep it in
place siren had wanted to crush the
monster bones and carry on stalking its
feeble human prey who were currently in
the process of getting away but somehow
that was impossible it was almost like
the monster had an indestructible
skeleton up above the mulle task forces
continued observing this Clash of the
Titans from their two helicopters seeing
how siren head was somehow doing a
serviceable job of sub doing the shy guy
one of the task force members joked
maybe we should hire this guy another
chimed in I don't think we have any
ballistic vests in his size the laughter
soon turned to screams when siren had
hurled 096 his flailing body up at one
of the helicopters with Incredible Force
knocking it out of the sky it greened
down to the ground a ball of fear and
violence before exploding anyone who
survived the initial blast was unlucky
enough to have seen the shy guy's face
their screams rang out briefly before
being a abruptly silenced by the monster
helicopter Alpha had no survivors
meanwhile Ricky and Elliot had kept
running until their lungs burned and
their muscles pumped thumbtacks seeing
that the chaos was so far behind them
now they took a moment to stop and
breathe recomposing themselves in the
second minor miracle of the night it
looked like the two of them had actually
survived this ordeal those two horrific
monsters had cancelled each other out
but Ricky and Elliot were about to learn
a harsh lesson they really weren't that
lucky the last thing the two of them
ever saw was siren head emerging from
the darkness once more the last thing
they ever felt was the monster's
terrible gnarled fingers curling around
their bodies too fast for them to escape
and the last thing they ever heard was
each other's screams followed by a
sickeningly meaty crunch elsewhere in
the forest as CP 96's whales died down
to its usual mudlin SOB the rage state
had ended all of its targets had been
destroyed it just hadn't been the one to
do all of the destroying per se not long
after that helicopter Bravo descended
safely and the remaining MTF members
closed around the blubbering Beast
someone black bagged it and everyone
breathed a sigh of relief knowing that
was at least one monster taken care of
tonight what about the other one the MTF
Lieutenant asked the team's Commander
shook his head and said uh let's worry
about that freak later and get 096 back
to containment this place gives me the
creeps hello one and all and welcome
back to the
anamatronic for projecting any seemingly
improbable scenario for your viewing
Indulgence and today we decided to do
something slightly different with it
here at SCP explained we usually
activate the
anamatronic Denis of the SCP universe
and other fictional characters like
Doctor Strange fighting the Scarlet king
or able crossing paths with Batman but
this
subscribed to us for a while some of you
might remember our video What If scp096
was put inside SCP 914 in it the shy guy
was tricked into entering the input
Booth of the anomalous refinement
machine during a Containment Breach what
emerged was maybe the handsomest man to
ever live Beautiful both on the outside
and within a lot of our comments pointed
out that this refined version of 096
felt akin to a gigachad and that got us
thinking what if a CP 096 was to
encounter the real gigachad well the
anamatronic one or as we like to call it
the obvious outcome pits the thin
humanoid anomaly Against The Man Behind
the meme Ernest kov is a Russian fitness
trainer and model forever immortalized
in the animals of Internet history by a
series of black and white photoshopped
pictures that garnered him the nickname
of gigachad thanks to his Practically
Perfect 90° jawline and muscular
physique kov seemingly unknowingly
became the archetype for the Ultram
masculine handsome man however The Man
Behind the gigachad meme is still just a
man the infamous photos of him were
heavily edited for an art project known
as Sleek in tears and while Ernest does
Sport some impressive muscles from all
his time at the gym that strength isn't
enough to save him from the shy guy
after all he is still just a man
according to to the
anamatronics the most likely outcome if
the two were ever to meet would end
pretty similarly to the Grim fate of
many others who have gazed upon the face
of scp096 the moment Ernest looks at the
creature he would in all likelihood
activate 0 96's rage State his physique
and above average level of Fitness might
give him a slight Advantage allowing him
to perhaps outrun the shy guy for longer
than most but ultimately Ernest kov
would be able to run but not hi from
scp096 the creature would track him down
and hone in on him with anomalous speed
dispatching him before returning to its
usual docile sobbing State the result
and scp096
victory now we know what you're thinking
is that really it we had the same
reaction too but hold on for a minute
after giving the machine an additional
set of variables we were able to get a
few more interesting outcomes out of the
the title of scenario 2 shy harder of
course Ernest kov might be the face of
an internet meme and ultimately just a
very strong Russian man in comparison to
the anomalous traits of scp096 but the
gigachad the gigachad is more than a man
so much more than the sum of his Parts
existing within the online zagge since
as early as
2017 the gigachad is far more powerful
than a mere mortal he doesn't just
represent idealized standards of ere
exaggerated masculinity like the Action
Movie heroes of the 1980s the gigachad
embodies those ideas he is the very
notion of a physically perfected human
specimen given form you may not like it
but Peak Performance doesn't even come
close to the gigachad and neither does
scp096 even at the top of its game the
creature quite literally pales in
comparison to its imposing opponent in
scenario 2 shy har the
anamatronic that if the two were to meet
the scales would tip in the complete
opposite direction from the first
outcome for that was scp096 against the
man but against the meme himself well
this fight is no contest as a matter of
fact it's hardly even a fight certainly
not a fair one and instead is more of an
execution from the moment the
Unstoppable Tower of muscle and perfect
angular jawline that is the gigachad
clasps eyes on scp096 it's practically
the beginning of the end the shy guy
doesn't even lift bro but gigachad can
bench 1 million times his own body
weight in his sleep so when scp096 comes
racing towards him intent on killing him
just for looking at its screeching wide
jawed face the gigachad does what the
gigachad does best he lifts grabbing a
scp096 with ease as it comes to him
screeching gigachad casually wasts the
creature off the ground although he's
only using the tiniest portion of his
immense and Infinite Strength it's more
than enough Force to send the shy guy
soaring upwards crashing through
multiple ceilings as it sent hurdling up
the numerous floors of the foundation
facility above of course being lifted is
hardly going to kill the shy guy
outright the creature is known to be
invulnerable after all but it's not like
gigachad can go down easily either don't
forget this is no mere mortal but an
internet meme incarnate and on the
internet nothing ever dies his Perpetual
existence as part of online history
aside the gigachad is so strong that no
doubt his abs could withstand the
Firepower of any conventional weapon
realizing that even if it could reach
him it couldn't even scratch the
gigachad scp096 would undoubtedly begin
a downward spiral the shy guy is a
creature so insecure in itself and its
appearance that it kills anyone who's so
much such as glances at its face in
photos so being presented with the
living embodiment of an idea it could
never even hope to attain the biceps the
perfect right angled jawline it's all
too much sending scp096 into a complete
meltdown the creature would be
neutralized once and for all by the very
existence of the gigachad resulting in
his victory okay so we're 1 point to
scp096 and one to gigachad and most
people would maybe consider leaving it
there but not us we wanted more than
that you see we quickly realized that
the
anamatronic was based on a lot of
earlier iterations of the gigachad meme
don't get us wrong that version of the
ultimate man could still easily destroy
the shy guy but around March of 2021 the
infamous photoshopped images of erns kov
started to be used in slightly different
formats that's the thing about memes
they're not only Immortal forever logged
in the ancient texts of the Wayback
machine and compilation videos here on
YouTube but memes are also adaptable
they can evolve and change finding new
variations as time goes on as such the
average fan versus average enjoyer meme
saw a new use of the gigachad before the
gigachad this notion of the ideal Ultram
masculine specimen was based on let's be
honest some pretty outdated ideas about
what it means to be a man after all it
takes more than muscle to be a man man
not every man or masculine presenting
person has to work out until they're
built like a brick wall perhaps the real
Measure of a Man is how sincere
sensitive and supportive you can be as
well as standing by your interests
rather than caving to Old societal
standards of masculinity and after we
updated our data the
anamatronic outcome or what we like to
call scenario 3 the average SCP 096
enjoyer in this projection the Giga
Chad's true strength isn't just his
masculine physique and his unattainable
standards instead it's in part the
inherent adaptability of his status as a
meme but also his compassion just like
before he's more than able to resist SC
SCP 96's attacks and the creature's
insecurity comes out put on full display
when presented with Giga Chad's sharp
jawline but rather than overcome his
anomalous adversary by fighting him this
scenario sees the gigachad comforting
the shy guy through calm empathy and
words of affirmation he reminds scp096
that true acceptance of oneself comes
from within and that message strikes a
chord with the creature in a turn of
events none of us saw coming the
gigachad offers to help scp096 overcome
his crippling and deadly sense of
insecurity the pair start using the
on-site gym together after hours when
there aren't any innocent Foundation
Personnel around there Giga Chad not
only offers to introduce scp096 to an
exercise regimen if that's what the
creature wants but also helps the shy
guy work on his confidence they form a
friendship with scp096 taking a liking
to working out not because it wants to
be buff like its new friend the gigachad
but more so because doing so makes it
feel more comfortable in its own skin
scp096 gradually starts to like itself
more more even eating healthier thanks
to Giga Chad's advice eventually the shy
guy begins looking far more content and
even starts to develop self-confidence
it's not often that a story involving
scp096 exists with the creature getting
to achieve some semblance of Happiness
well there is one that comes to mind the
very same Shy Guy story that sent us on
this particular streak of pitting it
against the gigachad in the first place
but what if we put them together would
coming cross a refined scp096 spell the
N for the gigachad or would the muscular
masculine meme undo the Shy Guy's
previous happy ending well according to
the
formation who had studied the new and
improved scp096 in great detail she had
quite the understanding of him but
perhaps the photograph from the desire
camera was more of a metaphor than what
scp096 or David really desired wasn't
specifically the researcher who' studied
him but a partner who understood him
someone to call an equal enter the
gigachad according to the calculations
made by the
both strong and sensitive came bursting
into the foundation facility there the
moment he and David saw each other was
like the meeting of an Unstoppable force
and an immovable object neither one
rushed to solve the encounter with
violence both the gigachad and scp096
appreciated each other's aesthetic
appeal both were remarkably handsome and
one couldn't bear the thought of ridding
the world of the other instead it was
love at first sight both d David
formerly known as scp096 and the
gigachad fell head over heels in love
with each other and looking at both it
was not hard to see why they were a pair
of fine perfectly chiseled fellas and
they instantly hit it off the newly
established couple enjoyed each other's
company spending time in deep
conversations scp096 introducing his new
partner to his friends at the foundation
while gigachad was comfortable with his
own masculinity to express his feelings
towards David with without fear or
judgment no relationship is perfect of
course for a short time a sliver of
David's old self reemerged the shy guy
in him worried that perhaps his
relationship with the gigachad was based
purely on both of their extreme good
looks and was nothing more than
superficial but by being an embodiment
of healthy idealized masculinity the
gigachad was able to sense something was
wrong with David and rather do the
insecure thing of letting it Fester he
addressed it directly and they discussed
the issue in a healthy mature and
constructive way not just so they could
put scp096 as worry to rest but so that
both of them could further strengthen
their relationship and grow as people
and of course gigachad wasn't just
attracted to scp096 is refined good
looks far from being superficial he
recognized that David was a complete
person beautiful both inside and out and
loved him as a whole not just because
they were both conventionally attractive
on the surface scp096 and the gigachad
stayed together for the rest of their
lives or as we decided to name this
fourth scenario from the
anamatronic through some nefarious means
a fateful postcard has been sent to one
of the residents of the murky Mysterious
aranam Island living on this particular
Island was already a strange and scary
enough existence given the the horrors
the inhabitants of anaram share their
home with but perhaps the only thing
just as horrible as life on that island
was being sent a postcard sure that
doesn't sound all that horrible
postcards are usually used to show a
corner of the world far away and extend
well wishes from friends or relatives on
vacations but ordinarily postcards don't
depict a photo of scp096 with the words
wish he was there scrolled on the other
side from its containment cell at the
SCP Foundation the shy guy instantly
sensed that somebody somewhere had seen
a picture of its face breaking down into
an enraged fit of homicidal insecurity
scp096 immediately broke from its
containment chamber and made a
CrossCountry beeline heading straight
for arinum at anomalously accelerated
speeds little did the creature or the
foundation know that the shy guy was
being led straight into a trap and the
poor island resident who had received
the chilling postcard while they were
unlucky enough to be the bait while the
SCP Foundation started frantically
trying to track down where it had gone
the shy guy had already made its way to
a wooden cabin belonging to the
unfortunate postcard recipient emerging
from the now emptied home once the owner
was no more scp096 would have returned
to his cell just as quickly as he left
that is if he wasn't the only monstrous
creature on the island a loud and sudden
noise caught the creatur's attention the
sound of an old steam train whistle it
rang out once more from somewhere off in
the distance but there was so much thick
fog hanging in the air around arinum
that it was almost impossible to see
anything especially with how dark it was
the second time the whistle sounded it
was closer but there was another sound
too and not the loud chugging of a steam
engine that you would expect it was an
erratic heavy thuing the noise of lots
of something drumming against the ground
causing the Earth itself to shutter legs
they were the steps of multiple huge
legs crawling across the surface of the
island heading straight towards scp096 a
third piercing whistle rang out even
closer still this time the orange glow
of a l could be seen dulled by the
surrounding fog but getting brighter and
clearer as it came closer the light was
casting Shadows against the dark fog
long spinley shapes of spidery
appendages until before the Shy Guy's
eyes a creature of pure nightmares came
bursting out of the fog it was a
monstrous sight even to scp096 its body
was the Red Front engine of an
old-fashioned steam train hoisted off
the ground by four pairs of enormous
black spinley spider-like legs that
propelled the Beast forwards at a
terrifying speed able to move without
the limitations of needing to follow a
railroad track the monster was barreling
towards scp096 with a twisted smile on
its grotesque face at the front of the
locomotive was its circular face with
its unnaturally white eyes and a mouth
that sported rows of razor sharp teeth
all covered in blood this hellish
Abomination a being that was part steam
engine and part giant spider was the
terror of arinum himself the carnivorous
Cho Chu Charles seeing Charles racing
towards them on its eight spider legs
would be enough to make anyone freeze up
and stop in their tracks out of sheer
Terror and scp096 was compelled to do
the same except the terrifying train
creatures pale eyes were looking
directly at the shy guy as Charles sized
the anomaly up as its next meal he was
looking at it and that meant scp096
had to kill him the question was how
could it how could the skinny spinley
humanoid HED to even fight something
like Choo Charles he was much bigger
even more fearsome but as quick as
Charles could move on his spidery legs
he was not faster than SCP 09 six in the
blink of an eye the shy guy raced off
shrieking and sobbing in despair leaving
Charles to continue roaming his island
territory in search of other human
inhabitants to terrorize scp096 had
retreated to some nearby Woods quick
enough to move out of Charles's path
somewhere it could hide for now but the
shy guy could feel a familiar painful
feeling almost pulling him back towards
Cho Chu Charles right back into Harm's
Way SC p096 possessed an inescapable
compulsion to kill anyone who looked at
its face and that seemed to include
horrifying part train part spider
hybrids it was a fact of the shy guys's
very existence he had to go after
whoever looked at him and make them pay
in fact it took all the creatures Own
Strength not to instantly rush back over
to Charles to try scp096 knew that if it
did then there was little chance it
would survive coming face to train phas
with the terror of arinum however while
it was watching Choo Chu Charles from a
safe distance seeing him crawl across
the landscape on his multiple legs that
SC scp096 noticed something it was
another light obscured by the fog but
this one was much higher up one could
almost mistake it for the moon if it
wasn't getting closer all the while
accompanied by the sound of woring
rotors well the shy guy had been evading
Cho Chu Charles the SCP Foundation had
been tirelessly trying to track down
down its location and now they'd found
their runaway anomaly here on Aron niram
Island as the chopper carrying the
mobile task force Drew nearer the
tyrannical train turned and took notice
to scp096 the foundation's arrival could
have meant a way home and away from the
spidery steam engine but to Charles the
approaching chopper meant only one thing
a new source of food Captain one of the
MTF troops aboard the chopper called
over his headset what is it do we have
eyes on scp096
the captain replied before realizing
what he'd said well not eyes on because
then it would have jumped up onto the
chopper and killed us all I mean is
there any sign of scp096 on the island
negative sir although you should
probably see this the soldier replied
begrudgingly the captain unbuckled
himself from this seat and snatched the
foundation operatives binoculars using
them to look down at arinum below it
didn't take him long to spot the massive
multi-legged monstrosity that was cho
cho Charles who had fallen still
waiting for the chopper to descend low
enough for him to reach good cravy what
on Earth is that thing the captain
exclaimed before taking another look
through the binoculars is that wait what
is an instance of SCP 2086 doing out
here SCP 2086 was an Infamous anomalous
species the foundation had encountered
before much like Charles they were
anthropod likee creatures with multiple
long legs that protruded from a body
resembling a man-made mode of Transport
however SCP 2086 is usually took on the
appearance of buses while in vehicle
form sir I I don't think that's an SCP
2086 the lookout replied to me it looks
more like an instance of SCP 3023
impossible all the way out here the
captain retorted we're nowhere near the
region where the anomaly occurs it could
have scurried its way from Germany and
taken Nest here sir the trooper
responded yet another anomaly that Choo
Chu Charles bore a striking resemblance
to SCP 3023 was a rare phenomenon that
that was known to occur at random but
was limited to a specific area of
central Germany the effect of this
phenomenon caused ordinary everyday
inanimate objects of any shape or size
to suddenly turn into aggressive spiders
sporting eight legs That Grew From
whatever was affected by SCP 3023
perhaps Chuchu Charles was indeed an
instance of SCP 3023 or some distant
evolutionary offshoot of SCP 2086 who
was hard to say for sure the only thing
for sure was that Charles was a
man-eating Beast more so than an
Insidious villain and being so highly
territorial he considered the entire
island of arinum to be his natural
habitat and his hunting ground anything
that arrived in his vicinity was prey to
the terrifying train and his ravenous
craving for human flesh meant he was
ready to attack the descending SCP
Foundation Chopper all right let's go go
go the MTF Captain called to to his
troops signaling them to start repelling
out of the helicopter and down to the
island keep your scramble goggles on Max
we still need to recapture 096 but first
priority is taking down this big ugly
beast wearing goggles specifically
designed to distort the shy guy from
their view the team began AB selling out
of the aircraft but Cho Chu Charles was
already waiting for them rearing back on
its four back legs the nightmarish train
spiders swiped at the descending MTF
operatives would first seem like an
instinctive uncoordinated assault
quickly became precise and Relentless
strikes as Charles sliced through some
of the cables the MTF troops were using
to repel down their Lifeline cut the
Unlucky Foundation operatives plummeted
from midair right down towards where the
terror of Aon niram was waiting for them
to fall a few of the mtfs made it to the
ground alive and immediately began
retaliating against Cho Chu Charles the
gunfire from their weapons flickered all
around the carnivorous creature but
their bullets could barely chip the red
paintwork on his steam TR train body
dashing towards his helpless human prey
on his many legs Charles began to Feast
then suddenly something started pulling
at one of his huge spider legs pulling
Charles back moments before he had a
chance to claim his latest victim the
captain of the foundation's MTF it was
scp096 having zipped out of hiding and
shrieking wildly as it used all of its
strength to wrench one of Cho Cho
Charles's multiple limbs angered that it
couldn't reach the MTF Captain the part
spider partk train hybrid stomped the
leg that was being pulled in a
successful attempt to free itself from
the shy guys's grip but in the same
instant scp096 used its anomalous speed
to reappear in front of the already
angered locomotive monster with his
railroad rage about to reach its
Breaking Point Charles entered into a
Relentless Rampage making quick work of
the leftover MTF troops before setting
his sight squarely on scp096 but doing
that was his biggest mistake now chuch
Chu Charles had seen the shy guy twice
and to the insecure anomaly that meant
Charles had to go traveling faster than
even the multi-legged monstrosity could
perceive scp096 began racing towards
chuch Chu Charles's many legs the shy
guy had realized that it didn't stand a
chance of dealing with the terror of
Aron niram the same way it handled all
the others that had seen its face so
instead it had settled on a new approach
specifically tailored to take down the
spider legged steam engine one by one
scp096 started knocking Charles's many
legs out from underneath him effectively
tripping him up over and over again the
shy guy moved so quick that the
cumbersome Charles could barely react in
time having one leg after the other
knocked out from beneath him causing him
to Tumble to the ground normally Choo
Cho Charles was smart enough to retreat
if he encountered something that could
fight back if he was injured badly
enough the spider like creature would
Scuttle out of Harm's Way in order to
heal his wounds but the rage at being
constantly tripped up by scp096 was
distracting Charles from the shy guys's
true Ploy with every leg it knocked out
from underneath the spidery steam train
scp096 had been gradually directing
Charles towards a nearby Gorge with a
terrifying burst of anomalous speed the
shy guy caused cho cho Charles to topple
over sideways rolling over himself until
he landed upside down in the bottom of
the rocky G Forge the multi-legged
locomotive Monster's spindly legs
flailed desperately as he tried to
reposition himself but with no luck
scp096 had managed what first seemed to
be impossible and beaten the terror of
Aon niram Cho Chu Charles or for now at
least silently passing through the inky
void of space a vessel was hurridly
making its way towards its destination
the craft was Sleek designed and built
by hands not of this world aboard one of
the occupants knelt before its Elders it
was time it gathered its Arsenal in a
methodical almost ceremonial fashion its
spear latched onto its back with its
survival gear a Medi kit containing
surgical equipment and specialized
serums it dawned its gauntlets then
reached for the final piece its mask
that had slipped over its face ready for
its task the creature boarded a smaller
Scout ship which was jettisoned and
began to descend toward the planet below
a world known as Earth on the surface of
the planet itself a technician was
sitting at his desk boards staring at
readouts from satellites and the endless
sweeping of a radar scanning the skies
above for any signs of disturbance for a
moment as the scoutcraft passed through
the atmosphere something happened that
broke the technician out of his boredom
there was a blip on the radar the tiny
detection of an unknown signal that of
an object traveling on a direct course
through the sky just as the technicians
started to take notice the approaching
ship activated a stealth mechanism
reflecting all light away from it in
order to render it almost invisible
while simultaneously becoming
undetectable to radar the blip vanished
from the screen and didn't reappear the
technician Shrugged thinking it was
probably nothing but an equipment glitch
besides the SCP Foundation didn't pay
him enough to follow up on every tiny
blimp a few hours later and several
continents away a mobile task force was
on an assignment the oppressive heat and
humidity of the londan Jungle was
bearing down on them especially in their
combat gear the operatives were all
feeling unbearably hot the foundation
researchers overseeing the mtfs mission
via satellite didn't have to contend
with the elements in the comfort of
their airconditioned Command Center but
little did they or their boots on the
ground know there was something else
visiting the rainforest 2o it had been
stalking the squad for a few miles now
and not not one of them had noticed just
as the creature planned a trio of red
laser beams cast three distinct dots
over one of the MTF operatives chest
suddenly a streak of energy shot through
the air crackling as it struck the agent
tearing through his chest and killing
him on the spot instinctively the
remaining troops turned and opened fire
at the treetop where the blast had come
from spraying a volley of bullets enough
to start shredding the wood of the tree
splinters and bark raining down they hit
nothing there was no sign of whoever or
whatever had fired that shot and killed
their teammate from behind them a pair
of discs with a row of long fanlike
blades around their Edge flew through
the air there was so much force behind
the arm that threw them that the pair of
shuriken lifted two of the remaining MTF
soldiers off their feet and impaled them
to the trunks of nearby trees the last
remaining Foundation operative looked at
the bodies of his dead squadmates in
horror before turning and fleeing but
just as he ran for his life something
caught him it was transparent cloaked
and near impossible to see but it had
plunged a pair of blades into the MTF
trooper's chest lifting him off his feet
with ease as he screamed in pain an
invisible leathery skinned hand reached
for his throat and twisted and in an
instant with a sickening crack the man
was silent and dropped limply to the
floor from the command center watching
an AZ this imperceptible monster tore
through four of their finest operatives
with ease a pair of researchers turned
to look at each other the Expressions
they both wore were faces of sheer
disbelief they both had heard stories
instantly recognizing the destructive
Behavior but never thought they'd see or
not see it carried out for real we still
don't have a name for them do we
researcher Hall asked as the pair of
them walked briskly down the corridor ah
negative replied his counterpart
researcher D liero but the files we
acquired from military intelligence
suggests they've been coming to Earth
for decades centuries even the earliest
known encounter took place in the 1700s
uh can we negotiate with this one at all
Paul asked fully expecting the answer I
don't think they respond well to that
kind of Engagement diligo said they seem
to come to Earth with One Singular
purpose to hunt for sport well it it
seems so uh what about their
capabilities the senior researcher
pressed their technology is pretty
Advanced even compared to some of the
things we've seen the other explained on
top of that they're fast strong and
completely ruthless pretty much apex
predator according to Intel the
instances of these creatures that have
previously visited Earth have displayed
a sort of tribal nature care to
elaborate how probe uh based on the
files their hunt seemed partially
recreational but also like some kind of
ritual to prove themselves as capable or
to challenge themselves that gives me an
idea the researcher replied contact
containment area 25b if we play this
right we can bag one of these creatures
and bring it in for testing time seemed
to race by by as Hall and D leria were
bundled aboard of transport and taken
directly to containment area 25b a
facility built by the foundation
specifically to house a particularly
dangerous anomaly within the hour the
two researchers were standing facing a
huge Stone Cube its dark surface
sporting a number of symbols engraved
into it growing impatient knowing their
window of opportunity was rapidly
closing Hall turned to one of the
foundation Personnel stationed within
the primary containment Zone around SCP
07 six Play It Again be instructed wake
him up hitting a button a recorded
message began to play over the
facility's loudspeakers it had been
translated into an ancient Sumerian
dialect that the entity within the stone
Cube had historically shown a preference
for come on out the message stated we
know you don't think any of us are worth
your time but we remember Omega 7 you
agreed to work with us before even
though you don't think we present enough
of a challenge to you but we may have
found something that will an adversary
that you could have the privilege of
besting in combat there was a brief
moment of silence before the stone began
to rumble the security Personnel on site
tensed up gripping their weapons shakely
nervous hands slowly the circular lock
on the side of the cube began twisting
the door had kept sealed beginning to
open are you sure we can do this how
asked eligio if SCP 076 isn't willing to
cooperate this could go south real
quickly and God forbid what if someone
somebody found out what we're having him
do Hall didn't answer instead watching
as the door to the cube finally opened
and a lean man in his late 20 stepped
out his gray eyes stared out of a mess
of jet black hair his body adorned with
tattoos of Arcane runes and a cult
imagery the sneering faces of demons
over his olive skin as the guards around
him nervously raised their weapons at
the ready SCP 076-2 casually stro up to
researcher Hall until the two were
inches away from each other
where Abel asked fitting him with a
Communications earpiece and having him
board a transport Abel was sent directly
towards the last known coordinates of
the now deceased MTF deep in the heart
of the londan Jungle sat at top a tree
as the aircraft made its approach the
creature had lowered its cloaking device
certain it was alone as it polished a
skull it had collected from one of the
ill- fated operatives the Predator was a
member of a species known as the Yuta
one of the few details about its race
that diligo files hadn't mentioned
everything else was accurate though it
was indeed a hunter here to claim
trophies as proof of its skill these
trophies happen to be the skulls and
spines of whatever it killed hearing the
sound of an incoming vehicle the
Predator instinctively reached for a
control on its left wrist Gauntlet its
cloaking device reactivated bending the
light away from itself to render the
alien Hunter nearly invisible through
the lenses of its biomask the Predator
watched The Craft pass overhead and the
shape of a single humanoid Heat
Signature dropping from it and landing
in the rainforest trekking through the
Lush vegetation Abel walked towards the
location he had been given it always
irked The Immortal barbarian when the
foundation attempted to use him to
perform their menial Dirty Work to Able
such tasks were beneath him but he had
been promised to fight with a worthy
adversary and that was the only reason
he had agreed to undertake this Mission
looking around as he reached to clearing
there was no sign of the MTF agents
until that is Abel craned his neck
upwards and found them something had
meticulously gathered up the bodies and
hung them from the branches by their
legs it felt distinctly like a warning
as well as a taunting gloat every
indicator pointed to this being the
action of a creature that was marking
its new found territory with a wave of
his hand Abel pulled a black edged sword
out of a pocket Dimension holding his
weapons and held the blade at the ready
looking down he saw three points of red
light had appeared on his bare chest
just as able caught side of the Treetops
where the lasers were coming from a bolt
of high energy plasma was fired towards
him within the same Split Second he
hurled his sword in the direction of his
invisible enemy the blast struck him and
knocked him down searing his flesh not
that Abel could feel pain at the same
time his sword spun through the air and
cleaved through the branch where the
Predator had been perched causing the
creature to drop to the Jungle floor
with a thud as the yacha stood up it
noticed its Gauntlet was sparking having
sustained damage in the fall now its
cloaking device was flickering on and
off the Predator knew it would need to
repair its equipment but first and
foremost needed to collect a trophy from
its latest kill the creature strowed
towards where Abel was laying a Scorch
Mark left by the plasma Caster burned
into his flesh its cloaking device still
malfunctioning the hunter reached down
to claim its prize Abel's eyes suddenly
snapped open and caught the creature by
surprise reeling his leg back he
delivered a sharp kick that sent the
Predator hurling backwards despite it
being well over 7 ft tall and F 520 lb
of armor and alien muscle Abel hurly
stood back up facing off against the
alien Warrior as it too Drew itself to
full height The Gauntlet on its left
wrist continued to spit Sparks until the
Predator reached a clawed digit over and
pressed to control with an electronic
beep its cloak deactivated fully and the
hunter was revealed it was tall standing
on two legs like a man it seemed life
and agile but clearly almost as strong
as Abel himself judging by how muscular
it was long appendages resembling locks
of hair protruded from its head behind a
metal face plate a mask covered the true
face of the creature below a clicking
chittering noise emanated from beneath
the Predator's biomask as it reached for
a sash that went across its front and
produced a pair of small metal circles
able flexed his shoulders and ran at the
creature the Predator hurled both its
discs at AEL curved blades extending
from both of them as they spun through
the air Abel ducked out of the path of
one shuriken narrowly dodging the second
as he charged the alien Hunter reaching
for its back the Predator produced The
Long ornate handle of its Combi stick
both ends of its telescopic spear
extended and the hunter began racing
forward to clash head-on with its new
found prey it plunged the spear right
through Abel with all its strength
lifting the Barbarian off his feet on
the end of its weapon out of nowhere as
CP 076 produced another of his swords
the Predator turning to look in
confusion at the weapon that had
seemingly just appeared in the hand of
what it had taken for an ordinary human
catching the offworld Game Hunter by
surprise able swept the sword through
the air cleaving the creature spear in
two causing him to drop back to the
ground landing on his feet following it
with the second Swift swing of his blade
Abel brought the weapon down on a slash
that cut across the creature's chest it
sliced through the thick reptilian hide
of the Predator leaving a streak of
fluorescent green blood oozing from its
torso the creature roared in pain it
sounded like a call of a lion echoing
through the trees in retaliation the
Predator extended a pair of blades
contained in its right Gauntlet and
swipe them at AEL the wrist blades
narrowly missed his face as he dodged an
incoming attack only to be caught by the
creature's other hand it gripped his
head and plunged downwards knocking AEL
over and sending him face first into the
rainforest floor reaching for his
cloaking device control the Predator
disappeared retreating into the jungle
to tend to its heavily ble in wound what
manner of devil is this creature Hall
Abel yelled at the researcher over his
earpiece hacking branches out of his
path with his sword as he followed the
trail of luminous green left by the
wounded Hunter it's a warrior From
Another World Hall replied a hunter that
tracks its prey by their body heat
considers itself honorable but often
likes to go after more dangerous targets
to challenge itself not unlike you AEL I
am nothing like this demon the Barbarian
shouted in Fury this gutless monster has
no honor
if it did it would not give itself such
an unfair Advantage nor would it run
away when wounded a true warrior would
be happy to die A Warrior's death in
single combat and would not rely on all
its fancy Weaponry well from what we can
tell these things have their own codes
of sorts diario's voice said over the
calms you might not think of this Hunter
as honorable but it definitely thinks of
itself that way maybe use that to your
advantage I do not need to be lectured
by the likes of you Abel interrupted you
have not known the heat of battle none
of you at the foundation have I will
follow the trail of this cowardly
BEAST's blood and cleave its foul head
from its shoulders unbeknownst to Abel
high above a branch the Predator was
watching him its biomask had been zoomed
in on him the hunter listening to the
barbarian's outrage it turned to the
task at hand opening up its medic kit
and producing the surgical tools within
as it tended to the Deep green cut
across its chest stifling Roars of pain
beneath its Mask The Predator stapled
the injury closed and applied a solvent
to cauterize it night was beginning to
fall and Abel had long since lost the
trail of green blood frustrated he
thought back to what the puny
researchers at the foundation had told
him of his alien adversary if it
believed itself to be honorable to have
a code then perhaps using that to lure
it out to face him might work with the
sun rapidly disappearing beyond the tree
line Abel gathered a number of branches
hacking them off trees with his sword
and fashioning them into burning torches
he placed them in a circle around the
circumference of a clearing creating a
makeshift gladiatorial Arena he could
feel his blood boiling the urge to
defeat this monster making him see
throwing his head back and beating a
fist against his chest Abel roared up at
the dark sky come out Hunter he howled
show yourself come on do it I'm right
here watching him from afar hidden by
its cloak the Predator recognized what
was happening this was a challenge
a direct call to engage in single combat
refusing this Challenge and shooting its
prey dead would be quicker easier but
the hunter knew it was being watched and
therefore judged with a growl it dropped
to the ground and paced towards the
circle able turned as the Predator
revealed itself appearing almost from
thin air as it did he drew one of his
weapons and stood ready to fight the
hunter Shrugged off the technology had
carried on its back dropping the plasma
caster and its medic kit before reaching
up and pulling off its mask
its face was grotesque four hooked
mandibles surrounding its mouth flared
in Anger you are one ugly Abel said only
to be interrupted by the Predator
extending the blades from its Gauntlet
and letting out another beastial Roar
holding his sword Aloft Abel gave a
goting beckon to his opponent as the
pair of them circled one another finally
the creature gave in and lunched at him
swiping its pair of razor sharp serrated
blades at AEL he swung his sword and at
the last second deflected the oncoming
BL blow with a clang of metal reaching
into his pocket di mention Abel pulled a
second weapon out in his other hand and
swiped at the Predator slicing through
the creature's hide and leaving another
gaping wound at its thigh roaring in
Fury the Predator launched another
strike able blocked the attack yet again
this time by Crossing his swords but the
Predator barged forward driving its
blades into the prey's chest and pinning
his two weapons against him the
Monstrous alien viciously headbutted
Abel the hooks of its mandible
scratching his face as it did before
reaching up to the back of his neck with
its free hand Abel could feel the sheer
strength of the hunter lifting him off
his feet ready to twist his neck and
pull his head off to claim it as a
trophy kicking the predator in the chest
AEL used the force of the impact to push
himself free from the creature's grip
back flipping through the air and
Landing a few feet away his swords
clattered together as they dropped to
the ground The Immortal Barbarian
summoning another and immediately
charging at the Predator it had been
winded by the kick and barely recovered
in time to defend itself as the blade
swung for its neck the Predator
staggered back green blood oozing from
its hide and pouring from its mouth that
blow had mortally wounded it it was
bleeding heavily and knew it might not
survive this hunt but it refused to be
bested by a human even one as seemingly
invulnerable as AEL punching over
listening to him slowly approaching to
deliver the killing blow the Predator
tapped a series of controls on its
Gauntlet a gradually accelerating
beeping began emanating from the device
turning around at the last second the
alien Hunter impaled Abel before he was
upon it skewering SCP 076-2 on its wrist
blades his sword had been raised above
his head to plunge through the creature
and even while impaled AEL was able to
deliver the final blow stabbing the
Predator while it too had stabbed him
the pair were locked in a stalemate
angrily roaring each other until an
explosion of energy burst from the
Hunter's gauntlets reducing both Abel
and the Predator to Adams watching from
their satellite feed Hall and digigo
side they wouldn't have their specimen
for testing but at least they knew that
Abel would eventually resurrect within
the stone cube of SCP
0761 but even higher up than their
satellite someone else was watching a
group of predators growled and chittered
amongst themselves having witnessed from
their ship as one of their own had died
in a battle with Abel although there was
no way of knowing the noises The Hunting
Party were making could have been
expressions of disappointment at their
fallen brother or a declaration of war
when you work for the SCP Foundation you
need to be ready for anything that's why
as part of the elite foundation training
regimen senior researchers and guards
are always running tests even against
things that aren't recorded anomalies
under the opes of the foundation that's
why today for a real change of pace here
at SCP explained we're not talking about
the SCP Foundation we're talking about
madeup monst monster stories Crow
sourced over the Internet we're seeing
how the foundation might F against
iconic Creepy Pasta monsters and Maniacs
like Herobrine Jeff the Killer the
Slenderman eyess Jack smile dog and many
many more we've even created all new
mobile task forces to take each one down
so could any of them best the
foundation's best and brightest let's
take a look and find out and be sure to
tell us which is your favorite Creepy
Pasta entity down in the comments below
let's get creepy Jeff the Killer first
up we've got everyone's favorite
disfigured knife wielding homicidal
teenager whether it's his terrifying
Visage or the iconic go to sleep
catchphrase that's forever carved into
your mind there are probably a lot of
people out there who have lost nights of
sleep worrying that this pale-faced
monster could be crawling through their
window but we know what you're probably
wondering isn't Jeff just a serial
killer why would the SCP Foundation use
up its time chasing down any old regular
human murderer we'd ask for you to think
again Jeff has displayed Feats that
clearly Mark him as anomalous despite
suffering debilitating Burns to his face
and body he still shows superhuman
strength agility and durability he's
also able to see without eyelids
suggesting some supernal element is at
play victims have also reported him
dodging shotgun blasts while stalking
prey so how would the foundation catch
him seeing as Jeff's modus operandi is
breaking into the homes of his victims
while they sleep the best method would
be staking out a neighborhood where he's
been shown to be active keeping close
observations on houses and even setting
up Personnel from mobile task force
Sigma 9 my name is Jeff in vacant houses
as honey traps Jeff is undeniably strong
fast and tough but if attacked and
surrounded by operative lives with
Superior Tactics he could be subdued
without casualties then it would just be
a matter of transferring him to a
standard high security humanoid
containment cell speaking of horrifying
creatures that come to you in the dead
of night The Rake this Supernatural
entity has been around for almost a
thousand years as far as scattered
reports are aware it's also been
reported across four continents and a
huge number of locations within those
continents the most recent recently it's
been reported in rural New York State
and Idaho in the early 2000s The Rake is
an inhuman Beast most often known for
its large frightening eyes and its Long
rake-like Claws not only does the
monster feed on human beings but it also
produces a traumatic level of fear in
its victims thankfully an entity like
this is far more familiar territory for
the SCP Foundation using their
state-of-the-art WebCrawler software
they could could catalog reported
sightings as they happen and use
clusters of these sightings to
triangulate the location of the rake and
dispatch field agents to perform
reconnaissance missions from there it
would just be a matter of waiting to
strike and sending in Mobile task force
Zeta 13 rake steppers fitted with Dr
Dan's scramble goggles to prevent them
from being affected by the seemingly
Cognito hazardous effects of viewing the
rake when the creature is placed in
containment and kept in a state of
Perpetual bright light it would simply
be a matter of applying a Scranton
reality anchor to prevent the creature
from somehow phasing out of containment
just make sure you avoid its big staring
eyes in the meantime though that won't
be a problem with the next Creepy Pasta
monster eyess Jack this stealthy
creature has its no eyes on one thing
and one thing only your kidneys and
unless you want to die or spend the rest
of your life on a dialysis machine we
recommend you keep your distance from
him he's discreet devious and diabolical
and if you wake up in the middle of the
night to see him staring down at you it
may be the last time your body is able
to filter toxins out of its blood
naturally thankfully we have a way to
make the foundation put a stop to his
organ harvesting ways sometimes to catch
a jack you need to use a jack there's no
way to catch Isa Jack without delicious
live kidney bait so weed recommends
sending in someone who has kidneys to
spare Dr Jack brigh brigh could be the
perfect bait without losing his life
luring idolist Jack into a decoy house
while mobile task force gamma 391 Hit
the Road Jack prepares to Spring their
cunning trap and plunge this unpleasant
kidney muncher into a humanoid
containment cell forever but our next
Creepy Pasta entity doesn't want your
kidneys it wants your life Smile Dog our
next next entity seems like a harmless
little JPEG to the untrained eye a
little freaky sure but nothing to lose
your mind over but we know that there's
far more to this grinning husky than
meets the eye if some reports are to be
believed this image may even be
connected to the Devil Himself if you're
unlucky enough to see this image in the
world it may already be too late for you
those who see it typically as an email
attachment from a mysterious address
spend the last week of their life in a
hell of the Mind before eventually
succumbing to oblique and mysterious
death it's a classic Cognito hazardous
image and the most frightening part is
that it's self-propagating with one of
the only ways to even mildly alleviate
the effects seeming to be spreading the
word by subjecting another person to
this nightmare that's when we bring in
Mobile task force row 19 Naughty Dog an
elite group of hardened military
programmers handpicked from the CI I's
cyber warfare unit they use their very
particular set of skills to design
WebCrawler software that Roots out and
takes down Smile Dog images across the
web and hopefully one day find the
origin of this whole thing the next
creature on the other hand we've given
up on finding the origin of that the
expressionless this entity kind of looks
like a terrifying store window mannequin
except rather than modeling fast fashion
she prefers to swallow cats hole and
murder Hospital staff oh and she also
calls herself God isn't she just so
quirky her primary abilities seem to be
extreme strength and large sharp teeth
that will easily Ren through human flesh
thankfully not anything the SCP
Foundation hasn't dealt with countless
times before seeing as the only recorded
incident involving the expression list
took place at a hospital in Los Angeles
that would be the most sensible area to
stake out a detail from the creature 's
original encounter is also telling it
reacted severely to the doctor's
attempts to sedate it implying that
chemical sedation is an effective method
of incapacitating the beast that's why
every member of mobile task force Kappa
99 ain't no dummy is a sharpshooter with
a tranquilizer rifle capable of putting
a hippo to sleep with a single shot
she'll probably feel less like a god in
her containment cell but while this
monster is expressionless the next one
has one very notable
expression Mr Widemouth compared to some
of our other Creepy Pasta contenders Mr
Widemouth may not look like much but
that our dear friends is exactly what
this nasty little malactor wants you to
think he may look like Gizmo's slightly
demented cousin but his intentions are
even more Sinister than that of your
average Gremlin if you're a kid home on
a sick day Mr Widemouth might strike up
a conversation after gaining your trust
he'll he'll try to lure you to his
special place beyond the trees for some
fun but take it from us all you'll find
out there is your doom this crafty
little creep small stature and
manipulative stealth abilities might
pose somewhat of a challenge for the SCP
Foundation but that doesn't mean they
can't get him with a little intelligence
and elbow grease mobile task force Alpha
18 the smile Smashers will follow
reports of children disappearing from
their isolated homes under mysterious
circumstances then using an extra
strength butterfly net straight from the
folks at Foundation R and D they can
chase down and capture the nasty little
monster but that won't be the case for
this next demonic offering no this
Creepy Pasta Legend is the one that
captures you no end house in recent
years there's been a spike in interest
in so-called extreme haunted houses if
you're not sure what these places are
like basically picture a CIA black site
with the occasional plastic skeleton
it's all waterboarding stress positions
and car batteries but even those places
are nothing compared to the nightmare of
no end house it's a moving possibly even
sentient spatial anomaly hiding in a
haunted house attraction and if you find
yourself inside best believe you're
never going to see the outside ever
again thankfully mobile task force Delta
35 Mam's Bane are on the case around
Halloween every year they use web
crawlers to detect chatter around no end
House events so they can swoop in and
intercept preventing hapless Thrill
Seekers from being devoured by the house
and providing amnestic treatment for
anyone who has too close of a call sadly
the foundation will not be able to
provide refunds for those who already
paid speaking of paying you'll really
pay if you end up in our next Creepy
Pasta location of Doom abandoned by
Disney mowgly Kingdom an abandoned
tropical Disney attraction based on The
Jungle Book movie is abandoned for a
reason it's a hot bed for anomalous
activity including freakishly large
mutant snakes reports of ghostly
activity and most prominent of all a
terrifying Photon negative Mickey Mouse
that stalks any hapless Urban explorers
who happen to find their way onto the
site of course the Walt Disney
Corporation keeps it all hush hush and
the SCP Foundation is happy to give them
a hand on that front even if the
frightening photo negative Mickey was
removed from the site it's likely the
other may appear and continue haunting
the site and seeing that the site cannot
be moved as a whole the foundation's
best bet is to form a perimeter around
the abandoned Disney attraction
preventing anything normal from getting
in and anything abnormal from getting
out mobile task force Omega 17 sons of
shiran are ever Vigilant and maintain a
strong presence in the surrounding area
but you don't need to go anywhere for
this next anomalous Terror if you're a
big Nintendo fan it might be sitting in
your house right now Ben Drowned this
haunted NES cartridge of The Legend of
Zelda Majora's Mask contains the
Restless Spirit of its last owner a guy
named Ben who well drowned if you slot
This creepy little gaming experience
into your Nintendo Entertainment System
you'll soon find that the soul of Ben is
communicating with you directly telling
you about how he died and why his
Consciousness lingers on embedded in the
code of the game thankfully other than
the psychological trauma of experiencing
the game you're unlikely to be actually
harmed by playing it however mobile task
force beta 51 Gamers don't have rights
are still on the case they'll try to
intercept all cursed copies of the game
and administer amnestics to anyone who
is unfortunate enough to play it while
it is still undenied L spooky it does
feel like a relief to finally find a
safe class anomaly on this list the same
can sadly not be said about our next
creature the Goatman if you're a fan of
camping then this malicious mimic is
going to be your worst nightmare this
monster has existed as a fixture of
Terror in everything from a number of
Native American mythologies to iconic
4chan green Tex posts you may be
thinking oh What's So Scary About a goat
but this thing is no goat
aside from the fact that it's the
greatest of all time at getting you to
crap your cargo shorts in the woods
first you'll smell blood in the air and
then feel an odd electrical static like
the feeling all around you right before
a lightning strike then you'll hear
noises strange noises something not
quite like a voice like an animal throat
straining to form human words that's
when you might notice your group of
friends has one more person than you
remembered and the one thing worse than
noticing that is not noticing it because
if you don't you may end up as the
shape-shifting goatman's latest victim
mobile task force Theta 11 got your goat
are constantly on the hunt for this one
but it's extreme intelligence and
ethereal nature make it a nightmare to
track but forget nightmares to track
it's time for Laughing Jack this candy
stripe clown from hell is a really nasty
customer definitely do not engage unless
you've got a Scranton reality anchor on
hand and you've got a backup from
members of mobile task force Iota 40 put
Jack in the Box as a former imaginary
friend gone Rogue Laughing Jack is a
semi- intangible reality warper of
considerable power he targets his
victims with sadistic Glee pulling them
into his dark carnival to experience all
kinds of nasty tortures Laughing Jack
shows No Remorse giggling while
committing every evil act you can
imagine you'll probably only find this
clown funny if you're already a depraved
serial killer and his sense of humor is
likely to utterly break your mind unless
you've been given amnestic treatment
from the SCP Foundation this is an
anomaly that would probably get along
swimmingly with a
cp16 the old man they could chat over a
few drinks one evening and share notes
on how to cause the maximum pain to
their hapless victims that being said
few people understand maximum pain more
than the next horrifying Abomination on
our roster the Russian sleep experiment
test subjects as anyone familiar with
the work of Gru division P will tell you
the Soviets performed some pretty
horrific occult activities throughout
the 20th century one of the most
disturbing of these was the infamous
Russian sleep experiment where in a
group of unfortunate political prisoners
were doused on a classified anomalous
gas that robbed them of their ability to
sleep a chemical compound that the
scientists hope might increase the
productivity of their workers and
Soldiers by eliminating sleep instead
over several terrifying days the
chemical and the sleep deprivation that
ensued caused the subjects to instead
become demonic monsters while current
accounts of the story suggest that all
the subjects were killed we can't say
for sure there weren't more out there or
that the experiment hasn't been repeated
as such mobile task force Omicron 899 is
constantly on the lookout for freakish
skeletal men wandering through the woods
never sleeping outside the dark forests
where Siberian Googs used to be based
better safe than sorry right though of
course you won't feel safe at all if you
spent your childhood watching scaring
media like horror movies or Eerie SCP
YouTube channels like And subscribe by
the way or scariest of all a strange
little puppet show called Candle Cove
feel little chill go down your spine oh
yes you remember this show don't you you
love seeing all those cute little
puppets going on swashbuckling pirate
Journeys on their adorable boat the
laughing stock though there was always
that villain wasn't there you think his
name was jawone but that's not what you
called him you called him the skin taker
because he always had that long cloak
made of tanned human skin you also
remember that one episode that was just
all the characters screaming I mean how
could you possibly forget and most of
all you remember asking your mom about
it and her telling you that you never
actually watched a show called Candle
Cove you just sat around watching static
for hours on end of course the SCP
Foundation keeps close TS on everything
related to this traumatic childhood
memory broadcasts of the show are
seemingly impossible to contain all the
foundation can really do is track down
people who have seen it and provide
amnestic treat treatment though trust us
there are things that will make your
childhood far worse than just watching
Candle Cove like running into this next
iconic monster the Slender Man this
terrifying entity is powerful as he is
Iconic a shape-shifting faceless
tentacled nightmare in a three-piece
suit who likes to hide in forests and
abandon buildings either stealing
children away or influencing their minds
until they become his proxies
Supernatural servants who do anything
their inhuman Master asks them to the
Slenderman is one of the most powerful
monsters in all of creepy pasta so the
foundation certainly has their hands
full with keeping his tentacles Under
Wraps all that mobile task force ch90
Marble Hornets can do is track sightings
and keep children out of the woods when
the danger of potential Slenderman
encounters arises getting him actually
contained basically seems out of the
question hm
after all this we might need to relax
maybe grabbing a nice sugar-free soda
and playing a session of Minecraft might
make us feel better we'll be safe there
right well probably unless we encounter
Herobrine the SCP Foundation fnally
enough is actually no stranger to
anomalies trapped in Minecraft they've
got SCP 4335 a welt in The Crucible to
thank for that but this Minecraft horror
story is a little more personal
Herobrine is a mysterious user with the
Minecraft default skin except with one
difference completely white eyes this
mysterious figure invades different
Minecraft servers acting incredibly
strange towards the people who created
them what makes this more than just some
random troll well according to Legends
Herobrine is the manifestation of the
Dead Brother of Minecraft's creator
Notch naturally the foundation doesn't
want people running into ghosts on
Minecraft so they dispatch mobile task
force chai 69 blocked and reported to
quarantine any servers where Herobrine
is cited and spread misinformation that
the crafty little entity had never
actually existed in the first place what
is the truth of the situation it's
unclear and that's exactly how the
foundation likes it so there we have it
folks how the SCP Foundation would
counteract some of the most infamous
Creepy Pasta creeps and creatures out
there which was your favorite do we miss
any and would you like to see any of
these expanded into a full video in the
future future let us know down in the
comments if you
[Laughter]
dare there's never a good day for a
super villain attack or a tense Feud
with your closest sibling and for the
Mighty Thor this day was turning out to
be both as the self-proclaimed strongest
Avenger flung his body across the planet
Earth using his trusty Magical Hammer
molier the Asgardian stealed himself for
yet another confrontation with his evil
half brother Loki the god of Mischief as
per usual Loki was terrorizing the
humans of a random City using his
Illusions to manifest imaginary dragons
and other ferocious beasts and what was
also usual is Thor had no idea what his
brother's motive or endgame was all the
God of Thunder knew was that this kind
of trickery dickery would not be stood
for while these terrible creatures
weren't real they were still very
frightening to the earthlings civilians
were running around in every direction a
away from Loki and this was causing all
kinds of chaos and traffic disturbances
regardless of what Loki's plan was Thor
knew that his brother had to be stopped
before things escalated further on Earth
humans needed to rely on vehicles to get
around and even the slightest
inconvenience in transportation could
lead to disaster Thor touched down in
the same City Square where Loki was
unleashing his horde of makeb believe
monsters Landing in a classically cool
superhero way hello brother Thor
proclaimed I don't suppose you'll be
stopping this without a fight Loki
smiled a mischievous smile and replied
aror we meet again and once again you're
wrong I can stop this anytime I want
Loki swiftly moved his hand through the
air casting a new spell to dismiss his
diabolical decoys the Illusions
dispersed naturally and soon the two
brothers were facing each other
one-on-one
see Loki chuckled Thor was rightly
confused by his brother's unpredictable
actions he pointed molier towards Loki
in an accusatory manner no Illusions no
sorcery what are you really playing at
Loki said Thor and then Loki reached
into his robes and produced an unusual
cube-shaped object as his good brother
was all too aware this particular Cube
was the latest in a long line of
mysterious and Powerful cubes that Loki
had used for his various evil plans Loki
juggled the unknown Cube from one hand
to the other then waved it in the air in
front of Thor and began to laugh
maniacally all I need to do is open this
ancient box of mysteries and I'll become
completely Unstoppable don't you dare do
it Loki Thor shouted that sort of power
will be misused in your hands that's
precisely the point Loki continued to
laugh then reached for what appeared to
be the lid of the cube he grabbed the
top of it and made a show of beginning
to twist this sent Thor's heroic
instincts into high gear and he threw
molier at the cube knocking it out of
Loki's grasp as the cube flew away from
the grinning villain Thor Dove to
retrieve it before his brother had the
chance he soon held the strange item in
one hand while calling mol back to the
other as Thor stared at the cube
pondering its purpose Loki stretched out
his hands in desperation oh no not my
Cube if you open it now my plan is
doomed Loki pleaded Thor responded with
a laugh of his own nice try brother but
I'm going to open it and so the God of
Thunder did Thor popped the Cube's lid
and braced himself for whatever Cosmic
force was about to be released but for
some reason nothing happened still
curious Thor took a cautious look inside
as it turned out the only thing within
this apparently non-magical Cube was
what appeared to be a fully developed
photograph what an Odin's name is this
Thor removed the image and held it close
to his face it appeared to depict an
emaciated pale humanoid with long
spindly limbs standing in the corner of
a compact room with smooth metal walls
in all his many years traveling the nine
Realms Thor had never seen anything like
it whatever the creature actually was it
certainly did not look happy of course
what Thor was actually looking at was a
photo taken of scp096 inside of its
containment unit at the foundation the
shy guy as its nickname suggested did
not like having its face looked at even
via secondary means such as photography
or video recording the anomalous
humanoid sense of Shame about its own
appearance was so great that a mere
moment after Thor fixed his Asgardian
Eyes Upon its Visage scp096 began to
stir in its containment unit the
creature wailed and covered its face
with both of its hands on its long siney
arms it screamed and carried on for a
duration of 2 minutes after which point
scp096 sprinted towards the steel walls
of its containment unit and smashed
through reaching speeds greater than
most Motor Vehicles scp096 began to zero
in on Thor's location as was always the
case when another being saw its face the
shy guy was compelled to utterly
annihilate the offending Observer with
its bare hands Thor himself had no idea
that scp096 was in route and continued
to squint at the photograph perplexed by
the mysterious entity depict therein
Loki now resumed his mad laughter
because once more he had managed to
trick his foolish brother into falling
for one of his ingenious schemes make
sure to get a good look brother Loki
gloated yes look at the full creature
that will bring about your inevitable
destruction Thor was annoyed if you
think that showing me a gross picture of
some lonly wret will strike fear into my
heart you've truly forgotten what it
means to be an Asgardian save your
sentiments for the halls of Valhalla the
green glad evildoer cackled you'll be
there soon enough and with that Loki
used a charm to turn himself invisible
and vanish completely from Thor's sight
Thor stomped his foot on the ground
angrily he wasn't sure how but it seemed
as though Loki had gotten the last laugh
once again Loki he shouted after his
brother come back here and face me with
honor then the God of Thunder sighed
pensively and thought to himself oh am I
kidding he's never going to change Thor
looked at his trusty Hammer mon your old
friend it seems like we've saved the day
yet again shall we away back to Avengers
HQ he then shook Monier up and down like
a puppeteer simulating a nod Splendid
idea mon glad you thought of it Thor
chuckled already in better spirits
that's when he began to hear the
footsteps of scp096 rapidly approaching
him Thor turned his head towards the
sound and saw the same disquieting
Creature from the photograph that was
inside Loki's Cube zooming headlong
towards him with Reckless abandon the
Asgardian linked he almost couldn't
believe his eyes whatever that thing was
it was faster than Thor could have
possibly anticipated was it looking for
the photograph he wondered hello there
Thor called out as scp096 continued to
make a beine at the Caped superhero the
God of Thunder waved the photograph of
scp096 in the air is this your um selfie
in all likelihood Loki had been his
usual conniving self and stole that
self-portrait from from the miserable
creature hoping that it would mistake
Thor for the thief the god of Mischief
had probably even used a glamour to
disguise himself as Thor when he did the
deed Thor believed that all he had to do
was clear up this misunderstanding and
that he and this strange Beast could go
their separate ways without coming to
blows it was a naive optimistic and
ultimately incorrect view of the
situation but at least the hero's heart
was in the right place I don't need this
so Thor said trying to reason with the
creature you can have it back if you'd
like but scp096 showed no signs of
stopping and was seemingly enraged even
further by Thor flaunting its decidedly
unflattering photograph the shy guy
kicked the ground and shot forward with
a powerful burst of speed one of its
elongated arms slammed into Thor's face
with enough Force to nearly knock the
Asgardian off his feet Thor was so
surprised that he instinctively whacked
the creature with molier sending scp096
kening backwards down the street it
wasn't launch more than a dozen feet
before its powerful arms and legs dug
into the pavement and slowed its
velocity to zero even though the thing
from the photo had taken a direct hit
from molier it barely looked phased on a
physical level one thing was for sure
the shy guy was still incredibly
distraught and it was directing all of
those negative emotions towards the God
of Thunder what was this thing what is
this thing Thor wondered to himself it
was fast strong and durable to an
unearthly degree if this thing wanted to
engage in single combat Thor wouldn't
back down he was an Asgardian Warrior
and sometimes that meant facing
challenges headon no matter how suddenly
they arose still his time with the
Avengers had taught him that having a
clear reason to fight was sometimes even
more important than the fight itself hey
quick question um what are you he said
aloud to the creature scp096 didn't
answer answer within seconds it was on
Thor again like a bil snipe on another
bil snipe the screaming humanoid swung
wildly pelting its opponent with blow
after blow Thor tried once more to
communicate with his unknown enemy I
have no quarrel with you weird one Thor
spoke so take your noodle arms and be
gone for all of its Relentless ferocity
the humanoid Abomination left countless
openings that a season Warrior like Thor
could easily exploit of course most
mortal combatants would be unable to
endure the brunt of the shy guys attacks
for long enough but true to his nature
Thor was a God the Avenger struck back
with another crushing blow from molier
aimed straight for the creature's
sternum once again the monster was
pushed back for a moment and then
resumed its mading Onslaught a blow like
that should have at least busted a rib
or two were the bones of this horrible
thing made of vibranium or some other
rare metal out of the depths of space
Thor realized he was now fighting on the
defensive while he had faced foes in the
path with much greater physical strength
than the shy guy including his superhero
colleague Bruce Banner's mean green ever
loving Alter Ego The Incredible Hulk the
sheer tenacity of scp096 meant that
being careless with his own protection
could lead to Thor taking unnecessary
hits that would eventually wear him down
in a prolonged fight the Ry humanoids
certainly didn't show any signs of
slowing down or tiring even though it
had to be expending a lot of energy to
move so quickly between his alternating
deflections and counter blows against
the creature Thor molded over his
brother's words from earlier Loki was
right about one thing this is a foul
Creature if ever there was one still as
long as there is thunder in my blood I
won't allow a hairless curl like this to
bring me my own destruction think Thor
what would Stark do at a time like this
he says he's the smart one after all
humor him with his highly sophisticated
tactical Acumen that was similar to Iron
Man except for the fact that it was much
better and stronger Thor efficiently
assessed his current situation while the
pale Beast was undoubtedly violent and
far mightier than most terrestrial
creatures its attention and all the
brute strength that came with it had
been fixated solely on Thor since it
arrived in the city the Asgardian best
guess as to why was the photograph that
Loki had tricked him into looking at
devious trickster that he is Loki must
have known that this thing would hunt
down and attempt to pulverize the latest
being to see its face which now of
course happened to be Thor the
revelation of this fact meant that Thor
no longer had to worry about the fate of
civilians if he chose to relocate to a
less populated Battlefield since the
creature was now guaranteed to follow
him nobody else needed to get hurt while
running from the fight wasn't exactly
the god of Thunder's favorite strategy
it would massively reduce the chance of
collateral damage he'd be saving lives
in classic Avengers fashion Captain
America would be so proud not that Thor
would have done it any differently even
if he didn't have The Star Spangled
man's approval scp096 leaped in towards
Thor to deliver its next waling strike
but the Asgardian quickly grabbed it by
the wrist and pulled the Ferocious
creature off its feet he lifted it up
and over his head before slamming it
down hard into the pavement with a bit
of space between himself and his
anomalous foe Thor began to swing molier
around by its leathery wrist strap the
shy guy desperately scrambled to its
feet to resume the attack but by that
time Thor had already thrown himself
Skyward
he soared between the buildings using
the force of mol's trajectory making it
his mission to exit the city as soon as
possible Thor looked down to see that SC
scp096 was following him along the
ground exactly as he predicted it would
well the battle with the Beast would
most certainly continue the second he
dropped back to Earth's surface he could
rest assured that the place where the
Showdown would take place could be
chosen by him he saw an evergreen forest
on a nearby mountain and decided that it
would do nicely as a place to finish
this I'm sure no one would mind a few
stray bolts of lightning around here
Thor thought the God of Thunder was
amused by the prospect of going all out
against this being even though it
probably had its reasons for wanting to
destroy the one that saw its face Thor
was past the point of Taking Chances on
diplomacy this distressing creature was
after all an adversary that Loki had
plotted to send after him through one
means or another and because of that it
was likely to have power and guile to
spare Thor breaking a sweat to Vanquish
the thing would be a fitting replacement
for the fight that he would have to have
with Loki Thor's feet hit the ground on
a Stony Mountain ledge and once again he
struck that iconic superhero Landing
pose remarkably the shy guy had kept
pace with Thor almost the entire time
the Asgardian had been flying smashing
through every tree and Boulder that
stood in its path even so Thor was more
than ready for it storm clouds rumbled
overhead the sky above the mountain was
trembling Ling as Thor decided that it
was time to bring down the thunder on
his unfortunate foe boom crack the
heavens flashed with electrical might as
Thor channeled the energy from several
lightning bolts through molier before
unleashing a Consolidated blast of
unbridled power onto scp096 the shy guy
didn't even attempt to dodge as Thor's
thundershock treatment bombarded it with
light and heat the likes of which few
Mortals could withstand Thor released a
second blast then a third so rounding SC
scp096 with as much lightning as these
Earthly Skies would offer him after
keeping at this for a while Thor decided
to let up momentarily to check in on his
foe only to see that there were no signs
of visible damage on the creature it
wasn't even slightly singed the God of
Thunder could feel his brother laughing
at him from somewhere out of sight and
Out Of Reach the Monstrous humanoid in
the forest below was proving to be far
more than Thor had bargained for but he
was nowhere near ready to give in and
accept defeat
still maybe this wasn't a fight worth
having on Earth all Thor's electrical
attacks were doing was destroying trees
and the planet was already facing
unprecedented levels of deforestation
due to the greed of human CEOs and Shady
entrepreneurs Thor certainly didn't want
to be part of the problem and now that
it was occurring to him he realized that
he should probably try to do something
about that once the situation with the
shy guy was resolved it didn't matter
how close of a friend Elon Musk was to
Tony Stark these overreaching humans had
to be given a Stern talking to by the
God of Thunder with or without hammer in
his hand of course Thor's
environmentalist concerns had to go on
the back burner for now since scp096 was
advancing towards him once again with no
hint of slowing down let's see if you
can follow me back to Asgard you son of
an elf Thor thought he held his hammer
Aloft and counted on hemal to deploy the
bifrost the Rainbow Bridge arrived
seconds before SCP 96's arms would have
reached the Asgardian and as expected it
instantly carried Thor into the
interdimensional space between his
destinations amidst the swirling sea of
multicolored lights Thor shared a laugh
with nobody but himself and mulier so
much for shy guy said Thor looks like
I'll have to resolve those body issues
on its own time I've been through
something similar so I can relate best
of luck pitiful beast but while Thor was
congratulating himself for his strategic
Retreat he almost didn't notice that his
foe hadn't actually stopped in it
Pursuit as a matter of fact scp096 was
currently inside of the bifrost and
swiftly gaining on the God of Thunder
the shy guy was truly running in the
'90s well 90 mph or more but it made the
same difference the creature grabbed
Thor by his ankles and screeched in
mortified rage Thor punched scp096 in
the face hoping to shake it off but to
no avail the two opponents spun through
the bifrost locked together in an
unbreakable grapple until they collided
with the walls of interdimensional space
Thor knew exactly where this was going
and he wasn't happy about it like a
sheet of ice composed of photons the
outer limits of the bifrost broke away
sending both combatants shooting off
into the void seconds later a wormhole
spit Thor and scp096 out in a vast
junkyard filled with the remains of
countless spaceships and alien life
forms great I'm trapped in this garbage
world again I knew I should have picked
somewhere closer Thor shook off the
nauseating effects of the failed
interdimensional trip scp096 was already
hail and Hardy for another round Thor
grimaced with frustrated
anticipation how about a quick 5minute
rest Thor implored the shy guy gentleman
stru scp096 roared and dashed forth more
craze than ever Thor exhaled in futility
I thought not he whipped molier around
and hurled it straight for scp096 is
Skull the reliable uru steel Hammer made
contact knocking the creature onto its
back at the very least Thor could always
count on his signature weapon to help
him out or could he when the Asgardian
tried to call the hammer back he was
shocked to find that scp096 had somehow
grabbed a hold of its handle even more
surprisingly it now appeared to be
wielding the Hammer as easily as Thor
could son of a you're telling me that
thing is worthy the shy guy now with
molier in hand pounced on Thor Swinging
The Hammer with no technique or finesse
it was everything Thor could do to
Simply avoid the creatur's range a blow
from molier was enough to cause serious
injury to even the most formidable
Asgardian Warrior damn you molier we
talked about this Thor thundered we're
friends aren't we but none of his words
could get through to the Hammer now that
it was in the hand of scp096 in an act
of righteous Defiance Thor called The
Fury of lightning into his own body this
strange foe which had come from Loki's
latest prank was about to find out what
happened when a god of thunder got
serious with the speed of a lightning
bolt Thor flew at scp096 and punched it
so hard that its grip loosened on molier
for all but a second and that second was
all Thor needed to reclaim his weapon
his hand clung tightly to mol's handle
as he swung the weapon into the Shy's
body with all of his might the shock
wave of this forceful blow launched
piles of debris High into the air and
sent scp096 tumbling across the surface
of the planet like a thrown piece of
discarded food at an Asgardian feast
with another pulse of electricity Thor
magnetized the portions of the rubble
which contained spaceship parts and used
his manipulation of that same energy to
bury the shy guy in the deepest heap of
trash he could manage and with one last
flick of molier Thor sent himself
hurdling through the largest wormhole in
the sky above and back into space where
it would be far more difficult for his
foe to follow him finally with some
distance Thor breathed a sigh of relief
you almost had me that time Loki what an
on usual being fought like a Berserker
but was somehow also pure of heart a
kindred spirit to myself perhaps even so
I truly hope to never meet that thing
again anyone working at the SCP
Foundation will no doubt be familiar
with SCP 3008 also known as the infinite
Ikea for those of you that aren't it
essentially does what it says on the can
or rather it's assembled just like it is
in the flat pack Furniture instructions
while on the outside it appears to be an
average unassuming branch of the
affordable Swedish Furniture Outlet
inside is a different story crossing the
boundary of SCP 38 automatic doors and
venturing a little too deep into its
mazike confines leads to an endless
Labyrinth of cullins and her dolls a
dimensionally transcendental area that
defies our ordinary human understanding
of physical space lurking deep within
the aisles of the infinite Ikea are SCP
3008-2 that are known as the staff a
race of misshapen faceless humanoids
with long freakish arms that prey on
anyone that enters once nightfalls and
yes there are people inside as SCP 3008
trapped Souls that have wandered into
the wrong Ikea only to end up missing
sometimes spending months or even years
inside if they ever get out at all an
alert was ringing filling the air with
loud blaring noise every member
Foundation Personnel stationed outside
the infinite Ikea was rushing about
guards standing at the ready the
storefront of SCP 3008 had been silent
for quite a long while with nothing
reported going in or coming out but the
foundation knew far better than to
assume that SCP 3008 didn't have
surprises in store for them pun fully
intended hey don't you dare click off we
know where you live and red right hand
are lining up the
shot anyway there appeared appeared to
be some kind of commotion Beyond the
Doors that quickly slid open just in
time for something to be slung through
the front entrance it almost looked as
if the Ikea itself had spat something
out like it was so toxic it couldn't
endure having to keep it within its
confines any longer cautiously
approaching with their weapons raised
the foundation's on-site security team
moved towards the discarded mess to get
a better look at whatever it was it
turned out to be a person a man in
around his late 50s beaten within an
inch of his life he was wearing some
kind of rudimentary ciret or crown
around his head seemingly fashioned by
hand out of stationer and other material
scavenged from the paper shop Department
of the infinite Ikea speaking of the man
was wearing an Ikea manager's uniform
with a name tag pinned to his chest that
identified him as Chris hanging from his
neck was an Ikea branded notepad with a
message message scrolled on it but
before you find out what that message
was we have another important message
for you one that directly impacts you
yes I'm talking directly to you it comes
from the sponsor of today's video
private internet access we know you've
heard a lot of big claims from a lot of
different VPN providers but you
absolutely must hear why we've chosen
Pia as our personal VPN and why you
should do the same unlike the SCP
Foundation and some of those other VPN
services is out there Pia is the world's
most transparent VPN provider they never
record or store any user data at all
don't believe us their no log policy has
been proven multiple times in court and
was even verified by an independent
audit by deoe and they stay transparent
so that you don't have to with pvpn your
IP address is hidden and your connection
is encrypted keeping your Digital Life
protected from the prying eyes of
network admins or even a certain mobile
task force unit and they've just
launched what is maybe their coolest
feature yet with servers now in all 50
US states you can look like you're
surfing the web from exactly where you
want need to look like you're checking
out that SCP database entry from Indiana
they've got an IP address for you there
or maybe you're on the west coast and
want to catch the early East Coast
premiere of your favorite show and avoid
spoilers not a problem with private
internet access I could go on and on
about all the features I regularly use
but why not try it yourself by going to
www.pnc slcp and get an 82% discount on
private internet access that's just $211
a month plus get three extra months
completely for free not long before
Chris was found in his roughed up State
outside the only Ikea that goes on
forever he was working at a different
branch one that was much smaller on the
inside Chris was the manager of the
store and widely regarded by his
employees to be an awful person nobody
knew if he had always been that way or
if instilling him in a position of power
over other retail workers had somehow
caused him to develop a bit of a God
complex either way there was little he
ever did to invoke much camaraderie with
his colleagues whenever any of the
store's workers were on their breaks
which they usually had to remind Chris
were permitted by law and not optional
conversation often turned to their
Collective poor opinions of their
manager he'd been given the job out of
pretty blatant nepotism it was well
known how cozy Chris was with the
regional manager of all the Ikea stores
in the area
on top of that Chris had a pretty nasty
habit of trying to force his employees
to stay behind after their scheduled
shifts had finished while also refusing
to pay them for overtime you see it was
his own mismanagement of the work Roa
that had left the store underst staffed
at crucial moments of the day the
solution you would think should be
obvious hiring a few more new staff to
help with the workload and to start
their shifts at times when others were
about to clock out for the day ah but
new employees wouldn't work for free
their wages would come out of the
store's budget and why would Chris want
to take on new workers as the person in
charge of payroll he could help himself
to that money adding the wages of
prospective colleagues as a bonus on top
of his own unjustifiably exorbitant
salary perhaps the worst part about
having Chris as a manager was that he
seemed to get away with murder as long
as the store kept making a profit then
the management above him didn't care how
badly he treated his employees or
flouted the rules for his own game but
it was those same colleagues who had
suffered and been scorned by Chris's
Behavior who had finally had enough
retail work is hard having to deal with
rude and impolite customers on a
day-to-day basis working long hours of
uninteresting and repetitive labor all
for a paycheck that only just covered
rent like we said it is a hard line of
work and the people in it deserve the
utmost respect but you throw megal LOM
maniacal manager into the mix and you've
got a ticking time bomb on your hands
one that'll sooner or later explode it
was witnessing Chris blatantly framing a
younger member of staff that finally
triggered detonation the kid had only
been a student working at Ikea all
through his weekends to make enough
money to pay his bills Chris saw this
less experienced employee not as a human
being doing his best but a chance to
make a quick Buck by breaking the rules
the manager started stealing cash from
the register then blamed it on his young
staff member when the losses started to
show on the store's monthly Financial
reports seeing that for themselves the
other members of the staff knew that it
was the manager's responsibility to
empty the registers regularly so they
didn't have too much cash in them in
case of a robbery given how much they
all despised Chris it didn't take much
effort for the entire Workforce to
organize a walk out halfway through the
Working Day outraged Chris had tried
calling any colleagues that were off
shift barking at them to come in and
work on their days off all of them said
no the thing is when you work in retail
complaints to upper management never
seem to go anywhere like we said if the
store is making profit that's all they
care about but seeing such drastic
action from the staff of the store he
was supposed to be running the Ikea high
high-ups came down on Chris like a
hammer they instructed that he'd be sent
to another Ikea outlet for a whole
afternoon to receive some mandatory
interpersonal training little did anyone
realize that this was the last anyone
would ever see of him not that his old
staff was sad to hear that he had
disappeared arriving at what looked like
an ordinary Ikea Chris parked his car
outside the place seemed deserted no
customers filing in and out of the front
doors the only other vehicles in the
parking lot looking like they had just
been abandoned by their owners the
manager scoffed to himself these people
running this store were going to teach
him how to do his job indignantly he
clipped his name tag on and stepped out
of his car marching across the asphalt
towards the entrance the automatic doors
gently slid open shutting smoothly
behind Chris as he stepped inside the
whole store was quiet barely a peep from
anywhere the high ceiling of the IKEA
store he so poorly managed carried a lot
of noise and made any sound Echo
throughout the building the squeaking of
shoes against the vinyl floors the
bustle of customers the electronic beep
of cash registers and the L dull music
played over the intercom but there was
none of that here a deathly silence
filled the aisles of flat pack Furniture
display models of hemness and trials
standing as still and forboding as
gravestones suddenly the sound of
movement reverberated from between one
row of aisles Chris began marching
towards its source expecting to find an
employee who would Point him in the
direction of the office where his
training was supposed to be conducted
sure enough within a few steps Chris
spotted a figure in a familiar bright
yellow t-shirt and blue pants the same
uniform his Ikea underlings wore at his
store excuse me he called as he strowed
towards the employee shoes clumping
against the floor with every step you
need to tell me where your manager is
I'm from the store across town here for
some pointless training seminar Chris
hadn't waited until he was close enough
to engage in Pleasant conversation
instead making his demands as he
approached the figure in the uniform
however didn't turn to face him hey I'm
talking to you Chris shouted you deaf or
something there was a pause telling
Chris that what happened next wasn't in
response to what he said although that
didn't make it any less frightening the
figure who had been hunched over near
the floor suddenly Drew itself up to its
full height it towered over Chris it
must have measured close to seven whole
feet as it turned the malignant manager
saw its face or that it didn't have one
no eyes no mouth nothing but a smooth
surface without any discernible features
its arms were elongated huge claw-like
hands hanging down to the creatures
knees being a coward Chris turned and
ran immediately confrontation was
another area his employees had noticed
he was sorely lacking in whenever faced
with a rude and cantankerous customer
Chris would never defend his colleagues
or their actions instead he would suck
up and brownnose two customers who were
clearly in the wrong essentially rolling
over the minute anyone raised their
voice so now confronted with a lumbering
faceless entity his self-preservation
instincts were kicked into overdrive and
he raced deeper into the store not
exactly in the best shape he slowed to a
halt wheezing as he tried to catch his
breath that was when looking around
Chris noticed just how long the aisle
seemed he was sure he would still be
able to see the front door from here yet
couldn't spot the entrance anywhere from
where he was currently standing panting
like a Thirsty Dog he looked over his
shoulder there was no sign of the staff
member he'd encountered little did Chris
know that it had lumbered off in the
opposite direction the second he had run
away from it hardly paying him any mind
at least while the lights were still on
unable to find the entrance or even a
fire door he couldn't escape through it
didn't take long for the lights inside
the infinite Ika to dim marking the
start of the night cycle something about
it being darker made the sounds of
shuffling even more noticeable there
were more than one of those faceless
uniformed creatures trembling Chris
climbed inside a kpad a wardrobe with a
sliding door barely able to sleep with
his knees tucked up under his chin he
spent the entire night inside the
cramped confined space every sound of
movement from outside brought with it
the mental image of one of the staff
sliding open the outer door and reaching
down to grab him the whole Sleepless
while Chris couldn't help but think
about what he could have possibly done
to deserve this cruel fate the next
morning the lights came back on and
started to bleed through the seams of
the flat pack wardrobe waking Chris from
what little Restless sleep he had gotten
he paused unsure if he should venture
out in case he came across another one
of the staff suddenly he heard the sound
of voices muted and muffled by the door
of the kpad but definitely real human
voices had it all been some horrible
nightmare had he fallen asleep at work
and been stuffed into a wardrobe by his
ungrateful employees oh now he had them
he would sue every last one of them out
of their jobs sliding the door open and
tumbling out of the KP Chris found
himself flying face down on the store
floor his legs too cramped to move just
as he tried to will them into moving
again a voice called out to him hey
mister it said you okay there a trio
footsteps raced over to where he was and
before he could get a good look at who
they belonged to hands were pulling
Chris up off the floor he looked at his
Rescuers bemused to see other people in
this endless void of affordable home
wear they were two men and a woman each
in disheveled clothing that looked like
they had been wearing the same thing for
years easy there fella one of the men
spoke name's Buster which settlement you
from what do you mean by settlement
Chris asked confused looks like we got
another newbie the woman chuckled dryly
when'd you get here ah yesterday I think
the former manager answered time can be
a bit screwy in here the second man
chimed in I'm Nolan this here is Janine
you got name uh Chris he nodded you
hungry Chris the three survivors LED
Chris through the winding expanse of the
Ikea without an end navigating The
Identical aisles with the expertise of
people that had been here long enough to
know their way around what felt like the
tiniest fraction of the time that he had
been lost the day before they brought
Chris to the food court who was bustling
with activity more so than the one at
his store with people patiently lining
up to take their fill of food from the
Ikea menu after joining the queue Buster
returned and handed Chris a plate of
Swedish meatballs with mashed potato
peas cream sauce and lingan Berry Jam so
pleased to see food again Chris began to
gluttonously Devour the whole plate
while the others explained some of what
was going on here although he was barely
listening according to Janine who had
been there the longest the inside of
this Ikea was like an endless maze there
was no clear way out even when retracing
steps back the way one first entered
Nolan then weighed in and explained that
there were pockets of people who had
survived this long inside SCP 3008 by
forming their own little communities
thanks to the sheer amount of space
within the store these settlements were
almost the size of small townships built
using whatever Furniture appliances and
other materials the other survivors had
been able to scr up how come you don't
run out of food Chris interjected it
replenishes every day man buster reply
and gesturing to the food court around
them sure it's not ideal if you aren't a
huge fan of Ikea food but you get used
to it could be worse All Things
Considered then what the hell do you all
do for money the stubborn manager
demanded look around you Janine scoffed
we don't need it in here we're cut off
from the rest of the world stuff like
money hardly makes a difference can't
get us home or kept us Fed so what's the
point Chris side evidently frustrated at
the prospect of living inside an Ikea
yet not having the opportunity for
monetary gain so who's in charge he
asked who runs this place well no one
Nolan Shrugged settlements all work
together help each other out if needed
but we don't have any singular person
running things hearing that out loud
caused a twisted idea to form in Chris's
balding head asking to be escorted by
Buster to the right aisle he started
Gathering up what he needed to make a
rudimentary Crown what's that for Buster
asked a little concerned about what
Chris was planning oh you wouldn't
understand he replied not looking up
from applying hot glue don't worry I'll
explain it in nice simple terms when I'm
ready that night despite being welcomed
into the Trio's town of lighting with
open arms Chris slipped back to the food
court while the other settlers were
sleeping carefully he avoided the
lurking staff and their drone calls of
the store is now closed please exit the
building reaching his destination the
malicious manager lay in wait for the
next morning Hiding Out Underneath the
counter where the food was served the
next morning the collected survivors of
the infinite Ikea were met with an
unfamiliar sight as they approached the
food court all the food had gone it had
still replenished overnight like it
usually did but someone had gathered it
up before anyone had a chance to eat
stood at top the counter with a smug
look on his face Chris made a show of
placing his crown over his head morning
everyone he announced from today things
are going to be a little different
around here but I'm sure we'll be able
to work together like one big happy
family holding the gathered SCP 3008
resid as his literal captive audience
all of them hungry and irritable Chris
outlined what he had determined to be
the best system possible for how things
should be run inside the endless store I
will keep all the food secure and safe
and we're going to start rationing it
out he explained what for a voice
shouted from the crowd it reappears
every night anyway well here's what
we're going to do if you just shut up
and let me finish Chris replied calmly
but with a condescending tone of
superiority according to Chris's grand
scheme every day each settlement would
be allocated what he deemed to be an
acceptable amount of ration food to feed
its population of survivors then he made
an offer to anyone who is willing to
help him if someone provided their
services in collecting the food each
morning and distributing the rationed
amount then Chris would allow them to
take an extra portion of rations just
for themselves you see now he asked the
crowd oblivious to how many of them were
scalling at him anyone that wants to
help they get rewarded with a little bit
extra call it a bonus what if we don't
want to help you another onlooker called
well that's fine by me Chris sneered
back more for those who want it I think
what they mean is Janine shouted from
the group what if we don't want you to
implement this ridiculous system at all
what's to stop us from just taking the
food we need every morning like we did
before you showed up typical he tutted
how lazy you just want the privilege of
having more then you should work to earn
it and as for your silly little notion
of just taking I'm going to be here
every morning I'll get to decide who
eats and who doesn't and how much they
deserve and if anyone wants to take more
than they deserve without offering their
help in return then they'll get half of
the rations they would get and so will
their settlement so with those queries
out of the way allow me to introduce
myself as your new store manager when
they recovered Chris's body outside of
the entrance to SCP 3008 the foundation
had no way of knowing exactly who had
beaten him up so badly the other
survivors inside the infinite Ikea might
have done it themselves while
overthrowing his short-lived stint as
manager or they might have decided not
to lower themselves to that level and
instead shunned him from entering their
settlements leaving him to fend for
himself with the staff around every
corner and their history of turning
aggressive towards humans come Nightfall
Chris's chances of survival were slim
the only real clue was the note that had
been found with him which read you can
have him back we don't want him now if
you aren't quite ready to check out of
the infinite I then you should go and
check out life in the endless Ikea for
another tale of a trap soul in SCP 3008
and then if you ever want suggestions on
what to do if you find yourself in the
same predicament then how to actually
beat SCP 3008 the infinite Ikea is the
only Survival Guide You'll Ever Need